SELECT COMMITTEE ON NATIVE
AMERICAN AFFAIRS AND JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE, AND
BEFORE WE START TO TALK ABOUT
SENSITIVE ISSUES, HERE IN INDIAN
COUNTRY, IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, WE WANT TO OFFER UP
A SONG AS PRAYER.
.
WELL, GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU TO
CHAIRMAN HART HERE FOR AGREEING
TO A JOINT HEARING HERE ON THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE FOR
COLLABORATING WITH THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON NATIVE AMERICAN
AFFAIRS ON THIS OVERSIGHT
HEARING. THE SUBJECT OF TODAY'S
HEARING IS WHAT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA AND CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS ARE DOING TO
COMPLY WITH THE NATIVE AMERICAN
GRAVES PROTECTION AND
REPATRIATION ACT, ALSO KNOWN AS
NAGPRA. THE STATE'S AUDITOR'S
OFFICE HAS RELEASED THREE AUDIT
REPORTS, TWO AUDIT REPORTS
REVIEWING èC COMPLIANCE, AND
LAST YEAR'S AUDIT REPORT LOOKING
INTO THE CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM COMPLIANCE AND TO SHOW
THEIR THEIR NEED TO CONTINUE TO
MEET WITH LEGAL OBLIGATIONS
UNDER THE DECADES OLD NAGPRA AND
CAL NAGPRA LAWS. THE FIRST AUDIT
FOCUSED ON THE UC SYSTEM AND WAS
RELEASED IN 2020. IT INDICATED
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES OF CONCERNS
SUCH AS THE LACK OF SUFFICIENT
OVERSIGHT IN DEVELOPING OR
IMPLEMENTING A REPATRIATION
POLICY, INADEQUATE COLLABORATION
OF NATIVE AMERICAN CONTRIBUTION
TO THE CRAFTING OF GUIDANCE. IN
THIS PROCESS, AND INCONSISTENT
IN POLICIES ADMINISTRATIONS
ACROSS THE UC SYSTEM. IN 2022, A
FOLLOW UP AUDIT WAS CONDUCTED TO
ENSURE PROGRESS WAS INDEED
OCCURRING FROM THIS REPORT, WE
LEARNED THAT NO ADEQUATE ACTION
WAS UNDERWAY TO ENSURE TIMELY
RETURN OF THE HUMAN REMAINS AND
CULTURAL ITEMS. THE MOST RECENT
AUDIT WAS PERFORMED BY SURVEYING
THE CAL STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
THE REPORT STATED. RESEARCHERS
FOUND THAT NEARLY 700,000 AND
COUNTING NATIVE AMERICAN REMAINS
AND ARTIFACTS STILL REMAINED IN
THE POSSESSION OF THE CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. THE AUDIT
REVEALS AND UNDERSCORES THE
CONTINUED CONTINUED NEED OF BOTH
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS TO
PRIORITIZE COMPLIANCE WITH
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW. IT IS
ALSO A FAILURE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
REPATRIATION IS A BASIC ISSUE OF
KNOWLEDGE. THE BASIC ISSUE, AND
ACKNOWLEDGING NATIVE AMERICAN
HUMANITY AND OUR PEOPLE'S SACRED
OBLIGATION TO PROTECT AND HONOR
THE HUMAN REMAINS OF OUR
ANCESTORS. SOME 30 YEARS AGO,
AFTER THE INITIAL ENACTMENT OF
NAGPRA, THE ORIGINAL EXPECTATION
WAS THAT NATIVE AMERICAN REMAINS
AND ARTIFACTS WOULD BE RETURNED
TO THE APPROPRIATE FAMILIES FOR
PROPER REBURIAL. ALL NATIONS,
ALL PEOPLES, SEEK TO CARRY OUT
THIS SACRED DUTY, BUT NATIVE
AMERICANS HAVE LONG BEEN DENIED
THE ABILITY TO ENTER THE REMAINS
OF OUR LOVED ONES AND ANCESTORS.
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM WOULD HAVE
AN ISSUE IF THE RESTING PLACE OF
THEIR DECEASED LOVED ONE WAS
DISTURBED IN ANY WAY. HOWEVER,
IT CONTINUES TO ALARM THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND THIS
LEGISLATURE ON THE INACTIONS
MOVING FORWARD EXPEDITIOUSLY ON
THE REMAINS OF NATIVE AMERICAN
PEOPLE. WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD AS A STATE LEGISLATURE
AND AS A BODY. I TAKE PRIDE IN
THE FACT THAT AS A STATE, WE
TAKE THE LEAD ON MANY ISSUES
ACROSS THIS NATION, ACROSS THIS
GLOBE. BUT IN THIS CASE, SADLY,
THE OPPOSITE. WE ARE FAILING IN
THIS AREA TO BE A PRIORITY FOR
OTHERS TO SEE. BUT BY HOLDING
HEARINGS LIKE THIS AND AUDITS,
WE CAN MAKE IT A PRIORITY TO
ENSURE THAT WE LEAD THE WAY IN
THE UNITED STATES AND GLOBALLY.
ON REMAINS BEING RETURNED TO THE
RIGHTFUL PEOPLE. WE CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT
THIS ENDEAVOR IS SOMETHING THAT
CONTINUES TO MAKE PROGRESS
TOWARDS. WITH ME TODAY IS
CHAIRMAN HART OF THE JOINT AUDIT
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU, CHAIRMAN
RAMOS. THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME
AND THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE TO PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HEARING. MORE
IMPORTANTLY, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE OF
REPATRIATION. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT AND EVEN SACRED TOPIC
TO MANY CALIFORNIANS AND MANY
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT DIGNITY HERE,
ABOUT ENSURING THAT ANCESTRAL
REMAINS AND BELONGINGS ARE GIVEN
THE RESPECT AND DIGNITY THAT
THEY DESERVE. I TRUST THAT WE
CAN ALL UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE THIS. IN REGARDING
THE MOST RECENT AUDIT REPORT
CONCERNING CSU AND NAGPRA, I WAS
TRULY SADDENED BY HOW LITTLE CSU
AND ITS CAMPUSES HAD DONE TO
COMPLY WITH COMPLY WITH THE LAW
AND RETURN ANCESTRAL REMAINS AND
BELONGINGS. THE NATIVE AMERICAN
GRAVES PROTECTION AND
REPATRIATION ACT WAS ENACTED
MORE THAN 30 YEARS AGO. NONE THE
LESS, THE AUDIT FOUND THAT MORE
THAN HALF OF CSU CAMPUSES HAD
NOT RETURNED ANY REMAINS OR
CULTURAL BELONGINGS. MORE THAN
HALF OF THE CAMPUSES DON'T EVEN
KNOW THE EXTENT OF THEIR
COLLECTIONS, SOMETHING THAT
FEDERAL LAW REQUIRED TO BE
COMPLETED 28 YEARS AGO. IN
REVIEWING THE ONE YEAR
ASSESSMENT PROVIDED BY THE STATE
AUDITOR, I BELIEVE THAT CSU HAS
FINALLY MADE SOME PROGRESS. THE
STATE AUDITOR FOUND THAT CSU
FULLY IMPLEMENTED TWO OF THE
EIGHT AUDIT RECOMMENDATIONS. CSU
HAS MADE SOME PROGRESS
IMPLEMENTING THE REMAINING FIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS. EIGHT CSU
CAMPUSES NOW HAVE A FULL TIME
EXPERIENCED REPATRIATION
COORDINATOR. THREE ADDITIONAL
CAMPUSES ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
HIRING COORDINATORS. THE CSU HAS
ENGAGED WITH TRIBES AND
DEVELOPED A CAMPUS REPATRIATION
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN. THESE ARE
ALL GOOD THINGS THAT WE ARE
ENCOURAGED BY, BUT THERE REMAINS
A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE, AND
THE PURPOSE OF THIS HEARING IS
TO HIGHLIGHT THE PROGRESS THAT
IS MADE, BUT TO ALSO UNDERSCORE
HOW CRITICAL THE WORK THAT
REMAINS IS AND HOW QUICKLY IT
MUST MOVE FORWARD. I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING THE STATE
AUDITOR'S THOUGHTS TODAY
REGARDING THE CSU'S, AS WELL AS
THE UK'S EFFORTS REGARDING
REPATRIATION, AND HOPE THAT BY
SHINING THE SPOTLIGHT ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE, THAT WE'LL BE
ABLE TO, TO OFFER ENCOURAGING
SUCCESS IN THE NEAR FUTURE ON
THIS CRITICAL ISSUE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, CHAIRMAN HART. AND
NOW GOING TO SENATOR LAIRD.
THANK YOU. I JUST WANT TO SAY,
WHILE I'M HERE AS THE VICE CHAIR
OF THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE, I ALSO CHAIR THE
SENATE EDUCATION BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND WE ADDRESSED
THIS ISSUE IN THE BUDGET PROCESS
THIS YEAR, AND WE STAND READY
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE SELECT
COMMITTEE AND JLAC ON THE
AUDITOR ON ANYTHING WE NEED FROM
THAT SIDE OF THE HOUSE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH, SENATOR
LAIRD, ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND JUST
REALLY THANK EVERYBODY FOR BEING
HERE BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, AS I
LOOK AT OUR AGENDA FOR TODAY,
IT'S ONE OF THOSE WE'VE BEEN
HERE BEFORE, BUT WE'RE MAKING
PROGRESS. AND AS WE START
LOOKING AT WAYS TO ATTACH
DIFFERENT THINGS TO GIVE A PUSH
TO THE CSU'S TO RESPOND
PROPERLY, WE'RE SEEING MORE
COMPLIANCE AND MORE COOPERATION
IN GETTING OUR REMAINS BACK TO
ANCESTORS. BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH THIS, WE'VE HEARD ABOUT
FAMILY MEMBERS HAVING THEIR
ANCESTORS LITERALLY BONES AND
BOXES, AND THAT IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE. AND WE'VE COME A
LONG WAY IN THAT AND ON THIS
JOURNEY. AND I KNOW WE WILL HEAR
MORE TODAY ABOUT MAKING THIS
RIGHT. BUT FOR THE CSU AND THE
UCS, IT IT'S FAR PAST TIME AND
IT'S TIME TO GET IT TOGETHER AND
MOVE FORWARD AND DO THE RIGHT
THING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NOW WE'LL MOVE TO OUR
FIRST PANEL, PANEL TWO
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR AND
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION. WE HAVE GRANT PARK,
STATE AUDITOR GRAYSON HUGH,
SENIOR AUDITOR, EVALUATOR
RAYMOND HITCHCOCK, EXECUTIVE
SECRETARY OF NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE COMMISSION. AND MARIO
PILLERI, NHC LEGAL COUNSEL.
THANK YOU. WE WILL START WITH
MR. PARKS. WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIRMAN HEART AND
CHAIRMAN RAMOS. IT'S GOOD TO BE
WITH YOU THIS MORNING TO DISCUSS
THE IMPORTANT TOPIC OF NAGPRA,
CAL, NAGPRA, AND MY OFFICE'S
RECENT AUDIT WORK EVALUATING THE
DEGREE TO WHICH THE èC AND THE
CSU SYSTEMS HAVE MADE EFFORTS TO
REPATRIATE THE REMAINS AND
CULTURAL ITEMS THAT BELONG TO
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES BY WAY OF
BRIEF BACKGROUND, THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECTED MY OFFICE
TO CONDUCT TWO AUDITS OF THE UC
SYSTEM THUS FAR, THE FIRST ONE
BEING IN 2019, THE SECOND 1 IN
2021, THE THIRD AUDIT JUST
STARTED, I BELIEVE, LAST MONTH,
AND THE FINAL AUDIT IS SCHEDULED
TO BEGIN IN 2026. WITH RESPECT
TO THE CSU SYSTEM, WE'VE
CONDUCTED JUST ONE AUDIT ON
NAGPRA AND CAL NAGPRA THAT WAS
COMPLETED JUST OVER A YEAR AGO
IN JUNE 2023, AND THAT WAS
REQUESTED BY THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE. AS
FAR AS THE GLOBAL CONCLUSIONS
AND FINDINGS IN THOSE THREE
REPORTS, ALL THREE NOTED
NONCOMPLIANCE OR GENERAL
INEFFICIENCIES WITH THE UC AND
CSU'S IMPLEMENTATION EFFORTS
WITH NAGPRA AND CAL. NAGPRA MY
OFFICE MADE 18 RECOMMENDATIONS
OVER THE COURSE OF THESE THREE,
AUDITS TEND TO èC AND EIGHT TO
CSU, AND THE RECOMMENDATIONS
GENERALLY FOCUSED ON ADDRESSING
THE FOLLOWING FOUR PROBLEMATIC
AREAS. THE FIRST ONE BEING THE
LACK OF SYSTEM WIDE OR CAMPUS
LEVEL POLICIES REGARDING NAGPRA
AND CAL. NAGPRA IMPLEMENTATION,
THE SECOND ONE BEING THE LACK OF
PROTOCOLS FOR PROACTIVELY AND
CONSISTENTLY COORDINATING WITH
TRIBES. THE THIRD ISSUE WAS WEAK
OVERSIGHT MECHANISMS TO MONITOR
CAMPUS COMPLIANCE AND PROGRESS,
SUCH AS THROUGH STATUS REPORTING
TO CAMPUS AND SYSTEM WIDE NAGPRA
COMMITTEES. AND THE FOURTH ISSUE
WAS THE NEED FOR BETTER
PRIORITIZING NAGPRA AND CAL
NAGPRA THROUGH THE CONSISTENT
COMMITMENT OF THE FUNDING AND
THE FULL TIME STAFFING NEEDED TO
EXPEDITE REPATRIATION, ALL THREE
AUDITS FOUND SIMILAR CONDITIONS
AT THE UC AND CSU IN THAT
SEVERAL CAMPUSES HAD SIGNIFICANT
COLLECTIONS SUBJECT TO
REPATRIATION. SOME CAMPUS
INVENTORIES WERE INCOMPLETE,
WITH SOME CAMPUSES SUCH AS UC
RIVERSIDE AND UC SAN DIEGO,
FINDING NEW DISCOVERIES OF
PREVIOUSLY UNACCOUNTED FOR
CULTURAL ITEMS. WE FOUND
UNCERTAINTY SURROUNDING LONG
TERM FUNDING AND STAFFING TO
REPATRIATE ITEMS, WHICH IS A
CHALLENGE IN THE PAST, SEVERAL
CAMPUSES RELIED ON INDIVIDUAL
ACADEMIC DEPARTMENTS, SUCH AS
ANTHROPOLOGY TO REPATRIATE
ITEMS, WHILE OVERSIGHT FROM THE
CAMPUSES EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP
WAS AT TIMES LIMITED AND THE
TRIBES THAT WE SPOKE TO ALSO
DESCRIBED INCONSISTENT TREATMENT
WHEN DEALING WITH DIFFERENT
CAMPUSES WITHIN THE SAME SYSTEM,
SUCH AS CAMPUSES USING DIFFERENT
METHODOLOGIES TO COUNT ITEMS IN
THEIR COLLECTIONS OR VARIATIONS
IN THEIR WILLINGNESS TO ABIDE BY
THE TRIBES PREFERENCES FOR
HANDLING CULTURAL ITEMS. SO THAT
GETS ME TO WHERE ARE WE TODAY
WITH RESPECT TO THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA, WE FOUND THAT
THEY'VE MADE PROGRESS OVER THE
LAST TWO AUDITS. BUT AS THE
CHAIRS MENTIONED, MORE WORK
REMAINS. THE èC, IN OUR VIEW,
HAS MADE PROGRESS AND
ESTABLISHING THE SYSTEMWIDE
FOUNDATIONAL POLICIES AND
EXPECTATIONS SURROUNDING
REPATRIATION. AND NOW IT'S THE
TIME TO FURTHER EXECUTE ON THESE
POLICIES AND PRACTICES. THE UK'S
50 PAGE, SYSTEM WIDE POLICY AND
PROCEDURES DOCUMENT, WE FOUND,
WAS DEVELOPED WITH FEEDBACK FROM
TRIBES AND THE NHC, AND THE
POLICY THAT UC DEVELOPED SETS
IMPORTANT POLICY EXPECTATIONS IN
KEY AREAS. FOR EXAMPLE, MAKING
IT CLEAR THAT THE CHANCELLOR OF
EACH CAMPUS IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE OVERSIGHT OF AND THE
ALLOCATION OF SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT THE UCI'S
POLICY ON REPATRIATION. WE ALSO
SEE THE EXPECTATION IN UC
POLICIES NOW THAT THEY HIRE
REPATRIATION COORDINATORS AT
EACH CAMPUS. WITH NAGPRA AND CAL
NAGPRA COLLECTIONS, WE SEE THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF CAMPUS AND
SYSTEM WIDE NAGPRA OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEES THAT NOW HAVE
APPROPRIATE TRIBAL
REPRESENTATION BASED ON
NOMINATIONS FROM THE NHC, AND
UC'S POLICY CONTAINS
EXPECTATIONS ON HOW CAMPUS
REPATRIATION COORDINATORS ARE TO
CONSULT WITH TRIBES. FINALLY, WE
ALSO SEE UC MOVING IN ITS
POLICIES INTO A DIRECTION OF
REQUIRING CAMPUSES TO DEVELOP
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS THAT
SPECIFY HOW CAMPUSES WILL NOT
ONLY PROACTIVELY REACH OUT TO
TRIBES, BUT ALSO INCLUDING
ESTIMATED BUDGETS FOR THE
NECESSARY WORK TO COMPLETE THEIR
REPATRIATION EFFORT IN A TIMELY
MANNER. TO DATE, WE'VE CONCLUDED
THAT THE UC HAS FULLY
IMPLEMENTED ALL OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE TWO
PRIOR AUDIT REPORTS BASED ON THE
DOCUMENTATION PROVIDED BY USC.
UC AFTER THOSE AUDITS, AND I
ANTICIPATE OUR NEXT AUDIT WILL
ALLOW US TO FURTHER TEST THE
ACTUAL IMPLEMENTATION OF UC'S
POLICIES AND PRACTICES AND TO
FURTHER FOCUS ON THE PACE OF
REPATRIATION AND FURTHER EXAMINE
THE CAUSES OF DELAY. ULTIMATELY,
THE UC STILL HAS SIGNIFICANT
WORK REMAINING ACCORDING TO ITS
OWN DASHBOARD, THE UC SYSTEM
CONTINUES TO POSSESS THOUSANDS
OF ITEMS CATALOGED AS HUMAN
REMAINS AND FUNERARY OBJECTS
THAT HAVE YET TO BE REPATRIATED.
UC BERKELEY, IN PARTICULAR HAS
AMONG THE LARGEST COLLECTIONS IN
THE UC SYSTEM, AND WITHOUT
MEANINGFUL AND DEDICATED FUNDING
AND STAFFING TO SUPPORT
EXPEDITED REPATRIATION, UC'S
ABILITY TO INCREASE ITS ACTIVITY
AND FORECAST WHEN ALL ITEMS WILL
BE RETURNED WILL LIKELY REMAIN
UNCERTAIN. OUR NEXT AUDIT OF THE
UC JUST BEGAN RECENTLY, SO I
KNOW GRAYSON AND I ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING DISCUSSIONS
FROM TODAY'S OTHER PANELS, WHICH
WILL HELP US INFORM OUR PLANNING
WORK FOR THAT AUDIT OF THE UC
SYSTEM. AND I ANTICIPATE THAT
NEXT UC AUDIT WILL BE ISSUED
SOMETIME IN WINTER 2025. TURNING
TO THE CSU SYSTEM, OUR AUDIT
THERE, THE CSU SYSTEM IN OUR
VIEW, DEMONSTRATED SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES WITH NAGPRA AND CAL
NAGPRA BASED ON OUR AUDIT, MANY
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE IDENTIFIED
AT CSU WERE SIMILAR ISSUES THAT
WE NOTED THE FIRST TIME AROUND
AT YOU AT THE UC SYSTEM IN
PARTICULAR, WE NOTED THAT THE UC
THAT THE CSU SYSTEM HAD NOT
PRIORITIZED REPEAT REPATRIATION,
PRIMARILY EVIDENCED BY ITS LACK
OF SYSTEM WIDE AND CAMPUS
POLICIES TO REPATRIATE TO
REPATRIATE ITEMS. FOR EXAMPLE,
NONE OF THE FOUR CAMPUSES WE
VISITED FOR OUR ON SITE TESTING
HAD CAMPUS WIDE POLICIES,
INSTEAD RELYING ON INDIVIDUAL
ACADEMIC DEPARTMENTS. THREE OF
THE FOUR CAMPUSES WE VISITED
ALSO LACKED POLICIES ON HOW TO
RESOLVE DISPUTES BETWEEN TRIBES.
ALSO AT THESE CAMPUSES, WE NOTED
THE ISSUE OF LACK OF FUNDING AND
STAFFING TO NECESSARILY
REPATRIATE ITEMS TIMELY. FOR
EXAMPLE, TEN OF THE 21 CAMPUSES
RESPONDING TO OUR SURVEY
REPORTED NOT HAVING SUFFICIENT
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER NAGPRA
AND CAL. NAGPRA AND ALTHOUGH
MANY CAMPUSES NOW HAVE NAGPRA
COORDINATORS TO WORK WITH
TRIBES, THESE POSITIONS ARE NOT
ALWAYS FULL TIME. FOR EXAMPLE,
SONOMA STATE, WHICH IS ONE OF
THE CSU CAMPUSES THAT HAD ONE OF
THE LARGEST COLLECTIONS AT THE
TIME OF OUR AUDIT, HAD A
REPATRIATION COORDINATOR ON A
PART TIME BASIS, WHO ALSO SERVED
AS A STARK STAFF ARCHEOLOGIST IN
THE ANTHROPOLOGY DEPARTMENT AND
AS PART OF THEIR OTHER DUTIES,
MANAGED THE MUSEUM'S COLLECTIONS.
WE BELIEVE REPATRIATION
COORDINATORS NEED TO BE A FULL
TIME JOB, GIVEN THE HISTORIC
DELAYS IN RETURNING ANCESTRAL
REMAINS IN THE CULTURAL ITEMS TO
TRIBES. AND FINALLY, AT THE CSU,
WE NOTED THAT AS THE CHAIRS
MENTIONED, THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF ITEMS THAT REMAIN TO
BE REPATRIATED. WE FOUND THAT 12
OF THE 21 CAMPUSES WE SURVEYED
DID NOT KNOW THE FULL EXTENT OF
THEIR COLLECTIONS, AND SOME
CAMPUSES HAD MORE THAN 100,000
ITEMS YET TO BE RETURNED. BASED
ON OUR SYSTEMWIDE SURVEY OF CSU
CAMPUS OFFICIALS, RESPONDENTS
ESTIMATED THAT ONLY 6% OF THE
CSU'S HOLDINGS HAD BEEN
REPATRIATED. GIVEN THE
CHALLENGES, WE SAW SYSTEMWIDE AT
THE CSU, WE CONCLUDED THAT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE SHOULD BE
DOING MORE TO SUPPORT CAMPUS
REPATRIATION EFFORTS,
PARTICULARLY IN THE AREA OF
ESTABLISHING SYSTEM WIDE POLICY
EXPECTATIONS AND CREATING NAGPRA
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEES. MY OFFICE
MADE EIGHT RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO ARE
FULLY IMPLEMENTED, AS THE CHAIR
NOTED, AND SIX ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF MOVING TOWARDS
IMPLEMENTATION. SOME OF THOSE
OUTSTANDING RECOMMENDATIONS
INCLUDE FINALIZING THE CSU
SYSTEM WIDE POLICY THAT INCLUDES
PROTOCOLS FOR CONSULTING WITH
TRIBES. OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT RECOMMENDATION SHOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED IN JULY 2025. IS OUR
LATEST UNDERSTANDING FROM THE
CSU SYSTEM. ANOTHER
RECOMMENDATION DEALT WITH MAKING
SURE CSU IS MONITORING CAMPUS
PROGRESS TOWARDS COMPLETING
THEIR INVENTORIES. WE UNDERSTAND
THAT'S TO BE COMPLETED AROUND
DECEMBER 2024. ANOTHER AREA IS
FOR THE CSU WE THINK IS
IMPORTANT IS ESTABLISHING SYSTEM
WIDE AND CAMPUS SPECIFIC NAGPRA
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEES THAT HAS A
TARGET IMPLEMENTATION DATE OF
DECEMBER 2024, REQUIRING FULL
TIME REPATRIATION COORDINATORS
AT CAMPUSES WITH SIGNIFICANT
COLLECTIONS. AT THE TIME, CSU
PROVIDED ITS ONE YEAR RESPONSE,
IT WAS ANTICIPATING AN AUGUST
IMPLEMENTATION DATE, SO THAT MAY
OR MAY NOT HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED
BY NOW. AND FINALLY, REQUIRING
CAMPUSES WITH COLLECTIONS TO
IDENTIFY THEIR FUNDING NEEDS AND
SEEK FUNDING AS NECESSARY TO
EXPEDITE THEIR REPATRIATION. OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT CSU HAS
GONE THROUGH A BUDGET DRAW
EXERCISE TO IDENTIFY THEIR
NEEDS, AND THEY'RE WORKING WITH
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW THAT FUNDING
MIGHT BE ALLOCATED TO CAMPUSES
TO SPEED UP THEIR EFFORTS. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE
CSU'S PROGRESS ANNUALLY OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS AS PART OF OUR
FOLLOW UP PROCESS, BUT IN
GENERAL, THOSE CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS. I HAVE GRAYSEN HUFF
WITH ME HERE TODAY, WHO SERVED
AS THE AUDIT TEAM LEADER ON OUR
PRIOR NAGPRA AUDITS, AND GRAYSON
AND I WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NOW WE'LL
MOVE TO, RAYMOND HITCHCOCK.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS
KUSHIMA. I'M RAYMOND C
HITCHCOCK. I'M A MIWOK
ANISHINAABE DESCENT. I'M AN
ENROLLED TRIBAL MEMBER OF WILTON
RANCHERIA. WE'RE THE ONLY
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBE RIGHT
HERE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY. AND
THE CLOSEST PROXIMITY HERE TO
THE CAPITOL. I'VE HAD THE HONOR
OF SERVING AS OUR TRIBAL
CHAIRMAN FOR TWO TERMS. AND NOW
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S
EXECUTIVE SECRETARY OF THE
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION. I'M JOINED HERE
TODAY, OF OUR NINE MEMBER
COMMISSION BODY APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR. I HAVE TWO
COMMISSIONERS HERE OR, EXCUSE
ME, THREE. I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
THEM. AND I'M GOING TO START
WITH YUKI AND ROUND VALLEY
TRIBAL MEMBER, OUR COMMISSION
VICE CHAIRWOMAN, MISS BUFFY
MCQUILLEN. IF SHE COULD RAISE
HER HAND. YEAH. AND THEN WE ALSO
HAVE IN THE HALLWAY, PAULA. BAND
OF MISSION INDIANS, TRIBAL
MEMBER AND COMMISSIONER WAYNE
NELSON AND PALOMA. BAND OF
MISSION INDIANS. COMMISSIONER
BONNIE CLARK. THAT IS OUT IN THE
WAITING ROOM HERE. SO I WANTED
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THEM. I ALSO HAVE
OUR CHIEF LEGAL COUNSEL, MISS
MICHELLE CARR, WITH US. AND
SITTING WITH ME TODAY IS OUR
STAFF LEGAL COUNSEL, MR. MARIO.
MARIO HAS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
WORKING WITH CAL, NAGPRA AND
NAGPRA UNIVERSITIES, MUSEUMS AND
TRIBES TO HELP FACILITATE
REPATRIATION THROUGH THE
ENACTMENT OF CAL NAGPRA IN 2001.
AND YOU HAVE NAGPRA IN 1990,
BOTH FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE SET
LAWS AND REGULATIONS FOR THE
RESPECTFUL RETURN OF ANCESTORS
AND ASSOCIATED FUNERARY AND
CULTURAL ITEMS BACK TO TRIBES.
WHILE THERE'S BEEN SOME
CHALLENGES IN IMPLEMENTATION,
THE NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION REMAINS COMMITTED TO
BUILDING COLLABORATIVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS. THE UNIVERSITIES
AND MUSEUMS, AND THE WORK THAT
STILL NEEDS TO BE DONE TO RETURN
THOSE ANCESTORS BACK HOME. I'M
HONORED TO USE THIS TIME TODAY
TO SHARE THE WORK THAT THE
COMMISSION HAS LED FOR
REPATRIATION IN 2020, AB 275,
AUTHORED BY MR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JAMES RAMOS, ENHANCED AND GAVE
MORE OVERSIGHT, TRACKING,
MEDIATION AND ENFORCEMENT POWERS
TO THE NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION. IT CALLED FOR ALL
INSTITUTIONS TO UPLOAD THEIR
INVENTORY AND SUMMARY
COLLECTIONS TO OUR WEBSITE
DATABASE LIBRARY, WHICH WE
CREATED IN 2022. IN THAT
DATABASE LIBRARY, THERE'S OVER
17,000 COLLECTIONS UPLOADED THAT
MAKE UP HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
ASSOCIATED FUNERARY AND CULTURAL
ITEMS, INCLUDING OUR ANCESTORS.
WE BELIEVE THERE ARE STILL MANY
MORE OUT THERE THAT HAVE BEEN
UNACCOUNTED FOR IN BOTH THE UC
AND THE CSU INSTITUTIONS, AS
WELL AS COMMUNITY COLLEGES,
WHICH HAVE YET TO BE AUDITED.
THE COMMISSION ACTIVELY SERVES
AS A RESOURCE TO ASSIST
INSTITUTIONS IN COMPLIANCE,
INCLUDING PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE, BEST PRACTICES,
TRAININGS AND DATABASE
WALKTHROUGHS WITH REPATRIATION
COORDINATORS. MORE RECENTLY, AB
389, AGAIN AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS, WAS CLEARLY
FOCUSED AT THE CSU SYSTEMWIDE,
AND THEIR LACK OF NIAGARA
COMPLIANCE, AS REFLECTED AS MR.
PARK SPOKE ABOUT FROM THE JUNE
23RD AUDIT, AB 389 TASKED THE
HERITAGE COMMISSION WITH VETTING
AND NOMINATED CAMPUS AND
SYSTEMWIDE REPATRIATION AND
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ADDITIONALLY, THE LAW REQUIRED
THE HIRING OF FULL TIME
REPATRIATION COORDINATORS FOR
ALL CSU CAMPUSES AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A UNIFORM
SYSTEMWIDE REPATRIATION POLICY.
UPON PASSAGE OF AB 389, IN THE
FALL OF 2023, THE HERITAGE
COMMISSION HAS WORKED CLOSELY
AND COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE CSU
NAGPRA LEADERSHIP TEAM TO
NOMINATE CAMPUS AND SYSTEMWIDE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WITH 23
CAMPUSES STATEWIDE AND THE
SYSTEM COMMITTEE, THERE ARE OVER
THERE EXACTLY 168 VOTING
POSITIONS AT THE COMMISSION
NEEDS TO FULLY VET AND NOMINATE
CAMPUS COMMITTEES, WORK DIRECTLY
WITH TRIBES TO FACILITATE
REPATRIATION OF ANCESTRAL
COLLECTIONS, WHEREAS THE
SYSTEMWIDE COMMITTEE PLAYS AN
INDIRECT ROLE. HEARING APPEALS
AND PROVIDING POLICY GUIDANCE TO
THE CAMPUS COMMITTEES. FOR THESE
REASONS, THE COMMISSION HAS
PRIORITIZED CAMPUS COMMITTEE
NOMINATIONS OVER SYSTEMWIDE
FIRST TO ENCOURAGE FASTER
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE LAWS AND
THE RETURN OF OUR ANCESTORS. THE
HERITAGE COMMISSION HAS SPENT
THE PAST SEVERAL MONTHS
DILIGENTLY WORKING ON THIS TASK.
SO FAR, OUT OF THE 168 VOTING
POSITIONS, WE'VE RECEIVED 111
APPLICATIONS, OF WHICH 84 HAS
MET THE STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS.
WE'VE CONTACTED 77 OF THOSE
CANDIDATES FOR INTERVIEWS AND TO
DATE, THE COMMISSION HAS
NOMINATED 29 CANDIDATES TO SERVE
ON CAMPUS COMMITTEES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. THERE IS STILL A LOT
MORE WORK TO DO TO FACILITATE
CRUCIAL REPATRIATION COMMITTEE
POSITIONS, BUT I'M PROUD OF THE
TIME AND THE WORK AND THE EFFORT
OF MY STAFF, SPEARHEADED BY MR.
PILLAR SITTING BESIDE ME HERE
TODAY AND THE COMMISSIONERS THAT
THEY HAVE DEDICATED TO FILL
THESE POSITIONS, THE CSU'S
ENGAGED IN LISTENING SESSIONS
AND TRIBAL CONSULTATION AROUND
THE STATE, AND CREATED AN
INTERNAL WORKING GROUP WHERE
BOTH COMMISSION VICE CHAIRWOMAN
MISS BUFFY MCQUILLEN AND STAFF
COUNSEL MARIA PILLAR ARE ACTIVE
PARTICIPANTS TO GIVE GUIDANCE
AND DIRECTION ON DEVELOPING A
ROBUST AND SINGULAR SYSTEMWIDE
REPATRIATION POLICY FOR THE CSU.
CURRENTLY, THE FIRST DRAFT OF
THAT REPATRIATION POLICY HAS
BEEN CIRCULATED TO THE HERITAGE
COMMISSION AND TO CALIFORNIA
TRIBES TO RECEIVE COMMENTS AND
ENGAGE IN A FORMAL 90 DAY TRIBAL
COMMENT AND CONSULTATION PERIOD.
REGARDING THE UC SYSTEM WIDE
COMPLIANCE WITH NAGPRA, THERE'S
STILL BEEN ISSUES ALONG THE WAY.
IN 2022, THERE WERE SEVERAL
COLLECTIONS NOT REPORTED AND
FOUND IN UC BERKELEY. PROFESSOR
TIM WHITE'S POSSESSION, WHICH
INCLUDED ANCESTORS OF THE SANTA
YNEZ BAND OF CHUMASH INDIANS, A
PART OF A COLLECTION THAT HAD
ALREADY BEEN REPATRIATED TO THE
TRIBE IN 2018. AMONG OTHER
ANCESTORS AND CULTURAL ITEMS.
THIS WAS A DISTURBING EVENT THAT
THE HERITAGE COMMISSION
ADDRESSED WITH THE UC. THE SEVEN
UC CAMPUSES AND THE SYSTEM WIDE
COMMITTEES HAVE MOSTLY BEEN
FILLED BY NOMINATIONS FROM THE
HERITAGE COMMISSION, AS DIRECTED
BY A PREVIOUS STATUTE.
CURRENTLY, THERE ARE ONLY THREE
VACANCIES, AND THE UC DAVIS
CAMPUS COMMITTEE AND FIVE
VACANCIES ON THE SYSTEMWIDE
COMMITTEE, WHICH MOSTLY ARE
NON-VOTING MEMBERS. AS A PART OF
THE SYSTEM WIDE COMMITTEE, WE
HAVE VICE CHAIRWOMAN BUFFY
MCQUILLEN, COMMISSIONER ISAAC
BOHORQUEZ AND FORMER COMMISSION
CHAIRWOMAN MISS LAUREN LARA
MIRANDA SITTING IN THOSE SEATS
TO FACILITATE REPATRIATION
COMPLIANCE. WHEN THE UC ADOPTED
ITS SYSTEMWIDE REPATRIATION
POLICY IN 2021, THE HERITAGE
COMMISSION PROVIDED SUGGESTIONS
FOR IMPROVEMENT, ESPECIALLY IN
REGARD IN ADDRESSING ADEQUATE
FUNDING, STAFFING, REPATRIATION
TIMELINES AND INTEGRATION OF
TRIBAL TRADITIONAL KNOWLEDGE
INTO THE POLICY. AS THE UC IS
REVISING THEIR POLICY IN
RESPONSE TO THE REVISIONS TO
FEDERAL NAGPRA, THE HERITAGE
COMMISSION WILL AGAIN SEEK THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
THE UC AND PROVIDE COMMENTS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS. IN JANUARY OF
THIS YEAR, FEDERAL NAGPRA
REGULATIONS WERE AMENDED THAT
HAD A SIGNIFICANT EFFECT ON CAL
NAGPRA AND WHAT THE COMMISSION'S
POWERS CAN BE. SO TO BETTER
TRACK THE FEDERAL NAGPRA
PROCESS, THE HERITAGE COMMISSION
WILL UPDATE OUR CAL NAGPRA
TRACKING SYSTEM TO ACCURATELY
MONITOR AND POTENTIALLY ENFORCE
THE REPATRIATION OF THOSE
COLLECTIONS. WE'LL NEED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
INSTITUTIONS AND TRIBES TO
ENSURE THEY ARE NOTIFYING THEIR
UPDATES THROUGHOUT THE FEDERAL
NAGPRA PROCESS AND RECORDING
THEIR REPATRIATION AGREEMENTS TO
THE HERITAGE COMMISSION, AS
OUTLINED IN CAL. NAGPRA THE
COMMISSION IS IN PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING DISPUTE RESOLUTION
AND MEDIATION REGULATIONS, WHICH
HAVE BEEN RECENTLY COMPLETED.
TRIBAL CONSULTATION. THESE
REGULATIONS PROVIDE A PROCESS
FOR THE COMMISSION TO CONDUCT
AND OVERSEE ISSUES WHEN THEY
ARISE BETWEEN THE TRIBES AND
INSTITUTIONS UNDER CAL NAGPRA,
DUE TO THE NET FEDERAL NAGPRA
REGULATIONS, THESE REGULATIONS
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
MEDIATION SUPPORT OR COMMISSION
LED RESOLUTION WHEN AN
INSTITUTION IS SUBJECT TO BOTH
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW AND GOING
THROUGH THE NAGPRA PROCESS, WE
STILL DO HOPE TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO HELP FACILITATE
AGREEMENTS AND REPATRIATION OF
OUR ANCESTORS. AS A PART OF THIS
EFFORT, THE COMMISSION IS
WORKING TO CREATE FREQUENTLY
ASKED QUESTIONS BEST PRACTICES
TO ASSIST THE CSUS. THE UC'S
STATE AGENCIES AND TRIBES TO
NAVIGATE BOTH NAGPRA AND CAL
NAGPRA EFFECTIVELY, AND
SEAMLESSLY, AND CLARIFY HOW NEW
FEDERAL NAGPRA REGULATIONS
PROCESS WILL IMPACT REPATRIATION
EVERY INSTITUTION AND THEIR
RESPECTIVE LEADERSHIP NEEDS TO
ACTIVELY STEP UP AND CONTINUE TO
MAKE IMMEDIATE CHANGES TO
FACILITATE REPATRIATION. IT'S
TIME TO GET ALL OF OUR ANCESTORS
ACCOUNTED FOR AND THE
INSTITUTIONS TO DO THE HARD WORK
AND ENGAGE IN THE TRIBAL
CONSULTATION TO GET OUR
ANCESTORS BACK HOME TO THE
TRIBES AND TRIBAL FAMILIES WHERE
THEY BELONG ONCE AND FOR ALL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
SO MUCH FOR THAT, TO BOTH OF THE
PRESENTERS HERE. NOW WE'LL MOVE
IT BACK TO THE DÍAS IF THERE'S
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
CHAIRMAN HART. YES. THANK YOU,
CHAIRMAN RAMOS. I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR, STATE AUDITOR
PARKS IN YOUR REMARKS, YOU
MENTIONED THAT, THE CSU'S HAD
ONLY REPATRIATED 6% OF THEIR
COLLECTION. AND WE HAVE BEEN AT
THIS WITH THE FEDERAL LAW FOR
NEARLY 30 YEARS. WOULD YOU TAKE
A GUESS AS TO HOW LONG IT WILL
TAKE AT THE CURRENT RATE OF
REPATRIATION FOR CSU TO FULLY,
IT'S ALL THAT REMAINS. I, I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION. I THINK
MAKING AN ESTIMATE LIKE THAT IS
INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING, GIVEN
THAT COLLECTIONS ARE DISCOVERED
THAT WEREN'T PREVIOUSLY
ACCOUNTED FOR, YOU NEVER KNOW
WHEN THAT CAN ARISE. AND ALSO
THE QUESTION ON HOW QUICKLY OR
HOW MUCH MORE TIME IS NEEDED TO
REPATRIATE ITEMS IS A FUNCTION
OF SEVERAL DIFFERENT THINGS. HOW
BIG IS THE COLLECTION? HOW MUCH
STAFF IS A GIVEN CAMPUS WILLING
TO COMMIT TO REPATRIATING ITEMS,
AND HOW MUCH FUNDING IS A CAMPUS
WILLING TO COMMIT TO THAT
EFFORT? THIS HAS BEEN A PROBLEM
30 YEARS IN THE MAKING, AND I
DON'T THINK WE'RE GOING TO GET
RESOLUTION WITHOUT BOTH TIME AND
INVESTMENT, TO GET THESE REMAINS
RETURNED TO TRIBES. THANK YOU. I
THINK THAT UNDERSCORES IT. WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH, CHAIRMAN
HART, SENATOR WILK, THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. MR. HITCHCOCK, I WANT
TO FOLLOW UP ON YOUR COMMENTS
FROM. AND I APPRECIATE YOU
CALLING HIM OUT BY NAME. DO YOU,
THE UC BERKELEY PROFESSOR THAT
HELD ON TO REMAINS THAT
ALLEGEDLY HAD ALREADY BEEN
DISPERSED BACK BACK TO THE
CHUMASH, WHAT WAS THE RESPONSE
ON THAT? AND HAS THERE BEEN ANY
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR HIS ACTION OR
INACTION AS REGARDS REGARDING
THAT? SO TO CLARIFY, PROFESSOR
TIM WHITE, FOUND OR HAD
COLLECTIONS IN HIS POSSESSION
UPON RETIREMENT THAT THEY FOUND
IN HIS, HIS, OFFICES OR TEACHING
FACILITIES, PART OF THAT
COLLECTION, IT TURNED OUT, WAS
PART OF A REPATRIATED COLLECTION
THAT WENT TO THE CHUMASH TRIBE
IN 2018. SO IT WAS AN ADDITION
THAT THEY HAD IN THEIR
POSSESSION THAT WERE NOT
ACTIVELY REPORTED. THE
COMMISSION SENT A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS TO THE UC. THEY
RESPONDED TO SEVERAL OF THEM,
THE PROFESSOR HAD SINCE RETIRED.
THERE WERE SOME SANCTIONS, BUT,
THERE'S STILL MORE TO BE
FOLLOWED UP WITH THAT
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE. ALL RIGHT. I
APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER. THAT WAS
REALLY DISTURBING. SO I'M GLAD
YOU SHARED THAT WITH ALL OF US.
OKAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MR. CHAIR, FOR
OUR AUDITORS, I MEAN, WHEN YOU
LOOK AT WHAT HAS BEEN FOUND IN
THE AUDIT AND THE LEVEL OF
PROGRESS THAT THE SYSTEMS HAVE,
HAVE MADE, WHAT KIND OF GRADE
WOULD YOU GIVE THE PROGRESS?
WELL AUDITORS TEND TO DEAL WITH
TERMS LIKE COMPLIANCE AND
NONCOMPLIANCE, AND I'LL TAKE
THAT. SO, SO NAGPRA HAS BEEN IN
EXISTENCE FOR QUITE A WHILE. AND
SO I WOULD GIVE A NONCOMPLIANT
GRADE, NONCOMPLIANT GRADE, YOU
KNOW, I, I FIND IT VERY HARD
WHEN, MANY OF US FIELD MULTIPLE
REQUESTS FROM THESE SYSTEMS,
MULTIPLE CONCERNS. AND IT'S
ISSUES LIKE THIS THAT GIVES ME
PAUSE, TO FACILITATE ANY OTHER
REQUESTS FROM THESE SYSTEMS WHEN
I KNOW IF THESE WERE, AFRICAN
REMAINS. MR. CHAIR, IT WOULDN'T
BE TOO GOOD IN TERMS OF MY
RESPONSE. AND SO WHAT ELSE
SHOULD WE BE DOING? I CAN WOULD
YOU SUGGEST THIS BODY DOES AS A
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT THERE
IS A RESPECTFUL, TIMELY,
REPATRIATION PROCESS? TO ENSURE
THAT THIS GETS DONE? I THINK ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I WOULD
RECOMMEND IS WHAT WE'RE DOING
RIGHT NOW IS HAVING OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS WHERE YOU BRING CSU AND
UC TO THE TABLE AND YOU HAVE
THEM ACCOUNT FOR WHAT PROGRESS
HAS BEEN MADE OR WHAT HAS NOT
BEEN MADE. I THINK, AND UNLESS
YOU CONTINUE TO SHOW LIGHT ON AN
ISSUE, IF YOU DON'T DO THAT, IT
BECOMES RELATIVELY EASY AND
COMPETING PRIORITIES AND FUNDING
TO MAKE DIFFERENT DECISIONS
ABOUT HOW YOU'RE GOING TO SPEND
LIMITED DOLLARS. BUT I THINK
THROUGH OVERSIGHT HEARINGS LIKE
THIS, I THINK THROUGH CONTINUED
AUDITS TO EVALUATE COMPLIANCE.
AND I THINK ALSO, PERHAPS MOST
IMPORTANTLY, THE LEGISLATURE CAN
HELP PLAY A ROLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT BOTH UC AND CSU SYSTEMS ARE
BOTH COMMITTING THE FUNDING
NECESSARY SPECIFICALLY FOR
NAGPRA AND CAL. NAGPRA
COMPLIANCE, AND THAT THEY'VE
COMMITTED THE STAFFING ON A FULL
TIME BASIS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE REMAINS ARE RETURNED,
BECAUSE IT'S I DON'T WANT TO SAY
EASY, BUT ONE LEVEL IS, YOU KNOW,
DEVELOPING THE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES AND PRACTICES THAT
EVERYONE'S GOING TO FOLLOW,
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTING THOSE
POLICIES AND DOING SO ON A
CONSISTENT BASIS REQUIRES BOTH
MONEY AND PEOPLE. AND SO I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE VALUES THAT I
HOPE MY AUDITS IN THE FUTURE
BRING IS AS WE CONTINUE TO LOOK
AT èC, WE'RE EVALUATING THE
MONEY AND THE PEOPLE THAT
THEY'RE COMMITTING TO THESE
PROBLEMS SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
MORE INSIGHT ON THE PACE OF
REPATRIATION AND WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE IN TERMS OF WHEN MIGHT WE
EXPECT ALL REMAINS TO BE
RETURNED? THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE SENATOR CORTEZ FOR
BEING HERE WITH US.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FONG, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VALENCIA, AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR THIS PANEL FROM
THE DÍAS? CHAIRMAN HART. YES MR.
CHAIR, I DON'T HAVE A QUESTION,
BUT I DO HAVE A COMMENT, AS
CHAIR OF JLAC, I READ A LOT MORE
AUDITS THAN I USED TO DO, AND
IT'S NOT OFTEN THAT I READ AN
AUDIT REPORT THAT IS, ELOQUENT
AND PROFOUND. BUT IN THIS CASE,
I WANT TO TAKE GREAT, PRIDE IN
RECOGNIZING THIS AUDIT ON PAGE
NINE, THE REPORT STATES THAT END
QUOTE, IF IT DOES NOT PRIORITIZE
COMPLIANCE WITH NAGPRA, THE CSU
MAY DEMONSTRATE A LACK OF
RESPECT FOR THE LAWS GOVERNING
ITS COLLECTION AND FOR THE
TRIBES WHOSE RIGHTS THE LAWS ARE
ATTEMPTING TO PROTECT A LACK OF
INSTITUTIONAL RESPECT CAN, IN
TURN, AFFECT THE ATTITUDES OF
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK AND
STUDY AT THE CSU CAMPUSES. QUOTE
THE AUDIT GOES ON TO DISCUSS HOW
CSU NEEDS TO HOLD ITSELF TO A
HIGHER STANDARD THAT WAS VERY
MEANINGFUL AND REALLY TOUCHED
ME, AND I APPRECIATE YOU
RECRUITING THESE REMARKS IN THE
AUDIT. I THINK IT ENCAPSULATES
THE ISSUE REALLY WELL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SO MUCH, ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE DÍAS
COMMENTS? THANK YOU. JUST A FEW
FROM MYSELF, WE TALKED ABOUT THE
UC SYSTEM AND THE COMPLIANCE.
CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ON THE NEXT STEP ON THE AUDIT
AND THE PROGRESS THAT WILL TAKE
PLACE? YOU MENTIONED THAT THE
NEXT AUDIT WILL TALK ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION, RIGHT? SO WE'RE
IN THE PLANNING EFFORTS NOW, I
THINK WE'RE AT A PLACE, AS I
MENTIONED IN MY OPENING REMARKS,
THAT WE'RE SEEING, UC WIDE
POLICIES. WE'RE SEEING
COMMITTEES BEING SET UP, WHAT
OUR NEXT AUDIT IS GOING TO FOCUS
ON, LIKELY WILL BE EVALUATING
THE EXTENT TO WHICH WE SEE UC
ACTUALLY FOLLOWING THROUGH AND
IMPLEMENTING THOSE KEY POLICIES.
AND I THINK, YOU KNOW, TALKING
WITH GRAYSON, TODAY BEFORE WE
HAD THIS HEARING, WE'RE GOING TO
FIND THE DISCUSSION TODAY FROM
VARIOUS PANEL MEMBERS VERY
INFORMATIVE AND HELPFUL AS WE,
YOU KNOW, MAP OUT FOR OURSELVES,
YOU KNOW, WHAT SPECIFIC
PROCEDURES WE MIGHT EMPLOY, WHAT
CAMPUSES WE MIGHT GO TO, WHAT
QUESTIONS WE MIGHT ASK. I MEAN,
OF COURSE, WE HAVE OUR OWN IDEAS
ON THE SUBJECT, BUT WHENEVER YOU
CAN HEAR FROM OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS, THAT'S ALWAYS
VALUABLE. AND WE PLAN TO
CONSIDER THAT AS PART OF OUR
PLANNING EFFORT FOR WHEN THAT
AUDIT GOES OUT IN WINTER. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT. AND THEN
ON THE CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
SIDE, YOU MENTIONED THAT SYSTEM
WIDE POLICIES, THAT THERE'S TWO
OUT OF EIGHT, I BELIEVE, AND SIX
ARE IN PROGRESS. CAN YOU
ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT MORE ON
THAT AND JUST IN TERMS OF
STATUS, THE TWO THAT ARE, THAT
HAVE MOVED FORWARD OUT OF THE
EIGHT AND THE SIX THAT ARE IN
PROGRESS. SURE. SO THAT THE, THE
TWO THAT HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED,
WE, WE'VE SEEN, AT THE UC
SYSTEM, WE, WE'VE SEEN THAT
THEY'VE, IMPLEMENTED A
REQUIREMENT THAT THERE BE
REPATRIATION COORDINATORS WHERE
THERE ARE CAMPUSES WITH 100 SETS
OF REMAINS OR CULTURAL ITEMS,
AND WE ALSO I'M SORRY, THAT WAS
èC YOU ASKED ABOUT CSU. CSU.
I'M SORRY, MY I MISSPOKE THERE,
BUT YOU COULD TALK ABOUT UC TWO
IF YOU WOULD LIKE, AT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WE MADE TO THE
CSU ACTUALLY FOCUSED ON THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE, AND WE
THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT THAT
THERE WAS A PERSON RESPONSIBLE
FOR NAGPRA AND CAL NAGPRA
COMPLIANCE AT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE LEVEL, AND SO WE'VE SEEN
A SOME UPDATES AND SOME ORG
CHARTS THERE. I BELIEVE THEY'VE
HIRED, SOMEONE IN THAT ROLE.
GRAYSON, YOU WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT WE'VE SEEN
THERE? YEAH. THE, MY NAME IS
GRAYSON HUFF. I'M A SENIOR
AUDITOR EVALUATOR WITH THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE, AND I DON'T
KNOW IF THERE'S TOO MUCH MORE TO
SAY THAN THAT. THEY HAVE
ASSIGNED A ROLE RESPONSIBLE FOR
OVERSEEING THE SYSTEM WIDE
REPATRIATION COORDINATOR,
WHEREAS BEFORE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE STRUCTURE WAS
LESS FORMALIZED, THEY HAVE AN
ORG CHART NOW, IT SORT OF SHOWS
AGAIN HOW THIS IS ALL SUPPOSED
TO WORK. SO WE'RE SATISFIED THAT
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AT, YOU
KNOW, THEIR, THEIR LEVEL ARE
PRIORITIZING THIS BY MAKING SURE
THEY'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
OVERSIGHT. AND THEN FOR THE
OTHER RECOMMENDATION, CHAIR
RAMOS, WE RECOMMENDED THAT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE SHOULD
REQUIRE EACH CAMPUS WITH NAGPRA
COLLECTIONS TO IDENTIFY AND
ESTIMATE, THE FUNDING AND
RESOURCES NEEDED TO COMPLETE
REPATRIATION, AS THE STATE
AUDITOR MENTIONED BEFORE, THAT
FUNDING PIECE IS REALLY
CRITICAL. BUT IT'S ALSO CRITICAL
THAT THE CAMPUSES UNDERSTAND,
EXACTLY WHAT THEY NEED, THAT
THEY'RE NOT JUST MAKING GUESSES
THAT THEY'RE REALLY
UNDERSTANDING THE RESOURCES THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO NEED TO
COMPLETE REPATRIATION IN A
TIMELY MANNER. AND SO WE
RECOMMENDED THAT THE CAMPUSES
MAKE THOSE ESTIMATES TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. AND WE HAVE
FOUND THAT THEY'VE DONE SO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT. AND
THEN, THE NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE COMMISSION, YOU
MENTIONED THAT THERE'S,
POSITIONS, THAT NEEDED TO BE
FILLED 168 VOTING POSITIONS. IS
THAT CORRECT? THAT IS CORRECT.
AND WHERE ARE WE AT IN THE
PROCESS OF GETTING, TRIBAL
PEOPLE, INTO THOSE POSITIONS? SO
AS, AS WE SPOKE, THERE'S BEEN
111 APPLICATIONS FOR BOTH THE
TRIBAL POSITIONS AND THE CSU,
BECAUSE EACH CAMPUS HAS SEVEN
POSITIONS, THAT WHICH CAN, WHICH
INCLUDE THREE FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBAL MEMBERS AND
ONE NON-FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
TRIBAL MEMBER AND THEN THREE CSU
REPRESENTATIVES, ONE OF WHICH
NEEDS TO HAVE NATIVE AMERICAN
STUDIES. BACKGROUND WE'VE ONLY
GOT 111 APPLICATIONS IN THIS
LAST ROUND SINCE NOVEMBER OF
2023. THERE'S 168 VOTING
POSITIONS OF THOSE 111, ONLY 84
WERE ACTUALLY STATUTORILY
QUALIFIED TO BE IN THAT
POSITION. OUR GOAL NOW IS TO
ACTIVELY LOOK AT EACH INDIVIDUAL
CAMPUS AND FROM THE HERITAGE
COMMISSION'S PERSPECTIVE AND
WORKING WITH STAFF COUNCIL HERE
AND THE CSU'S TO INDIVIDUALLY
TARGET THOSE CULTURALLY
AFFILIATED AREAS LIKE CSU, SAC
STATE. WHAT ARE THE CULTURAL
AFFILIATED TRIBES AND JUST DO
MORE CONCERTED EFFORTS TO TRY TO
FACILITATE GETTING MORE TRIBAL
INVOLVEMENT. AND THE CSU,
BECAUSE WE NEED THESE POSITIONS
FILLED. AND IT'S A IT'S A HUGE
TASK. AND UNDERTAKING THAT, MR.
PALAU IS, MAYBE WANT TO SPEAK TO
A LITTLE MORE. YEAH. AND IF I
CAN ADD ON RESPECTFULLY, THE
COMMITTEES ARE A REQUIREMENT
UNDER THE LAW, AND THERE ARE A
LOT OF MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS THAT
THE AUDIT HAS SET FORTH, AS WELL
AS THE STATUTE HAS SET FORTH.
BUT EVEN WITH ONLY MEETING THOSE
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS, THOSE ARE
THE FLOOR, THE CAMPUSES THAT
HAVE DONE AND BEEN THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL IN MOVING
REPATRIATION FORWARD QUICKLY ARE
THOSE THAT ARE ACTUALLY BUILDING
MEANINGFUL AND RESPECTFUL
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES, WE SAW THAT AT CSU
CHICO AS THEY'VE MOVED A LOT OF
THEIR COLLECTIONS FORWARD, VERY
QUICKLY. AND IT'S ABOUT
EMPOWERING THE TRIBAL VOICES.
MR. JACKSON, YOU ASKED WHAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO, IN
ORDER AS A LEGISLATURE TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD? I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IS LISTENING TO
AND EMPOWERING TRIBAL VOICES OF
LIFTING THOSE WHO ARE SAYING
THAT THERE ARE THINGS THAT ARE
WORKING AND THERE ARE THINGS
THAT ARE NOT WORKING. SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE REST OF THE PANEL
TODAY WHERE WE HEAR THOSE VOICES
AS WELL. THANK YOU. I JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT WHEN YOUR
COMMENT, THAT COLLABORATION FROM
THE INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES REACHING
OUT TO THE LOCAL TRIBES HAS BEEN
BENEFICIAL IN FILLING THOSE
POSITIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE DÍAS BEFORE I
RELEASE THE PANEL? WELL THANK
YOU. WE'LL MOVE TO OUR NEXT
PANEL AND IN BETWEEN I'LL OFFER,
MEMBERS THAT HAVE CAME IN ANY
OPPORTUNITY TO STATE ANY
COMMENTS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
OPENING COMMENTS. BUT THANK YOU.
NOW WE'LL MOVE TO PANEL THREE,
TRIBAL RESPONSE TO THE AUDIT.
WILL I'LL CALL THE FIRST FOUR UP
AND THEN THE NEXT, PANEL, THE
NEXT AFTER THAT. SO THE FIRST
FOUR WILL BE, CHAIRWOMAN LYNNE
VALBUENA FROM THE SEMINOLE
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT, CHAIRMAN
CHARLES MARTIN FROM THE MORONGO
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT, CHAIRMAN JACK
POTTER FROM THE REDDING
RANCHERIA TRIBAL GOVERNMENT, AND
CHAIRMAN LEO SISKIYOU, CHAIRMAN
FROM THE TACHI YOKUT TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND WE'LL START WITH, CHAIRWOMAN
VALBUENA, WHEN YOU'RE READY. I
AM READY. THANK EVERYONE. THAT'S
A WARM GREETING IN OUR LANGUAGE
FROM SAN MANUEL SERRANO. SO GOOD
MORNING, CHAIRMAN RAMOS. AND
GOOD MORNING, COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
SPEAK THIS MORNING. ON A MATTER
OF GREAT IMPORTANCE TO ALL OF US
AS NATIVE PEOPLE, TO SAN MANUEL
AND OTHER CALIFORNIA TRIBES HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND THROUGHOUT THE
NATION. I AM CHAIRWOMAN VALBUENA
OF THE SAN MANUEL BAND OF
MISSION INDIANS. WE ARE A
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE ARE THE
YUHAVIATAM CLAN OF MARIAM, THE
SPANISH CALLED US SERRANO
INDIANS. LIKE MANY OTHER TRIBAL
NATIONS IN THE STATE, WE REMAIN
VERY CONCERNED BY WHAT TRIBES
PERCEIVE AS INDIFFERENCE, AS
EVIDENCED BY THE LACK OF
PROGRESS BY UC AND CSU AND THE
SYSTEMS TO COMPLY WITH THE
NATIVE AMERICAN GRAVES
PROTECTION AND REPATRIATION ACT
OF 1990, OR NAGPRA. THE FEDERAL
LAW REQUIRES THAT UNIVERSITIES,
MUSEUMS, AND OTHER INSTITUTIONS
THAT ARE SUPPORTED BY FEDERAL
FUNDS MUST ABIDE BY THE TERMS OF
NAGPRA ON REPATRIATION OF HUMAN
REMAINS, FUNERARY OBJECTS, AND
OTHER ITEMS OF CULTURAL
PATRIMONY TO FURTHER SUPPORT THE
REPATRIATION OF CULTURAL ITEMS
TO TRIBES, CALIFORNIA ENACTED
CAL NAGPRA IN 2001, THEN AMENDED
IT IN 2020. THE 2020 AMENDMENTS
SPECIFICALLY REQUIRE
UNIVERSITIES TO CONSULT WITH
TRIBES BEFORE CONDUCTING REVIEWS,
CONSULT WITH TRIBES OF
COLLECTIONS OF REMAINS, AND
CULTURAL ITEMS IN THEIR
POSSESSION. TODAY, WE ARE NO
FURTHER ALONG AS OUR ANCESTORS
AND CULTURAL ITEMS REMAIN IN THE
POSSESSION OF MUSEUMS AND UC AND
USC INSTITUTIONS, WITH NO
DISCERNIBLE EFFORTS TO
REPATRIATE REMAINS AND CULTURAL
ITEMS TO TRIBES. THIS SITUATION
IS A AS A VERY PAINFUL REMINDER
TO ALL OF US AS NATIVE PEOPLE
THAT ARE PLEASED TO UNIVERSITIES
FOR THE RETURN OF OUR ANCESTORS
AND CULTURAL ITEMS AS THE LAWS
REQUIRE, HAVE BEEN IGNORED. WE
WOULD LIKE NOTHING MORE TO HONOR
OUR ANCESTORS BY TAKING
APPROPRIATE STEPS TO PREPARE
THEM AGAIN FOR THE SPIRIT WORLD
AND BRING THEM BACK HOME. WE ARE
TAUGHT THAT OUR ANCESTORS CANNOT
REST IF THEY ARE NOT PROPERLY
PREPARED AND SENT ON THEIR
JOURNEY. SO IN 2022, THE STATE
AUDITORS COMPLETED A REVIEW OF
THE UC AND CSU SYSTEMS
COMPLIANCE WITH NAGPRA AND CAL
NAGPRA. AS YOU HAVE HEARD FROM
THE SUMMARY OF THE REPORT, THE
FINDINGS ARE TRAGIC AND SHOW A
COMPLETE DISREGARD FOR THE
RIGHTS AND INTERESTS OF
SOVEREIGN TRIBES IN CALIFORNIA.
SINCE THE REPORT WAS ISSUED,
SAMUEL HAS CLOSELY MONITORED
RESPONSES FROM USC AND UC. THE
CSU SYSTEM HAS HELD TEN
LISTENING SESSIONS ACROSS THE
STATE TO HEAR FROM TRIBAL
REPRESENTATIVES ON WHAT SHOULD
BE INCLUDED IN DEVELOPING CSU
CAL NAGPRA POLICY, SAMUEL
CULTURAL RESOURCES MANAGEMENT
DEPARTMENT STAFF ATTENDED THE
SESSION IN LONG BEACH, AND THAT
WAS ON APRIL 3RD OF THIS YEAR.
DURING THE LISTENING SESSION,
TRIBAL REPRESENTATIVES
RECOMMENDED THAT TRIBAL
KNOWLEDGE BE GIVEN IN A ROLE IN
IDENTIFYING CULTURAL PROJECTS,
OBJECTS FOR REPATRIATION.
REPATRIATION FUNDING SHOULD BE
MADE AVAILABLE TO TRIBAL
PARTNERS TO HELP WITH THE
FINANCIAL BURDEN OF CONSULT
CONSULTATION EFFORTS. ALSO CSU'S
SHOULD ALSO PROVIDE LAND TO
REBURY ANCESTORS AND CULTURAL
ITEMS IF REQUESTED BY CULTURALLY
AFFILIATED TRIBES AND BEAR THE
COST OF THOSE REBURIALS
SCREAMING. BECAUSE WE FINALLY
GOT IN CSU STAFF TASKED WITH THE
WORK OF REPATRIATION SHOULD NOT
COME FROM ANTHROPOLOGY.
DEPARTMENTS SHOULD NOT COME FROM
ANTHROPOLOGY DEPARTMENTS TO
AVOID CONFLICTS OF INTEREST AND
REMAIN TRUE TO STATE AND FEDERAL
REPATRIATION LAWS AS INTENDED,
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WOULD BE
THE MOST APPROPRIATE AUTHORITY
TO ENGAGE IN REPATRIATION
EFFORTS ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY, SO ATTENTION SHOULD
ALSO BE GIVEN TO HOLDING PAST
AND RETIRING PROFESSORS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ALL THE ITEMS
THAT WERE COLLECTED UNDER THEIR
WATCH AND PURVIEW. TOO OFTEN,
CULTURAL ITEMS ARE HIDDEN AWAY
IN THE PROFESSOR'S PERSONAL
HOMES OR STORAGE CONTAINERS.
THAT IS NOT A GOOD THING. THIS
PRACTICE IS HIGHLY UNETHICAL AT
BEST, AND UNDERMINES THE PURPOSE
OF HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
AS A PLACE OF LEARNING. SOME
CAMPUSES MOVE FORWARD WITH
SUBMITTING FEDERAL AND STATE
REPORTS WITHOUT EVER HAVING
CONSULTED WITH TRIBES, AS THE
LAW REQUIRES. THIS IS NOT A GOOD
PRACTICE EITHER, AS IT SHOWS
TRIBAL PERSPECTIVES HAVE BEEN
SOMEWHAT SIMILARLY DISMISSED IN
THE PROCESS. THERE IS A NEED FOR
HOLD AND TRUST AGREEMENTS BY
WHICH CULTURAL ITEMS CAN BE
STORED ON CAMPUSES AT THE
REQUEST OF CULTURAL, CULTURALLY
AFFILIATED TRIBES, EITHER
INDEFINITELY OR UNTIL REBURIAL
OR PHYSICAL TRANSFER TO THE
TRIBE. THAT THAT CAN OCCUR. SO
WE RESPECTFULLY OFFER THE
FOLLOWING RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
COLLEGES TO FACILITATE OR
IMPROVE THE REPATRIATION PROCESS.
PRIORITIZE AND APPROPRIATE
FUNDING FOR ALL ASPECTS OF
REPATRIATION, INCLUDING
SUPPORTING TRIBAL CONSULTATION
AND REBURIALS NAGPRA
PRACTITIONERS SHOULD NOT BE
UNDER SUPERVISION OF
ANTHROPOLOGY DEPARTMENTS, BUT
SHOULD REPORT DIRECTLY TO THE
CHANCELLOR OR AN APPROPRIATE
AUTHORITY WITHIN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. PREPARE
PLANS OF ACTION TO IDENTIFY AND
RECOVER ALL CULTURAL MATERIALS
THAT C SUS ARE ACCOUNTABLE FOR,
TO INCLUDE FULL SEARCH OF
CAMPUSES FOR PREVIOUSLY
UNACCOUNTED MATERIALS,
COLLECTIONS CREATED BY PAST AND
RETIRING PROFESSORS, TRIBAL
CONSULTATION SHOULD ALSO TAKE
PLACE BEFORE FEDERAL OR STATE
REPORTING. CULTURAL SENSITIVITY
TRAINING FOR FACULTY, STAFF AND
NAGPRA PRACTITIONERS ALSO
ESTABLISH A REGULAR CADENCE OF
ISSUING REPORTS TO TRIBES AND
STATE FEDERAL AGENCIES WITH
OVERSIGHT OF THE OF THE NAGPRA
AND CAL. NAGPRA LAWS. AGAIN,
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE COMMENTS ON BEHALF OF
SAN MANUEL BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS OCCUPY. OH YEAH. THANK
YOU, CHAIR VALBUENA. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO CHAIRMAN CHARLES MARTIN
FROM THE MORONGO TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT. GOOD MORNING,
GENTLEMEN, I WANT TO GIVE THANKS
TO YAHWEH YESHUA AND THE SPIRIT,
THANK YOU, CHAIRMAN RAMOS AND
THE MEMBERS OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE FOR CONVENING TODAY
GATHERINGS TO HEAR FIRSTHAND
ABOUT COMPLIANCE WITH CAL NAGPRA
GUIDELINES. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THE
EXPERIENCES OF THE MORONGO BAND
OF MISSION INDIANS, AND TO HEAR
THE EXPERIENCE OF OTHER TRIBES
IN RELATION TO THE NECESSARY AND
OVERDUE REPATRIATION EFFORT.
CURRENTLY, MORONGO IS ENGAGED IN
A ONE CAL NAGPRA REPATRIATION
PROJECT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY, SAN BERNARDINO.
ADDITIONALLY, THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, RIVERSIDE RECENTLY
INITIATED CONSULTATION WITH
MORONGO TO REVIEW COLLECTIONS
FOR REPATRIATION, AND WE WILL BE
MOVING FORWARD IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH UCR ON THAT EFFORT. SO FAR,
MORONGO'S WORK WITH CSUSB HAS
BEEN POSITIVE AND THE FOLLOWING
STEPS HAVE BEEN COMPLETED. THE
CSUSB CAL NAGPRA TEAM VISITED
MORONGO TO SHARE INFORMATION AND
INVENTORY LISTS REGARDING TWO
COLLECTIONS HELD IN THE
UNIVERSITY'S DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES THE TEAM
INFORMED THE MORONGO SHPO AND
THAT'S OUR TRIBAL HERITAGE.
REPATRIATION OFFICE AND CULTURAL
HERITAGE STAFFS THAT THE
COLLECTIONS HAD BEEN EXAMINED BY
A FORENSIC EXPERT WHO DETERMINED
THAT THEY DID NOT CONTAIN ANY
HUMAN REMAINS. THE TWO
COLLECTIONS HAD BEEN ACQUIRED
FROM TWO DIFFERENT SOURCES. THE
FIRST WAS THE WORK OF A FIELD
SCHOOL CLASS FROM SEVERAL YEARS
AGO, AND SECOND WERE ACCEPTED
FROM A CULTURAL RESOURCES FIRM
THAT HAD TAKEN OVER AN
INCOMPLETE PROJECT THAT WAS
LATER ABANDONED. CSUB SUB
ACCEPTED THE COLLECTIONS WITH
THE INTENTION OF USING THEM AS
TEACHING MATERIALS FOR
UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE
STUDENTS. THE MORONGO TRIBAL
HISTORIC PRESERVATION OFFICE AND
CULTURAL HERITAGE STAFFS WERE
INVITED TO VIEW THE COLLECTION
AND TO VISIT THE CURATION ROOM
AND LABORATORIES WHERE THE
COLLECTIONS ARE STORED AT
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY, SAN
BERNARDINO. THIS VISIT WAS
CONDUCTED WITH RESPECT AND
TRANSPARENCY, AND OUR
REPRESENTATIVES WERE ABLE TO
APPROACH, EXAMINE, AND DISCUSS
THE ARTIFACTS WITHOUT
INTERRUPTION, INTRUSION, OR
SAFETY CONCERNS. THE MORONGO
TRIBAL ARCHEOLOGISTS EXAMINED
INVENTORY RECORDS AND CONFIRMED
THAT THE ORIGIN SITES OF BOTH
COLLECTIONS WERE WITHIN MORONGO
ANCESTRAL LANDS. ONE COLLECTION
CLAIM CONTAINS MOST MOSTLY
PRE-CONTACT MATERIALS AND A FEW
HISTORIC PERIOD ITEMS, WHILE THE
SECOND COLLECTION CONTAINS
MOSTLY HISTORIC PERIOD MATERIALS
AND FEWER PRE-CONTACT ITEMS.
SOME OF THE COLLECTION AND THEIR
ACQUISITION WERE PROVIDED BY THE
TRIBAL ARCHEOLOGIST TO THE
MORONGO CULTURAL HERITAGE
DEPARTMENT, OUR CULTURAL
HERITAGE DEPARTMENT IS PREPARING
A PRESENTATION FOR TRIBAL
COUNCIL TO CONSIDER WHEN
DECIDING THE DISPOSITION OF
THESE COLLECTIONS. THEY HAVE
ALSO BEGUN PLANNING ON HOW THE
COLLECTIONS AND RELATED ARCHIVAL
MATERIALS WOULD BE STORED.
SHOULD TRIBAL COUNCIL SEEK TO
RECREATE THEIR COLLECTIONS TO
THE MORONGO RESERVATION. WE ARE
ENCOURAGED BY THESE POSITIVE
STEPS FORWARD WITH CSUB TO DATE
AND THE DEVELOPMENT DEVELOPING
CONSULTATION WITH UCR. HOWEVER
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE ENTIRE
PROCESS ACROSS THE STATE, IT IS
CLEAR THAT NUMEROUS BARRIERS
STILL EXIST THAT ARE HINDERING
FULL COMPLIANCE. THESE OBSTACLES
INCLUDE LACK OF FUNDING FOR
STAFF AT EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS AND TRIBES TO
DEVELOP INVENTORIES AND TO CARE
FOR COLLECTIONS, LACK OF FUNDING
FOR THE EQUIPMENT NEEDED FOR
CURATION, SUCH AS HOUSING,
ENVIRONMENTAL CONTROLS, RECORD
KEEPING DEVICES AND PROGRAMS,
POOR STORAGE CONDITIONS FOR
EXISTING COLLECTIONS DUE TO A
NEGLECT OR A LACK OF FUNDING,
COLLECTIONS FROM SINGLE SITES OR
PROJECTS THAT HAVE DISPERSED
AMONG SEVERAL INSTITUTIONS. LACK
OF KNOWLEDGE REGARDING THE
EXISTENCE OF HUMAN REMAINS AMONG
COLLECTIONS, PARTICULARLY THOSE
ACQUIRED AND STORED BEFORE
NAGPRA LAWS WERE ESTABLISHED,
UNWILLINGNESS FROM SOME
INSTITUTIONS TO COOPERATE OR
REPATRIATE THEIR RESEARCH
COLLECTIONS. LOSS OF
DOCUMENTATION REGARDING OLDER
COLLECTIONS, LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING ON THE PART OF
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS AND
THEIR DECISION MAKERS REGARDING
TRIBAL SIGNIFICANCE,
SENSITIVITY, AND THE IMPORTANCE
OF COLLECTIONS THAT REPRESENT
OUR ANCESTORS AND THEIR
BELONGINGS. PROBLEMS WITH HAVING
ADEQUATE TEACHING MATERIALS TO
USE IN THE CLASSROOM AND
LABORATORY WHEN PREPARING
STUDENTS FOR PROFESSIONAL JOBS,
ADDRESSING THESE BARRIERS WILL
REQUIRE A CONCERTED AND
SUSTAINED EFFORT FROM ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO FACILITATE A
TIMELY, RESPECTFUL REPATRIATION
PROCESS THAT HONORS THE CULTURAL,
HERITAGE AND ANCESTRAL LANDS OF
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES.
TOGETHER, WE CAN BUILD A FUTURE
WHERE THESE PRACTICES ARE NOT
ONLY COMPLIANT WITH LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS, BUT ALSO REFLECT
THE DEEP RESPECT AND RECOGNITION
THAT OUR INDIGENOUS CULTURES
DESERVE. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
ADD, AND LISTEN TO THE TO THE
FORMER, PANEL. YOU KNOW, WE'RE
REFERRING TO OUR AUNTIES, OUR
UNCLES, OUR GRANDFATHERS, OUR
GRANDMOTHERS, SOME OF THEM
REMAIN WERE REFERRING TO THEM AS
BONES ON A SHELF. HOW MANY TIMES
DO YOU GOT TO, YOU KNOW, TAKE
THE IN THE EVENT THAT THEY WERE
GIVEN BACK, THEY'RE GIVEN BACK.
THEY'RE NO LONGER BONES ON A
SHELF. HOW MANY TIMES ARE YOU
GOING TO GIVE THEM BACK? THAT'S
ALL WE'RE ASKING IS THAT THEY BE
GIVEN BACK. FOLKS THAT'S ALL
WE'RE ASKING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. CHAIRMAN MARTIN,
NOW WE'LL MOVE TO CHAIRMAN, JACK
POTTER FROM REDDING RANCHERIA.
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT ESTÁN. MY NAME
IS JACK POTTER JUNIOR. I'M THE
TRIBAL CHAIRMAN OF REDDING
RANCHERIA, AND I'M HERE TODAY,
AND I HEARD THE PREVIOUS PANEL
AND IT KIND OF BOTHERS ME
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE IT GOES
BACK TO MONEY, AND IT MAKES ME
THINK HOW MANY TIMES IS MONEY
GOING TO BE ALLOCATED FOR OUR
PEOPLE? IN THE BEGINNING OF THIS
STATE, $5 BOUNTIES WERE PUT ON
THE HEADS OF OUR MALES, AND
$1.50 BOUNTIES ON OUR FEMALES
AND OUR CHILDREN. THESE ARE THE
ANCESTORS WE'RE TRYING TO GET
BACK TODAY. AND NOW THE CSU'S
AND UC'S WANT MORE MONEY TO
RETURN THEM TO US. IT'S A MATTER
OF HEART. THEY SHOULD JUST HAND
THEM OVER. THEY KNOW WHERE THEY
CAME FROM. IT SHOULDN'T TAKE SO
MUCH MONEY. CHICO STATE
UNIVERSITY HAS PROVED THAT THEY
WERE ONE OF THE WORST OFFENDERS.
AND, THEY ARE ONE OF THE BEST
ONES IN COMPLIANCE. NOW BECAUSE
THEY HAVE FULLY GOT ON BOARD
WITH WHAT THEY HAD WITHOUT
SEEKING FUTURE MONETARY
CONTRIBUTIONS OR ANYTHING. AND I
BELIEVE THAT IT'S BECAUSE THE
LEADERSHIP THERE HAS A HEART AND
THEY UNDERSTAND THE CONNECTION
WITH TRIBAL PEOPLE. AND I'M NOT
SPEAKING AGAINST OTHER
NATIONALITIES BECAUSE I DON'T
KNOW THEIR WAYS, THEIR BURIAL
PRACTICES OR THINGS. BUT WITH
NATIVE PEOPLE, THERE ARE CERTAIN
THINGS WE HAVE TO DO. AS I'M IN
MOURNING RIGHT NOW, MY HAIR IS
SHORT. I LOST A SISTER AND SO WE
DO THOSE THINGS. WE REMOVE OUR
HAIR SO WE DON'T DREAM OF OUR
DECEASED PERSONS TO ALLOW THEM
TO TRAVEL SO THEY HAVE SMOOTH
TRANSITION. AND MY GRANDFATHER,
HE WAS THE MEDICINE MAN FOR THE
PIT RIVER TRIBE, AND HE HAD
DREAMS. AND HE SAID ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY SO MANY OF OUR
PEOPLE HAVE ALCOHOL PROBLEMS OR
DRUG PROBLEMS, BECAUSE THEY HEAR
THE SPIRITS OF THOSE THAT ARE ON
THESE SHELVES CALLING OUT TO
THEM. WE HAVE FAMILY
CONNECTIONS, AND WE DON'T HAVE
TO KNOW THAT PERSON BECAUSE YOUR
BLOODLINE FROM THE BEGINNING OF
TIME HAS YOU CONNECTED TO
EVERYONE. AND SO THOSE FAMILY
LINES, THEY'RE CALLING OUT TO
THEIR ONES THAT ARE HERE TODAY
ASKING THEM, PLEASE GET ME HOME,
BRING ME HOME. AND IT BOTHERS ME
BECAUSE I DON'T NEED TO TURN TO
DRUGS OR ALCOHOL, BUT I HEAR
THOSE CRIES MY ANCESTORS SPEAK
TO ME ON A DAILY BASIS, AND THEN
TO BE HERE TO HAVE TO SPEAK
BEFORE PEOPLE I'M GLAD, AND I'M
THANKFUL FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS FOR BRINGING THIS TO
LIGHT. BUT IT'S BEEN IN THE
MAKING FOR OVER 30 YEARS, AND IT
SHOULDN'T TAKE 30 YEARS TO HAVE
OUR PEOPLE BROUGHT HOME. JUST
USE YOUR HEART. CSU AND UC
SYSTEM. YOU HAVE THOSE LIST. GET
A HOLD OF THOSE TRIBES AND HAND
THEM OVER. THANK YOU, THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU, CHAIRMAN POTTER,
FOR THAT. NEXT, WE'LL MOVE TO
CHAIRMAN LEO SISKIYOU, CHAIR OF
THE TACHI YOKUT TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
RAMOS. COMMITTEE MEMBERS, MY
NAME IS LEO CISCO. I HAVE THE
HONOR TO REPRESENT MY PEOPLE OF
THE SANTA ROSA RANCHERIA.
TAKAOKA TRIBE, WE'RE AT THE
HEART OF THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
JUST THREE HOURS SOUTH OF HERE.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
INVITING OUR NATIONS HERE AND
FOR THE FOLLOW UP ON THIS
MATTER. I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
IT. GIVING THE UTMOST RESPECT
AND ATTENTION OUR ANCESTORS
DESERVE THIS ISSUE NOT ONLY
AFFECTS OUR COMMUNITIES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, BUT AFFECTS TRIBES
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AGAIN, I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK, ASSEMBLYMAN
RAMOS AND THE ENTIRE LEGISLATURE
FOR YOUR UNWAVERING SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THIS THIS IS A
CRUCIAL STEP TOWARD THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND COMPLIANCE
WITH NAGPRA AND CAL NAGPRA BY
THE CSU SYSTEM. MANY FACTORS
HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO THE CSU
SYSTEM, MAKING LITTLE PROGRESS
IN THE TIMELY RETURN OF OUR
HUMAN REMAINS AND CULTURAL ITEMS
TO OUR RESPECTIVE TRIBES. THEY
GENERALLY LACK POLICIES,
FUNDING, AND STAFFING NECESSARY
TO FOLLOW THE LAW AND REPATRIATE
THEIR COLLECTIONS. SOME DO NOT
EVEN KNOW THE EXTENT OF THEIR
COLLECTIONS OF OUR ANCESTORS
REMAINS AND CULTURAL ITEMS.
DESPITE FEDERAL AND STATE LAW
REQUIREMENTS, THE FACT THAT
LITTLE TO NO PROGRESS HAS BEEN
MADE IN REPATRIATING OUR
ANCESTORS FUNERARY OBJECTS AND
CULTURAL ITEMS OVER THE PAST 34
YEARS, SINCE FEDERAL NAGPRA WAS
ENACTED IN 1990, IS INEXCUSABLE,
AND IT'S UNACCEPTABLE. THE
BIGGEST FACTOR HERE IS OUR
ANSWERS. OUR ANCESTORS AND THEIR
BELONGINGS WERE NOT A PRIORITY.
AGAIN, THAT'S THE PROBLEM. OUR
PEOPLE WERE NOT GIVEN A PRIORITY.
NAGPRA WAS NOT GIVEN A PRIORITY.
WE WERE GIVEN A PRIORITY. OUR
TRIBE RECENTLY FROM THE CHICAGO
FIELD MUSEUM, AND WE RECEIVED
MANY OF OUR ANCESTORS
BELONGINGS. AND I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF BEING IN THE ROOM
WITH OUR BELONGINGS BEFORE THEY
CAME HOME. AND YOU COULD FEEL
THE ENERGY, YOU COULD FEEL THE
HAPPY THAT THEY'RE THEIR
DESCENDANTS WERE THERE. YOU
KNOW, WE FELT THAT WE FELT WE
FELT THE GOOD ENERGY. AND THAT'S
WHAT THE ONE THING THAT CSU AND
èC WILL NOT UNDERSTAND, A PART
OF OUR CULTURE. WE FEEL OUR
ANCESTORS, YOU KNOW, THEY ARE
NOT SCIENCE PROJECTS. YOU KNOW,
OUR ANCESTORS CARRY VALUES
STORIES AND WE WANT TO BRING
THOSE STORIES AND THOSE VALUES
HOME. AND IT'S SAD THAT THIS
CRIME CAN BE PRACTICED PUBLICLY.
AND IT TAKES AN AUDIT. IT TAKES
INTERVENTION BY OUTSIDERS TO
MAKE THIS RIGHT. YOU KNOW, WE
HAD OUR LAST MEETING AT FIRE
MOUNTAIN'S FIRE MOUNTAIN AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS ORGANIZED
THAT. AND WE DISCUSSED THE
FINDINGS OF THE AUDIT AND CAL
STATE CHICO, AGAIN, ONE OF THE
WORST ONES MADE TREMENDOUS
PROGRESS IN REPATRIATION
DESPITE, QUOTE UNQUOTE, LACK OF
FUNDING. NOW, IF THEY CAN DO
THIS, DESPITE THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCES, WHO'S TO SAY THAT
THE REST OF THE CSU SYSTEM COULD
NOT DO THE SAME? AGAIN, NOT A
PRIORITY. THE ANCESTRAL REMAINS
AND CULTURAL ITEMS BEING HELD IN
THESE INVENTORIES ARE VITAL IN
PRESERVING OUR NATIVE AMERICAN
CULTURE, HISTORY AND SHOULD BE
REPATRIATED TO THEIR RESPECTIVE
TRIBAL NATIONS AS LAWS REQUIRE.
IT IS TIME TO MAKE THINGS RIGHT
AND BRING OUR PEOPLE HOME WHERE
THEY RIGHTFULLY BELONG. NOW,
WHEN IT COMES TO OUR FUTURE
GENERATIONS, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
STRESSED THE IMPORTANCE OF
EDUCATION TO OUR YOUTH, AND WE
ENCOURAGE THEM TO ATTEND THESE
INSTITUTES OF HIGHER LEARNING.
AGAIN ARE THEY GOING TO TELL OUR
YOUTH OR THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE ENOUGH RESPECT FOR OUR
ANCESTORS? THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE RESPECT FOR THEM BECAUSE
THEY COME FROM THE SAME BLOOD.
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE NOT BAG OF
BONES SITTING IN BOXES. THERE
ARE PEOPLE. AND THOSE ARE THE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO EXPLAIN
TO OUR YOUTH. ARE WE LYING TO
THEM? YES, WE ARE. AS TRIBAL
LEADERS, I AM ASHAMED TO SAY
THAT I AM LYING TO THEM BECAUSE
I WANT THEM TO GO TO FURTHER
THEIR EDUCATION. BUT THE PLACES
I WANT THEM TO GO ARE DOING
STUFF LIKE THIS TO OUR PEOPLE.
SO WE ASK THAT YOU GIVE US, GIVE
US THE OPPORTUNITY TO HEAL AND
OUR TRIBE, JUST LIKE MANY OF THE
TRIBES IN THIS ROOM, ALL NATIONS
WILL REMAIN COMMITTED AND SEE
THIS THROUGH TO THE VERY END.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THOSE COMMENTS IN
THIS PANEL AND YOUR TESTIMONY.
IS THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
DAIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHARON
QUIRK-SILVA, IT'S REALLY MORE OF
A COMMENT, BUT FIRST, I WANT TO
THANK, ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
HEARTFELT, COMMENTS. SOMETIMES
WHEN YOU'RE IN A LEGISLATIVE
POSITION, WE GET A LOT OF
INFORMATION OVER A PERIOD OF
TIME. AND THIS IS NOW MY 10TH
YEAR BEING A LEGISLATOR. ALSO
I'M AN EDUCATOR, AND I
REPRESENT, FULLERTON, WHICH IS
THE HOME OF CAL STATE FULLERTON.
AND YOU TAKE A LOT OF
INFORMATION IN AND THEN THERE
BECOMES AN MOMENT. AND THE
MOMENT IS RIGHT NOW RIGHT HERE
AT THIS MOMENT. AND THIS IS WE
CAN GET DOCUMENTS AND DOCUMENTS,
AND WE HAVE A WHOLE FOLDER HERE
FILLED OF REPORTS AND
INFORMATION, BUT IT'S MUCH
SIMPLER AND IT'S AS SIMPLE AS
YOU SAID. IT'S ABOUT THE WILL,
ABOUT THE SIMPLE WILL TO DO WHAT
IS RIGHT, TO BRING HOME YOUR
ANCESTORS IN A TIMELY FASHION.
IT IS UNCONSCIONABLE THAT WE'VE
HAD TO HAVE SEVERAL AUDITS NOW
OVER A 30 YEAR PERIOD WHEN THE
LAW HAS BEEN THERE, BUT WHEN YOU
RUN MAJOR INSTITUTIONS, WHETHER
IT'S A CSU OR A UC SYSTEM, THERE
ARE PRIORITIES AND THERE'S
HUNDREDS OF PRIORITIES. AND
UNLESS WE MAKE THIS A NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY AND SAY WE'RE NOT GOING
TO ACCEPT THESE DELAYS, WE'RE
NOT GOING TO ACCEPT THESE
EXCUSES, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
ACCEPT THAT WE CAN'T DO
SOMETHING BECAUSE CHICO IS
EXAMPLE OF WHAT YOU CAN DO WHEN
YOU MAKE THAT INTENTIONAL
DECISION TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT. SO
I'M VERY HAPPY TO HEAR THE REST
OF THE PRESENTERS. I MAY HAVE TO
LEAVE, BUT WHAT I WOULD SAY IS
IT IS NO MORE EXCUSES. LET'S DO
THIS. IT IS NOT COMPLICATED.
IT'S Þ. SADLY, I WAS REALLY IN
ONE OF THE DOCUMENTS PRESENTED,
AND AGAIN, MY FAVORITE
CHANCELLOR IS HERE, BUT I WAS
REALLY, PRETTY, SADDENED TO READ
THE REPORT OF CAL STATE
FULLERTON THAT WAS MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE BROAD, TYPE OF,
PLAN TO HOUSE THESE COLLECTIONS
AND REALLY PAY TRIBUTE. AND THEN
BECAUSE OF A HIRING PRACTICE,
THEY REMOVED TWO INDIVIDUALS WHO
WERE SPEARHEADING AND SAID,
WELL, NOW, YOU KNOW, THIS IS
OKAY BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO BE
BETTER. BUT THE POINT IS, WHEN
YOU DELAY, WHEN YOU CHANGE
LEADERSHIP, THIS CAUSES TIME.
AND I SAT ON THIS EXACT AUDIT
TWO YEARS AGO WITH YOU AS WE
BROUGHT THIS AND OTHERS OF US
HAVE. SO, SIMPLY NO MORE DELAYS.
IT'S TIME FOR RESPECT IN RETURN.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS. ARE THERE ANY
OTHERS WISHING TO COMMENT? WELL,
I WANT TO THANK YOU, FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND REALLY TALKING
ABOUT THE TRIBAL CONSULTATION
BEFORE, REPORTS GO OUT TO THE
FEDERAL OR TO THE STATE AREA OF
COMPLIANCE WITH THE INSTITUTIONS
THAT WAS BROUGHT UP. I THINK
THAT THAT NEEDS TO, RESONATE
RIGHT, THAT WE NEED TO HAVE THE
INPUT OF TRIBAL PEOPLE PRIOR TO
ANY REPORTS GOING OUT, AND
TALKING ABOUT THE FIELD SCHOOL
AND THE INCOMPLETE PROJECT WHERE
REMAINS ARE, SHEDS A LIGHT TO
HOW THESE REMAINS END UP IN
ARCHIVES, WHERE THEY'RE AT NOW
OF OUR OF OUR LOVED ONES, THAT
IT'S DURING FIELD SCHOOLS, FIELD
SCHOOLS THAT WERE IMPLEMENTED,
THROUGH SCHOOLS, UCS, CAL STATES
AND EVEN PRIVATE FIELD SCHOOLS
THAT WILL GO OUT THERE AND,
EXCAVATE AND FIND REMAINS OF OUR
PEOPLE. AND WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT COMPONENT ALSO IS
ADDRESSED SO THAT WE START TO BE
MORE PROACTIVE BEFORE THESE
REMAINS ARE EVEN UNCOVERED, AND
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT UP.
AND CHAIRMAN POTTER, THE
REMAINS, THAT WE TALK ABOUT, AND
THE LOVED ONES THAT ARE THERE,
YOU MENTIONED IT SHOULD BE A
MATTER OF HEART OF COMPLYING. WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO HAVE AUDITS
AND HEARINGS AND TALK ABOUT
FUNDING THESE THINGS. IT SHOULD
BE THE PROPER THING TO DO IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS,
RETURNING REMAINS OF OUR PEOPLE,
OF OUR LOVED ONES. SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT, CHAIRMAN SISKIYOU, YOU
BRING UP AN AREA, ANOTHER AREA
THAT THIS BODY, IN THE SELECT
COMMITTEE HAVE, ADDRESSED WAS
EDUCATION ATTAINMENT. AND WE
MOVED PIECES OF LEGISLATION IN
THOSE ARENAS. BUT YOU BRING UP
A, A STATEMENT THAT I THINK
NEEDS TO RESONATE. HOW CAN WE
TELL OUR KIDS, HOW COULD WE EVEN
OURSELVES GO TO A CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY OR A UC WHEN FROM THE
TOP LEVEL DOWN, THEY HAVEN'T HAD
RESPECT FOR OUR ANCESTORS, SO IT
GOES DEEP. AND I THINK WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT REPATRIATION AND WE
TALK ABOUT, REMAINS OF LOVED
ONES THAT ARE THERE, WE CAN'T
JUST STOP THERE. IT GOES DEEPER
THAN THAT IN THE HISTORICAL
TRAUMA THAT WE HAVE TO NOW MOVE
FORWARD AND TELLING OUR KIDS TO
PURSUE A HIGHER EDUCATION. SO
IT'S TIME THAT THAT WE DO COME
TOGETHER AS A STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY, THE CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM, THE UC SYSTEM, AND START
TO BRING, AN END TO THIS
PRACTICE SO THAT WE CAN
HONORABLY, MOVE OUR KIDS INTO
HIGHER EDUCATION. THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THAT COMPONENT INTO THE
EQUATION. I WANT TO THANK EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF YOU AS NOW WE
MOVE TO THE, OTHER PRESENTERS
HERE WITHIN THE TRIBAL RESPONSE
AUDIT. LARA LEE ROSS, VICE
CHAIR, FEDERATED INDIANS OF
GRATON TRIBAL GOVERNMENT. BUFFY
MCEWEN, TRIBAL HERITAGE
PRESERVATION OFFICER OF THE
FEDERATED INDIANS OF GRATON
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT AND CATALINA
CHACON, COUNCIL MEMBER OF THE
PECHANGA TRIBAL GOVERNMENT.
HEY. AND WE'LL START WITH,
LAURALEE ROSS, VICE CHAIR OF THE
FEDERATED INDIAN GREAT AND
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT. HI. GOOD
MORNING, MY NAME IS PRONOUNCED
LAUREL ROSS. IT'S A LITTLE
DIFFERENT. APOLOGIES. NO. NO
WORRIES. I WOULD LIKE TO FIRST
START OFF WITH A THANK YOU, AND
FOR STARTING OFF TODAY WITH A
PRAYER SONG, I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE ARE HERE ON
THE LAND OF THE WILTON TRIBAL
NATION. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
RAMOS. AND MEMBERS OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE AND
THE ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS. I AM
LAUREL ROSS. I AM THE VICE CHAIR
EMERITUS OF THE FEDERATED
INDIANS OF GRATON RANCHERIA,
HAVING SERVED 28 YEARS ON TRIBAL
COUNCIL, I AM REPRESENTING MY
TRIBE OFFICIALLY TODAY. I ALSO
SERVE AS THE CHAIR OF THE UC
PRESIDENT'S NATIVE AMERICAN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE, AND I'M A
MEMBER OF THE SONOMA STATE
UNIVERSITY CAMPUS COMMITTEE FOR
CAL, NAGPRA AND NAGPRA
COMPLIANCE. I AM SPEAKING TODAY
ON BEHALF OF TRIBAL CHAIRMAN
GREG SARRIS AND THE TRIBAL
COUNCIL, THE FEDERATED INDIANS
OF GRATON RANCHERIA IS A TRIBE
COMPRISED OF SOUTHERN POMO AS
WELL AS COAST MIWOK. FROM OUR
ABORIGINAL AND CULTURALLY
TRADITIONAL LANDS OF SONOMA AND
MARIN COUNTY. OUR RESERVATION IS
IN SONOMA COUNTY. I GREW UP ON
WHAT WAS THE HISTORICAL
RANCHERIA WHERE MY MOM STILL
RESIDES. SONOMA STATE UNIVERSITY
SITS ON OUR ABORIGINAL TERRITORY
AS DOES MANY COMMUNITY COLLEGES,
PRIVATE COLLEGES AND MUSEUMS
WITHIN OUR ABORIGINAL TERRITORY.
DUE TO THE URGENCY THAT WAS
SHARED LAST YEAR AT THE AUDIT
OVERSIGHT HEARING IN AUGUST, THE
PROCESS HAS BEEN SLOW AND
CUMBERSOME AS THE CSU HAS TRIED
TO ACHIEVE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
DIRECTIVES OF AB 38. WHILE I WAS
NOMINATED AND APPOINTED TO SERVE
ON THE CSU UNIVERSITY CAMPUS
COMMITTEE, THE PATH TO GET THERE
WAS SLOW AND BUREAUCRATIC. THE
PRESIDENT OF CSU RESIGNED.
LEADERSHIP IS NEEDED TO MOVE THE
CSU CAMPUS COMMITTEE FORWARD AND
TO ACHIEVE THE OBJECTIVES OF
CAL. NAGPRA AND NAGPRA. TRIBES
ARE FACED WITH INSTITUTIONAL
BUREAUCRACY COUPLED WITH
CHALLENGES FOLLOWING QUALIFIED
FINDING QUALIFIED APPLICANTS WHO
ARE SUITABLE TO SERVE ON THE
CSU, WHO ARE NOT CSU EMPLOYEES
WHO ARE CONFLICTED OR HAVE
POTENTIAL CONFLICTS, ALL OF
WHICH SLOWS DOWN COMPLIANCE. THE
CSU HAS, SEATS AVAILABLE
REMAINING. THERE STILL IS A CSU
SYSTEM WIDE COMMITTEE THAT HAS
NOT BEEN FORMED FORMALLY.
FURTHER AB 389 REQUIRES CAMPUSES
TO HAVE A FULL TIME, EXPERIENCED
REPATRIATION COORDINATORS, AS
WELL AS A SYSTEM WIDE
COORDINATOR. BY JULY 1ST OF
2024, ADRIAN TAFOYA, THE CSU CAL
NAGPRA PROJECT MANAGER, HAS BEEN
HIRED AND IS MAKING SIGNIFICANT
STRIDES IN OUTREACH AND
COMMUNICATION. HOWEVER, IT IS
UNCLEAR IF CSU HAS FULLY
EMPOWERED HER TO EFFECTIVELY
OVERSEE AND IMPLEMENT AB 389.
CLARITY IS NEEDED REGARDING THE
OVERALL LEADERSHIP AND STRUCTURE
TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE AND
PROGRESS WAS NOTED ON THE
EARLIER THE FIRST PANEL THAT
THERE WAS AN ORG CHART
EXPLAINING SUCH STRUCTURE THAT
HASN'T TRICKLED DOWN CSU
LEADERSHIP. THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE MUST CONTINUE TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR COMPLIANCE,
FUNDING, TRAINING, REPORTING,
AND ENFORCEMENT OF NAGPRA AND
CAL NAGPRA. I URGE THE COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR TO USE THE UC, NAGPRA
POLICY AS A ROADMAP TO DEVELOP
THE CSU POLICY AND ESTABLISH
COMMITTEES TO IMPLEMENT NAGPRA
AND CAL NAGPRA. HOWEVER, THE CSU
DRAFT POLICY IT WAS JUST
RELEASED ON JULY SECOND TO
TRIBES FOR REVIEW AND PROVIDED
COMMENTS IN DECEMBER OF 2023,
NEW NAGPRA REGULATIONS WERE
PUBLISHED IN THE FEDERAL
REGISTRY AND BECAME EFFECTIVE
JULY 12TH OF THIS YEAR. THESE
NEW REGULATIONS DISMANTLE HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE SECTION 80 20.7.
BECAUSE THE NEW NAGPRA
REGULATIONS ELIMINATED
CULTURALLY UNIDENTIFIABLE HUMAN
REMAINS. CATEGORY REQUIRES
MUSEUMS AND FEDERAL AGENCIES TO
OBTAIN FREE, PRIOR INFORMED
CONSENT BEFORE ANY EXHIBITION OF
ACCESS TO OR RESEARCH ON HUMAN
REMAINS OR CULTURAL ITEMS, AND
REQUIRES DEFERENCE TO INDIGENOUS
KNOWLEDGE. THE FEDERAL
REGULATIONS ALSO ALLOW CAL,
NAGPRA, AND NAGPRA TO WORK
TOGETHER TO PROMOTE TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY. THE NEED FOR CSU'S
AND UC'S TO THOUGHTFULLY AND
MEANINGFULLY COMPLY WITH BOTH
NAGPRA AND CAL. NAGPRA IS
CRITICAL. LAST YEAR, ON AUGUST
29TH, I TESTIFIED HERE BEFORE
THE SAME JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE AND ASSEMBLY OF SELECT
COMMITTEE ON NATIVE AFFAIRS
REGARDING AB 3089 AND THE CSU
AUDIT. THE TRIBE, MY TRIBE
SUPPORTED THE FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATION OF THE AUDIT,
WHICH HIGHLIGHTED CSU'S SYSTEM'S
OVERWHELMING FAILURE TO
INVENTORY AND REPATRIATE
REPATRIATE COLLECTIONS TO
TRIBES. I STRESSED LAST YEAR,
AND I'M GOING TO STRESS AGAIN
NOW IT IS CRITICAL TO RECOGNIZE
THAT ALL STATE AGENCIES AND
MUSEUMS RECEIVING STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDING AND POSSESSING
HUMAN REMAINS AND CULTURAL ITEMS
MUST COMPLY WITH CAL, NAGPRA,
AND NAGPRA. THE AUDIT IS THE
ONLY OVERSIGHT TOOL TO ENSURE
THIS COMPLIANCE. THEREFORE, WE
URGE THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE TO DIRECT THE STATE
AUDITOR TO CONDUCT AUDITS OF THE
STATE AGENCIES AND MUSEUMS TO
ENFORCE NAGPRA AND CAL NAGPRA.
ADDITIONALLY, ANNUAL REPORTING
TO THESE AGENCIES AND MUSEUMS
MUST BE A LEGISLATIVE MANDATE.
THE CURRENT PACE OF PROGRESS
TOWARDS CULTURAL JUSTICE IS
UNDENIABLY SLOW, PAINFULLY SLOW.
WE MUST WORK WITH A RENEWED
SENSE OF URGENCY AND ENSURE THE
EFFORTS ARE COMPREHENSIVE ACROSS
EVERY AGENCY. IN CLOSE, I WOULD
LIKE TO JUST LEAVE YOU SOME
NUMBERS AT SONOMA STATE
UNIVERSITY. JUST IN MY TRIBE
COAST MIWOK, SOUTHERN POMO OF
SONOMA AND MARIN COUNTIES, THERE
ARE 510 COLLECTIONS. I'M BEING
CONSERVATIVE. WE HAVE COUNTED
OVER 290 500,000 ITEMS. THESE
ARE ANCESTRAL FRAGMENTS TO
FUNERAL OBJECTS. OBJECTS AS WELL
AS, REFLECTING THE PROBLEMATIC
AREAS IN FIELD SCHOOLS AND
RESEARCH. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND FOR YOUR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP ON THIS MATTER, AND
FOR GIVING US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. WE'LL NOW MOVE TO
CATALINA CHACON, COUNCIL MEMBER
FROM THE PECHANGA. TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT. CHAIRMAN RAMOS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, MIRIAM
NORTON, CATALINA CHACON,
PECHANGA. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS CATALINA CHACON AND MY TRIBAL
COUNCIL MEMBER FOR THE PECHANGA
BAND OF INDIANS. I ALSO SERVE AS
THE VICE CHAIR OF THE TRIBAL
ALLIANCE OF SOVEREIGN INDIAN
NATION, OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
TACIN. I ALSO SERVE AS THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA TRIBAL
FAMILIES COALITION, AND ALSO
SERVE AS ON THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS. THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING AND HOLDING THIS HEARING
TODAY, AND KEEPING THIS ISSUE IN
FRONT OF THE LEGISLATURE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, HOME TO THE MOST
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS IN THE COUNTRY, THE
NATIVE AMERICAN GRAVES
PROTECTION AND REPATRIATION ACT.
NAGPRA HAS PROVEN INADEQUATE AND
INEFFECTIVE WHEN IT COMES TO
RESEARCH UNIVERSITIES LIKE THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY,
NAGPRA REQUIRES FEDERALLY FUNDED
MUSEUMS AND UNIVERSITIES TO
REPATRIATE ANCESTRAL REMAINS AND
CULTURAL ITEMS TO FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE UC AND CSU
HAVE A WELL-DOCUMENTED AND
CHRONIC HISTORY OF NONCOMPLIANCE
WITH THESE FEDERAL AND STATE
LAWS DESIGNED TO BRING OUR
ANCESTORS HOME. ALTHOUGH MORE
THAN 30 YEARS HAVE PASSED SINCE
NAGPRA WAS ENACTED, THE STATE
AUDITOR RECENTLY FOUND THAT MORE
THAN HALF OF THE CSU CAMPUSES
HAVE NOT RETURNED ANY REMAINS OR
CULTURAL ITEMS TO TRIBES. OUR
TRIBAL ANCESTORS AND CULTURAL
ITEMS ARE STILL SEEN AS
SPECIMENS TO MANY RESEARCHERS.
INSTEAD OF HUMAN BEINGS WITH A
RIGHT TO A FINAL, DIGNIFIED
PLACE OF REST. EVEN TODAY, THERE
ARE AMATEUR ARCHEOLOGICAL
SOCIETIES THAT ARE GENERALLY NOT
SUBJECT TO NAGPRA, BUT THEY HAVE
CSU PROFESSORS AND STAFF AS
MEMBERS, AND THEY COORDINATE
REGULARLY WITH CSU CAMPUSES TO
OFFER FIELD SCHOOLS TO CSU
STUDENTS. THEY OFTEN HOUSE THE
EXCAVATED RESOURCES AT CSU
CAMPUSES, WITH CSU. CSU STAFF
ASSUMING RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THEM. THEY TRADE THEM WITH EACH
OTHER, THEY TAKE THEM HOME. ALL
OF THIS SO THEY CAN PUBLISH
PAPERS AND BOOKS ABOUT A PEOPLE
AND A CULTURE THAT HAS NOT
CONSENTED TO BEING TREATED AS
SPECIMENS. FAILING TO RETURN OUR
TRIBAL ANCESTORS WHOSE REMAINS
AND FUNERARY ITEMS WERE DUG UP
IN THE NAME OF SCIENCE IS
DISGRACEFUL, INCONGRUENT WITH
THE REPUTATION AND STATED VALUES
OF THE UC AND CSU. AFTER YEARS
OF DEEP FRUSTRATION AND
DISAPPOINTMENT WITH
REPATRIATION, OUR TRIBE PECHANGA
HAD ENOUGH OF THE DELAYS, THE
DEFIANCE AND THE DISRESPECT.
THAT'S WHY PECHANGA SPONSORED AB
2836 BY FORMER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TODD GLORIA. IN 2018. THE INTENT
OF THE BILL WAS TO COMPEL THE UC
TO FINALLY TAKE FEDERAL NAGPRA
NAGPRA SERIOUSLY TO RETURN OUR
ANCESTORS TO THE APPROPRIATE
TRIBES FOR PROPER CARE.
SPECIFICALLY, THE BILL
ESTABLISHED A SYSTEM WIDE
FRAMEWORK FOR THE PROCESS TO
RETURN OUR ANCESTRAL REMAINS.
CULTURAL ITEMS, AND CREATED A
SYSTEM OF CHECKS AND BALANCES BY
REQUIRING THAT REPATRIATION
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES INCLUDE
A TRIBE, INCLUDE TRIBAL VOICES
BOTH IN THEIR CREATION AND
IMPLEMENTATION AT EVERY STEP. WE
THANK YOU, CHAIRMAN RAMOS, FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND AUTHORING AB
389. LAST YEAR WE WERE VERY
HAPPY TO HAVE WORKED WITH YOUR
OFFICE TO MODEL A SIMILAR
FRAMEWORK FOR THE CSU. IN SPITE
OF THIS PAINFUL AND TRAUMATIC
PAST, LAWS LIKE AB 2836 AND AB
389 GIVE US HOPE. HOPE FOR THE
RETURN OF OUR ANCESTORS TO THE
RIGHTFUL FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES, AND HOPE FOR THE
DAY WHEN OUR GRANDCHILDREN WILL
NOT HAVE TO UNDERTAKE THIS HEAVY
AND TRAUMATIC WORK. THE STATE
AUDITOR HAS OUTLINED SEVERAL
THOUGHTFUL RECOMMENDATIONS IN
THE REPORT FROM LAST YEAR. WE
AGREE WITH THE KEY
RECOMMENDATIONS, NAMELY THAT
THAT THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
SHOULD FIRST ENSURE THAT
CAMPUSES PROPERLY CONSULT WITH
TRIBES IMMEDIATELY CONCERNING
PROTOCOLS FOR PREPARING THE
REQUIRED INVENTORIES. BY
DECEMBER 2024. THIS INCLUDES
LOCATING CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE
HANDLING AND IDENTIFYING
ANCESTRAL REMAINS AND CULTURAL
ITEMS. I WANT TO ESPECIALLY
EMPHASIZE THIS RECOMMENDATION BY
THE AUDITOR AND ADD THAT WHILE
WE WANT TO RETURN OUR ANCESTORS
HOME AS TIMELY AS POSSIBLE, WE
DO NOT WANT THE US èC OR CSU TO
RUSH THE PROCESS OR SKIP STEPS
AND SEND RELATIVES TO THE WRONG
PLACES, ENSURING PROPER TRIBAL
CONSULTATION FIRST WOULD GO A
LONG WAYS TO AVOIDING SUCH
MISTAKES. SECOND, ALTHOUGH THE
SYSTEMWIDE NAGPRA POLICY HAS
BEEN RELEASED AND TRIBAL
CONSULTATION IS PLANNED FOR THE
FALL OF 2024, A CLEAR PROCESS OF
HOW TRIBAL GOVERNMENT INPUT AND
BEST PRACTICES WILL INCORPORATE
WILL BE INCORPORATED INTO THE
POLICY SHOULD BE COMMUNICATED TO
CONSULTING TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS.
THIRD, REQUIRE CAMPUSES TO HAVE
FULL TIME REPATRIATION
COORDINATORS. LET ME EMPHASIZE
THAT TRAINING ON REPATRIATION
LAWS IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR
THE COORDINATORS. OUR EXPERIENCE
IS SHOWING US THAT SOME THAT ARE
PUT IN CHARGE OF REPATRIATION
AND CONSULTATION ARE SIMPLY NOT
TRAINED IN REPATRIATION LAWS OR
TRIBALLY APPROVED BEST PRACTICES.
THIS IS CAUSING DELAYS AND
MISTAKES THAT ARE BURDENSOME ON
OUR TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS. FINALLY,
THE INTENT OF THE CAMPUS AND
SYSTEMWIDE COMMITTEES REQUIRED
BY AB 389 ARE NOT INTENDED TO BE
BARRIERS TO REPATRIATION, BUT
RATHER TO PROVIDE CALIFORNIA
TRIBES WITH A VOICE IN
REPATRIATION DECISIONS TO ENSURE
THAT THEY'RE IN COMPLIANCE WITH
FEDERAL AND STATE REPATRIATION
LAWS AND TRIBAL PRACTICES. IN
CLOSING, LET ME SAY THAT WE
RECOGNIZE CSU IS AT THE
BEGINNING STAGES OF IMPLEMENTING
THEIR SYSTEMWIDE REPATRIATION
PROGRAM. WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT
THE UC AND CSU FACE CHALLENGES.
THERE ARE LARGE AND THEY ARE
LARGE AND COMPLEX ORGANIZATIONS
RESPONSIBLE FOR NEARLY 1 MILLION
STUDENTS. FUNDING FOR NAGPRA IS
ALSO A CHALLENGE. HOWEVER, WE
CANNOT BEGIN TO ADDRESS THIS
CHALLENGE WITHOUT KNOWING WHAT
WE FACE. TO THAT END, THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE SHOULD MAKE
FUNDING FOR NAGPRA A PRIORITY
AND SHOULD ESTIMATE THE FUNDING
NEEDS. MR. CHAIRMAN, WE LOOK
FORWARD TO REAL PROGRESS BY NEXT
YEAR. WE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE SOME
THOUGHTS, AND WE STAND READY TO
HELP CORRECT THIS INJUSTICE.
NIELSEN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
TESTIMONY AND IDENTIFYING KEY
AREAS THAT ARE THERE, NEXT WE'LL
GO TO BUFFY MCEWEN, TRIBAL
HERITAGE PRESERVATION OFFICER,
FEDERATED INDIANS, TRIBAL OF
GRATON, TRIBAL GOVERNMENT. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLYMAN RAMOS, MEMBERS
OF THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE AND ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON NATIVE AMERICAN
AFFAIRS. MY NAME IS BUFFY
MCQUILLEN. I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE FEDERATED INDIANS OF GRATON
RANCHERIA. I CURRENTLY SERVE AS
A FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBAL
MEMBER ON THE UC SYSTEMWIDE
REPATRIATION COMMITTEE. WITH
OVER 20 YEARS OF DIRECT
EXPERIENCE IN THE REPATRIATION
FIELD, IT IS ALSO MY HONOR TO
SERVE AS A GOVERNOR APPOINTEE TO
THE NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION. WHILE HONORED, I AM
NOT FORMALLY REPRESENTING THE
COMMISSION TODAY, BUT I WILL
CLARIFY FROM OUR EARLIER
TESTIMONY FROM SECRETARY
HITCHCOCK, A FEW ITEMS IN TWO
AUDIT REPORTS ISSUED IN 2019 AND
2021. IT WAS OVERWHELMINGLY
CLEAR IN THE AUDIT FINDINGS THAT
THE UC HAS NOT ADEQUATELY
PRIORITIZED THE RETURN OF NATIVE
AMERICAN ANCESTRAL REMAINS AND
CULTURAL ITEMS THEY WERE ALLOWED
TO REPORT THAT THEY ADDRESSED
THE AUDIT FINDINGS, WHICH
INCLUDED EVERYTHING FROM
FAILURES TO IDENTIFYING
COLLECTIONS, CONSISTENT
PRACTICES FOR TRIBAL
CONSULTATION, INCONSISTENT
PRACTICES TO PRIORITIZING
FUNDING FOR REPATRIATION. WHILE
IT SEEMS THE UC WAS ABLE TO
RESPOND TO THE FINDINGS, THERE
STILL SEEMS TO BE IN PRACTICE,
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES FOR
TRIBES TO REPATRIATE ANCESTRAL
REMAINS AND CULTURAL ITEMS. WITH
THE ISSUANCE OF UPDATED AND
CLARIFYING REGULATIONS BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THIS PAST
JANUARY 2024, THERE HAS STILL
BEEN A SLOW EFFORT TO IMPLEMENT
THE UPDATED REGULATIONS. èC
REPATRIATION STAFF AND THE
PRESIDENT'S OFFICE, WHILE
COMMITTED TO THE EFFORTS TO
IMPLEMENT THE LAW, THERE ARE
CHALLENGES WHEN IT COMES TO
ENSURING THAT CAMPUSES ARE IN
FACT MEETING THEIR FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR NAGPRA. BECAUSE
THERE IS AN AUDIT REQUIREMENT
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE 828, THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR, WHICH REQUIRES
THE CSA TO CONDUCT AN AUDIT
COMMENCING IN THE YEAR 2019 AND
2021 REGARDING UC'S CALIFORNIA
COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL NAGPRA,
AND SHALL REPORT ITS FINDINGS TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND TO ALL OTHER
APPROPRIATE ENTITIES. IT SEEMS
THERE IS A DIRE NEED TO RENEW
THIS EFFORT TO REVIEW THE UC
COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL NAGPRA.
BOTH AB 275 AND 389 REQUIRE
COMPLIANCE WITH BOTH STATE AND
FEDERAL REPATRIATION LAWS. THERE
IS ALSO GREATER CLARITY AMONGST
PRACTITIONERS IN THIS FIELD THAT
THE ONLY PATH TO REPATRIATION IS
BY WAY OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S NAGPRA PROCESS. UC
CAMPUSES HAVE YET TO FULLY
COMPLY WITH FEDERAL NAGPRA AND
HAVE BEEN ALLOTTED MORE TIME TO
SUBMIT INVENTORIES AND SUMMARIES.
HOWEVER, LET'S BE CLEAR WITH 30
YEARS NOW PLUS INTO THE
REPATRIATION, THERE IS NOWHERE
NEAR BEING COMPLETION ON THE
HORIZON. ONE THING I REALLY WANT
TO BE CLEAR ABOUT AND REALLY
STRESS, IS THAT UNTIL CAMPUSES
FULLY COMPLY WITH INVENTORIES
AND SUMMARIES AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL, WE CANNOT MOVE FORWARD
WITH REPATRIATION BECAUSE IT IS
ONLY THROUGH THAT PROCESS. WHILE
CAL NAGPRA UPLIFTS THE PROCESS,
IT IS THROUGH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT REPATRIATION
ACTUALLY HAPPENS. SO I WANT TO
BE REALLY CLEAR ABOUT THAT. WE
HAVE TO WORK IN CONCERT WITH ONE
ANOTHER IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE
THIS. SO WHILE WE CAN DO THINGS
AT THE STATE LEVEL, IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL TO ACTUALLY FOLLOW THAT
FEDERAL PROCESS. THE ONE THING I
WANT TO CLARIFY IS THAT THE
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
FUNDAMENTALLY FEELS THAT
EVERYBODY SHOULD COMPLY. ALL
INSTITUTIONS AND MUSEUMS, WHILE
WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE OTHER
INSTITUTIONS SPOTLIGHTED, IT IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL FOR EVERY
INSTITUTION TO HOLD THEMSELVES,
THEIR CONSULTANTS, ACCOUNTABLE.
THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE PANEL.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE DÍAS? I
DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE, SOME OF
THE MEMBER CARRILLO AND SOME OF
THE MEMBER THREE OF US, WHO
JOINED US, BUT DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FOR THIS
PANEL FROM THE DAIS? I WANT TO
THANK YOU. FOR BRINGING FORWARD,
DURING YOUR TESTIMONY, FROM
GREAT AND AS FAR AS THE
NOMINATION PROCESS AND
IDENTIFYING THAT THAT COULD BE A
BARRIER TO GETTING THESE
POSITIONS FILLED, WE WOULD LIKE
TO WORK WITH YOU TO IDENTIFY
WHAT THOSE BARRIERS ARE, SO THAT
WE COULD START TO, LOOK AT THAT,
TO ENSURE THAT THAT'S NOT A
HINDRANCE, FOR MOVING FORWARD
AND COMPLYING WITH CAL NAGPRA
AND THE FEDERAL NAGPRA. THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THAT THAT
FORWARD. ALSO, I JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY. YOU TALKED, AND
MENTIONED ABOUT SONOMA STATE,
510 COLLECTIONS, BUT DID YOU SAY
295,000? PIECES OF ARTIFACTS
INDIVIDUALLY? RIGHT. SO THEY
CONSIDER THE 510 COLLECTIONS AS
SORT OF LIKE A LARGE COLLECTION.
BUT WITHIN THOSE COLLECTIONS,
WHEN YOU START GOING PIECE BY
PIECE, ITEM BY ITEM, THE TOTAL
IS NEARING UP TO 300,000. WOW.
AND SO WOULD IT BE SAFE TO, SAY
OR ELABORATE THAT WHAT WAS
IDENTIFIED IN THE AUDIT AS
700,000, NATIVE AMERICAN REMAINS
COLLECTIONS ARTIFACTS THAT, A
FORMULA LIKE THIS COULD ACTUALLY
BE IMPLEMENTED, THAT IT'S FAR
MORE THAN JUST THE 510. AND IN
THIS CASE, ALMOST 300,000. YES.
ASSEMBLYMAN RAMOS, WE AND I HAD
MENTIONED I WAS BEING
CONSERVATIVE, HOWEVER, WE DO
FEEL THAT THERE IS PROBABLY
MORE, GIVEN THAT THERE ARE
OTHER, DOC, RESOURCES AND BOXES
THAT HAVE YET TO BE, REALLY
FULLY VETTED. I'M ALSO AWARE IN
THE SHORT TIME, ONE OF THE
MILESTONES THAT HAS HAPPENED
SINCE THIS LAW WAS IMPLEMENTED
WAS A LOT OF THE CSU'S ARE DOING
IN A OUTREACH INTERNALLY TO
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS. SO BEYOND
ANTHROPOLOGY, BIOLOGY, OTHER
TYPES OF DEPARTMENTS THAT MAY
ALSO HAVE CULTURAL AND HUMAN
REMAINS, THAT HAVE GONE UNDER,
ADDRESSED OR NOT ACCOUNTED FOR.
SO IT UNDERSCORES THE POINT
THAT, THIBAULT MCQUILLEN HAS
SAID ABOUT REALLY ENSURING THAT
THE INVENTORY AND EXPANSIVE,
AWARENESS OF ALL OF THE
UNIVERSITIES IS THOROUGHLY
RESEARCHED AND ASSESSED FROM
EVERY DEPARTMENT TIP TOP TO
ALSO, THE PRIOR CHAIR TALKED
ABOUT THE PROFESSORS WHO RETIRED
WHAT'S IN PEOPLE'S HOMES BECAUSE
WHAT HAD RESULTED AT SONOMA
STATE, FOR EXAMPLE, WAS A HUGE
POINT OF EDUCATION FOR SOME
PROFESSORS AND DEPARTMENTS WHO
REALLY DO NOT UNDERSTAND NAGPRA
OR EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS OR
REPATRIATION. SO IN
INSTITUTIONALLY, THERE NEEDS TO
BE A GREATER AWARENESS. BESIDES
THE TYPICAL ANTHROPOLOGICAL
DEPARTMENTS, AS WELL AS
UNDERSTANDING THAT POTENTIALLY
THERE ARE COLLECTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN IN HIDING OR IN BYWAYS,
THAT THE UNIVERSITIES HAVE NOT
THOUGHT ABOUT BEFORE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. AND,
CATALINA, FROM A TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT, BRINGING UP AS FAR
AS THE AMATEUR FIELD SCHOOLS,
THIS STILL IS A PRACTICE THAT'S
TAKING PLACE CURRENTLY AS WE'RE
SITTING HERE, THOSE FIELD
SCHOOLS THAT GO OUT AND WORK
WITH THE LOCAL EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS, GOING AND DIGGING
UP AREAS THAT SOMETIMES UNCOVER
REMAINS. AND SO IT GOES DEEPER
TO COMPLIANCE WITH CAL STATE
UNIVERSITIES, UCS. IT GOES TO
HOW THOSE REMAINS, HOW OUR LOVED
ONES ARE BEING EXCAVATED IN THE
FIRST PLACE, I KNOW THAT THAT
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING TIRELESSLY
ON THIS, ON THIS EFFORT ALSO
REPATRIATION, BUT IDENTIFYING
THAT AND MAKING SURE THAT HOW DO
WE MOVE FORWARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE FIELD SCHOOLS, ARE
NOT CONTINUING TO DO THIS? I
WISH THEY WOULD STOP IT. WE
SHOULD JUST STOP. IT'S SO
DISHEARTENING FOR US, FOR THE
TRIBAL LEADERS BEFORE ME THAT
SAT UP HERE. I MEAN, YOU CAN
HEAR IT IN OUR WORDS, IN OUR
HEARTS. AND YOU KNOW, WE JUST
WANT OUR PEOPLE BACK. WE WANT
THEM SAFELY PUT TO REST. YOU
KNOW, GENTLEMAN THAT WAS SITTING
UP HERE EARLIER, THE,
LEGISLATOR, I CAN'T REMEMBER HIS
NAME. JACKSON BUT YEAH. JACKSON.
YOU KNOW, HE SAID, GOD, I DON'T
KNOW HOW I'D FEEL IF THIS WAS MY
ANCESTORS. I'D BE TAKING THIS,
YOU KNOW? AND IT'S LIKE THAT FOR
EACH ONE OF YOU UP HERE. I MEAN,
JUST IMAGINE IF THIS WAS YOUR
ANCESTORS AND IT'S BEEN
HAPPENING FOR SO LONG. I MEAN,
OVER 30 YEARS, NAGPRA HAS BEEN
ENACTED, AND WE STILL CAN'T GET
THIS RIGHT. IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
RIGHT. WE NEED TO BRING OUR
ANCESTORS HOME. AND THAT'S ALL
WE'RE ASKING. WELL, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. AND ALSO,
THE COMPLIANCE OF PROFESSORS AND
RETIRED PROFESSORS THAT KEEP
THESE, IN THEIR ARCHIVES, AND
AGAIN, IT NEEDS TO BE STATED
THAT OUR LOVED ONES AND OUR
ANCESTORS ARE NOT TROPHIES TO BE
PUT ON A SHELF. WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE REPATRIATION
PROCESS CONTINUES. BUT WE HAVE
TO STOP THAT PROCESS TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR LOVED ONES AND
REMAINS DO NOT CONTINUE TO MOVE
THAT MOVE FORWARD. SO IT WAS A
TESTIMONY IN THIS PANEL AND
PRIOR THAT THERE SHOULD BE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR PROFESSORS
AND RETIRING PROFESSORS FOR WHAT
THEY HAVE WITHIN THEIR
COLLECTIONS. SO THANK YOU, FOR
THAT. AND IT ALSO WAS BROUGHT UP
THAT EVEN THOUGH WE'RE FILLING
THESE POSITIONS, THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE FURTHER EDUCATION ON
THE LAWS THEMSELVES. AND I GUESS
THAT WOULD GO INTO SOME OF THE,
RECRUITMENT PROCESS, MAYBE AFTER
THE RECRUITMENT IS DONE THAT
THERE SHOULD BE SOME TYPE OF
EDUCATION ON THESE LAWS AND CAL
NAGPRA AND NAGPRA LAWS ON
REPATRIATION. SO IT WILL TAKE
THAT TO HEART. AND, AND THANK
YOU FOR THAT, CATALINA AND
BUFFY, YOU MENTIONED THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE FEDERAL
AND THE CAL NAGPRA. IF WE'RE
FOCUSED STRONGLY ON THE STATE
CAL NAGPRA, WE'RE FORGETTING
THAT A LOT OF THESE INSTITUTIONS
STILL HAVE TO COMPLY WITH THE
FEDERAL ASPECT. CAN YOU
ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT MORE ON
THAT? YES. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMAN RAMOS, IN ORDER TO
ACTUALLY ACHIEVE REPATRIATION
WITHOUT THE LIABILITY OR RISK
THAT COMES WITH ACTUALLY,
TECHNICALLY PROPERTY TRANSFERS,
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE TO NOTICE IT
IN THE FEDERAL REGISTER AND YOU
GIVE NOTICE TO ALL OF THE
POTENTIAL OTHER CULTURALLY
AFFILIATED TRIBES OR ANCESTRAL,
LINEAL DESCENDANTS THAT COULD
COME FORWARD. THAT'S A VERY
FORMAL PROCESS UNDER FEDERAL
LAW. AND SO WE REALLY UPLIFT
THAT IN CALIFORNIA. AND SO IF
YOU DON'T GO THROUGH THAT
PROCESS, BASICALLY YOU OPEN UP
YOURSELF TO LIABILITY, NOT AN
ATTORNEY. BUT I KNOW A LOT OF
ATTORNEYS. SO, BUT THAT IS ONE
OF THE, THE RISKS THAT COME WITH
REPATRIATION UNDER STATE LAW IS
WE DON'T HAVE A MECHANISM RIGHT
NOW TO DO THAT. THAT'S NOT TO
SAY THAT SOMETHING COULDN'T BE
CREATED, BUT RIGHT NOW IT REALLY
STEMS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOWN TO THE STATE
SYSTEM, AND THAT WE REALLY
SUPPORT THAT EFFORT. AND THAT IS
A LOT OF WHAT WE ARE DOING AT
THE NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
BEING ABLE TO MEDIATE, WE ARE
ABLE TO ACTUALLY SIT DOWN. WE
HOPE TO SIT DOWN WITH TRIBES WHO
MAYBE ARE IN DISPUTE, OR WITH
CAMPUSES WHO ARE IN DISPUTES AND
DON'T UNDERSTAND THE LAW OR
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY A TRANSFER
NEEDS TO OCCUR, OR WHY A
CULTURALLY AFFILIATED TRIBE
WASN'T ACTUALLY CONTACTED. THOSE
ARE THE MECHANISMS THAT ARE IN
PLACE UNDER THE COMMISSION'S
AUTHORITY. SO THOSE ARE ALL THE
WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN SUPPORT
FEDERAL LAW, ALONG WITH ALSO THE
REPATRIATION REVIEW COMMITTEE AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL. THERE'S ALSO
FAILURES TO COMPLY, NOTICES THAT
CAN GO OUT. SO THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK THAT WE CAN DO IF WE
ACTUALLY SIT DOWN AND WORK
TOGETHER WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THREE OF US. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. MR. CHAIR,
FOR AND BOTH OF YOU, I THINK,
FOR PUTTING TOGETHER THIS
HEARING, I HAD A SOME COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS. FIRST, THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US TODAY. YOU KNOW,
I'M LEARNING SO MUCH, AND NOT
PROUD THAT OUR UNIVERSITIES ARE
NOT COMPLYING AND THAT THEY HAVE
A HISTORY OF NONCOMPLIANCE, I
KNOW ONE OF YOU MENTIONED THAT
OVER HALF OF CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES HAVE NOT
RETURNED ANYTHING, AND IT'S
HORRIBLE TO HEAR THAT. WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING, THESE RETIRED
PROFESSORS ARE KEEPING SOME OF
THESE ITEMS AND THE WAY THEY'RE
TREATING, THE REMAINS. AND I'M
CURIOUS IF, YOU KNOW, AS PART OF,
YOU KNOW, GRADUATE EDUCATION,
LIKE OUR FUTURE RESEARCHERS AND
ACADEMICS AND PROFESSORS IS
NAGPRA AND REPATRIATION ANY PART
OF THAT TRAINING, SO THAT IN THE
FUTURE, YOU KNOW, OUR FUTURE
RESEARCHERS KNOW THIS, AND IT'S
PART OF THEIR TRAINING. DO WE
KNOW IF THAT'S HAPPENING
ANYWHERE? I MEAN, I THINK THAT
I'M HAPPY TO TRY TO RESPOND TO
THAT. UNDER THE NEW REGULATIONS
THAT THAT CLARIFY, THIS PART OF
THE PROCESS UNDER IT'S CALLED A
DUTY OF CARE. AND THERE IF YOU
WORK WITH TRIBAL NATIONS TO AND
IF TRIBAL NATIONS WANT TO LEAD
RESEARCH PROJECTS OR THEY HAVE
THEIR OWN RESEARCH INQUIRIES,
THERE COULD BE A PROCESS FOR
DOING TYPES OF FIELD SCHOOLS
THAT MAY BE IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF THE CAMPUS THE UC SYSTEM, THE
CSU SYSTEM, AND THE TRIBE. BUT
IT REALLY BRINGS IT INTO THE
TRIBAL FOLD WHERE THEY CAN
ACTUALLY MAKE DECISIONS. AND SO,
YOU KNOW, IT, IT COULD WORK IN A
MANNER WHERE THERE IS AN
ACCEPTABLE STANDARD TO A
SPECIFIC TRIBE OR TRIBES, BUT
CATEGORICALLY, AS ASSEMBLYMAN
RAMOS IS SAYING, WE'RE AS INDIAN
PEOPLE, WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT MADE
FOR THE SHELVES. SO WE ARE NOT
OBJECTS AND NOR ARE PEOPLE OR
THEIR CULTURAL ITEMS. AND SO IT
REALLY SETS THAT APART. AND SETS
THAT STANDARD, AND SO THAT'S
REALLY THE CRITICAL PIECE, I
THINK, TO UPLIFT RIGHT NOW IS TO
REALLY SET THAT STANDARD AND
REALLY, YOU KNOW, CEMENT THAT IN
THESE SYSTEMS THAT THAT'S
UNACCEPTABLE. THAT IS NO LONGER
BECAUSE IT IS A HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATION. SO I THINK THAT IS
WHERE WE'RE AT. WE MAY GET TO A
POINT WHERE THERE COULD BE SOME
ALLOWANCES, BUT WE'RE WE'RE
REALLY AT A STARTING POINT 30
PLUS YEARS IN. OKAY. NO, THAT'S
THAT'S GOOD TO HEAR BECAUSE I'M
JUST CURIOUS IF THAT WAS PART OF
THEIR TRAINING, THEIR GRADUATE
SCHOOL TRAINING AND HOW ARE WE
CHANGING THAT. RIGHT SO THAT
THEY KNOW THIS IS NOT
APPROPRIATE. AND I THINK THAT
THERE, THERE'S, THERE'S A WAY TO
CHANGE THE SYSTEM. ABSOLUTELY
ABSOLUTELY. IT REALLY IS,
THOUGH, CHANGING CHANGING THE
IT'S A PARADIGM SHIFT, OF, YOU
KNOW, HOLDING THEMSELVES
ACCOUNTABLE, BUT IF THEY HAVE
NOT YET DONE THAT, WHICH MANY OF
THEM ARE UPSET BY THE RESEARCH
BAN, WHICH ACTUALLY IS NOW
UPLIFTED IN FEDERAL LAW, THAT
YOU CAN'T JUST GO DO THAT. SO
YOU KNOW THAT THAT WAS A
MONUMENTAL STEP FOR TRIBES. THAT
WAS A BIG VICTORY TO ACTUALLY
HAVE THE FEDERAL SYSTEM SUPPORT
US IN THAT WAY. WELL THAT'S
GREAT, YEARS AGO, I USED TO WORK
AT A MUSEUM OF NATURAL HISTORY
IN NEW YORK CITY. I WORKED IN
SCIENCE EDUCATION, BUT MY
COLLEAGUES THAT WORKED IN
ANTHROPOLOGY AND OTHERS, I
REMEMBER THERE WAS JUST A FEAR,
RIGHT, THAT NATIVE TRIBES WOULD
COME AND TAKE THESE ITEMS THAT
ARE STORED IN BASEMENTS, NOT ALL
ON DISPLAY. AND I NEVER REALLY
UNDERSTOOD WHY WHY THEY'RE JUST
STORED SOMEWHERE. AND YOU JUST
WANT TO KEEP THEM JUST BECAUSE.
BECAUSE THAT IS, WHAT THEY'RE
USED TO, RIGHT? THIS IS THAT HOW
THEIR FIELD OF STUDY WORKS?
UNFORTUNATELY. AND, BUT I THINK
IT'S TIME TO CHANGE. AND IN
CALIFORNIA, ESPECIALLY HERE,
SINCE WE'RE HERE AT THE
LEGISLATURE. LEGISLATURE, YOU
KNOW, I REALLY FEEL AND I
SUPPORT THIS. AND AS I
TRANSITION TO THE FEDERAL LEVEL
AND TO CONGRESS, I DEFINITELY
WANT TO KEEP UPDATED ON, YOU
KNOW, THE HOW THE FEDERAL, YOU
KNOW, LAWS CAN SUPPORT AND MAKE
CALIFORNIA ACCOUNTABLE IN SOME
WAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, MEMBER RIVAS. SO, MEMBER
GARCIA. YEAH. THANK YOU, THAT
WAS AN EXCELLENT QUESTION. AND
YOU GAVE A RESPONSE, BUT I THINK
IT DESERVING OF MAYBE A
REFRAMING. AND SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE, MANDATE THIS TYPE
OF TRAINING FOR THOSE GOING INTO
THIS PARTICULAR FIELD OF STUDY?
AND PERHAPS EACH ONE OF YOU CAN
CHIME IN ON THAT, BECAUSE WE'VE
GOT LEGISLATORS HERE AND OTHERS
WATCHING AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
HERE, THAT IF THE SENTIMENT IS,
WE SHOULD MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION. THAT IS HOW WE CAN
BEGIN THE SHIFTING OF HOW THE
ANTHROPOLOGISTS AND OR OTHER
ACADEMIC RESEARCHERS FROM THE
CLASSROOM ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICE. AND, YOU
KNOW, THE I THINK WHAT MOST
FOLKS ARE HERE TO HEAR FROM ARE
THE NEXT PANELISTS, BECAUSE WHAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE FIRST
PANEL, THE SECOND PANEL IS ALL
TOO FAMILIAR, TO MANY OF YOU IN
THIS ROOM. AND TO MANY HERE ON
THE DAIS. BUT THE REFRAMING OF
THE QUESTION MORE SIMPLE, CAN WE
PERHAPS PROCEED WITH
CONDITIONING THESE TYPES OF
TRAINING, METHODS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE FUTURE ACADEMICS ARE
NOT ADHERING TO THESE OLD
PRACTICES THAT ARE, QUITE
FRANKLY, VERY DISRESPECTFUL, AND
ANYONE ELSE, AS OUR COLLEAGUE,
MR. JACKSON SHARED, WOULD, WOULD
BE UP, YOU KNOW, FURIOUS ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, THIS PROBLEM SO
HAPPENING. SO THAT'S THE
QUESTION IS, SHOULD WE CONSIDER
LEGISLATION TO CONDITION THESE
TYPES OF TRAININGS FOR FUTURE
ACADEMICS? I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR THAT, I'D LIKE TO SHARE
WITH YOU, A SORT OF AN ANSWER OR
AN EXAMPLE OR MODEL THAT I THINK
COULD BE REPLICATED AND
CERTAINLY SHOULD BE, DEEPLY
UNDERSTOOD AND MORE DEPTH, FOR
MY TRIBE, WORKING WITH SONOMA
STATE, THEY HAVE AN
ANTHROPOLOGICAL INFORMATION
CENTER, A LOT OF THE COLLECTIONS
THAT I REFERRED TO EARLIER HAVE
COME THROUGH, DIFFERENT
CONTRACTORS WHERE THE
ANTHROPOLOGICAL CENTER IS PAID
TO COME OUT AND DO, SERVICES
THROUGH DIFFERENT PROJECTS THAT
ARE REQUIRING THAT TYPE OF
KNOWLEDGE. WHAT WHAT WE'VE
ADVOCATED FOR IS FOR THE
ANTHROPOLOGICAL CENTER TO STOP,
MONETIZING THEIR RESOURCES AND
SERVICES FOR ANTHROPOLOGICAL
SERVICES AND COLLECT AND THUS DE
FACTO BECOMING THE HOLDER OF
THESE COLLECTIONS. BUT TO UPLIFT
TRIBES NOT JUST OUR OWN, BUT
OTHER TRIBES TO DO DIRECT TRIBAL
CONSULTATION SO THAT TRIBES ARE
PUT IN FRONT WHERE THEY SHOULD
BE TO ACTUALLY, DECIDE AND
DICTATE WHERE, THERE IS
COLLECTIONS, IF THERE ARE JOBS
OR SOME SORT OF IMPACT TO A
PLACE RATHER THAN CREATING IT. A
MONETARY MEANS FOR A UNIVERSITY
TO KEEP THE FLOW OF THEIR
CENTER, AND I THINK THERE ARE
SOME REALLY YOU FOLLOW THE MONEY
IS ALWAYS KIND OF THE ADAGE, BUT
I THINK THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
THERE WHERE THE CENTERS, RATHER
THAN BEING GATEKEEPERS, REALLY
NEED TO BE UPLIFTING TRIBES
THROUGH REAL, MEANINGFUL
CONSULTATION SO THEY DON'T
ACTUALLY BECOME THE RECIPIENTS
IN THE FIRST PLACE. AND JUST TO
ADD TO THAT, I THINK THAT TRIBES
IN GENERAL ARE ALWAYS LOOKING TO
MANDATE BEST PRACTICES WHEN IT
COMES TO THINGS LIKE THIS. I
THINK EVEN IN THE ARCHEOLOGICAL
FIELD, WE NEED TO HAVE, ETHICS.
THERE NEEDS TO BE ETHICS
INVOLVED. AND THAT'S CURRENTLY
NOT THE CASE RIGHT NOW. SO WE
ARE ALWAYS LOOKING FORWARD TO
BEST PRACTICES AND MANDATING ALL
OF THAT IS DEFINITELY IN FAVOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, ASSEMBLYMAN
MATHIS. THANK YOU. JUST QUICKLY,
I THINK, TO MEMBER RIVAS,
COMMENT. THE METHODOLOGY HAS
BEEN, YOU KNOW, THESE ARE
CULTURES THAT HAVE BEEN STORED
IN BASEMENTS OF MUSEUMS AND
OTHER PLACES. AND IT REMINDED ME
BRIEFLY OF WATCHING, LIKE
INDIANA JONES. BUT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A CULTURE THAT'S
DEAD AND GONE. THIS THESE ARE
OUR CULTURES, YOUR CULTURES, OUR
FAMILY MEMBERS THAT VÌ THE
FAMILY MEMBER MAY BE PASSED.
THEIR SPIRIT STILL LIVES ON, AND
THEIR ANCESTORS ARE HERE BEGGING
TO GET THEM BACK, WHICH GOES TO
WHAT YOU JUST SAID ABOUT THE
ETHICS ON WHAT'S BEING DONE. AND
IT NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT AND
REPHRASED OF YOU KNOW WHAT, IF
THERE'S STILL IF THERE'S STILL A
TRIBE, IF THEY'RE STILL A NATION
SAYING, GIVE US OUR PEOPLE BACK,
THEN THAT'S WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE. IT'S NOT YOU KNOW,
SOMETHING 10,000 YEARS AGO AND
EVERYBODY'S GONE. THIS IS HERE
TODAY, NOW. AND THAT'S WHAT
NEEDS TO CHANGE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ANY MORE
COMMENTS? QUESTIONS FROM THE
DÍAS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
ENLIGHTENING TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU. NOW WE'LL MOVE TO OUR NEXT
PANEL WITH CAL STATE
UNIVERSITIES AND èC RESPONSE TO
THE AUDIT. WE HAVE WITH US
DISTINGUISHED MILDRED GARCIA,
CHANCELLOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY. STEVE PEREZ,
PRESIDENT, CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY, CHICO TERESA
MALDONADO, VICE PRESIDENT FOR
RESEARCH INNOVATION, UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA. AND DEBORAH
MARTIN, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
RESEARCH POLICY ANALYSIS
COORDINATION, UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, GLENYS ECHAVARRIA,
SYSTEMWIDE REPATRIATION
COORDINATOR, UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, WHO WILL JOIN US
VIRTUALLY WHEN WE GET TO THAT
POINT. AND RICHARD LYONS,
CHANCELLOR OF UC BERKELEY. AND
ALEX LUCAS, DIRECTOR OF
REPATRIATION, UC BERKELEY. AND I
KNOW THERE'S, LIMITED SEATS, SO
I'M NOT SURE HOW, EVERYBODY'S
PUT TOGETHER, BUT WE'LL START,
WITH THE CHANCELLORS AND CAL
STATE UNIVERSITIES AND WE'LL GO
THROUGH THE, THE AGENDA AND CALL
PEOPLE UP. SO FIRST WE'LL GO
WITH, THE CHANCELLOR, CHANCELLOR
GARCIA, THEN STEVE PEREZ, TERESA
MALDONADO AND DEBORAH MOTEN,
FIRST FOR CHAIR HEART AND CHAIR.
RAMOS, THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
TODAY'S HEARING AND PROVIDING ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE PART OF
IT. I AM DOCTOR MILDRED GARCIA,
CHANCELLOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY. I WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN BY ACKNOWLEDGING TO THE
LEGISLATORS AND TO THE TRIBAL
LEADERS HERE TODAY THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY HAS
FALLEN FAR SHORT OF OUR
OBLIGATIONS TO RETURN THE NATIVE
AMERICAN ANCESTORS AND CULTURAL
ITEMS THAT HAVE BEEN ON OUR
CAMPUSES FOR FAR TOO LONG. OUR
ACTIONS AND INACTIONS HAVE
CAUSED GREAT PAIN TO NATIVE
AMERICANS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
I RECOGNIZE, AND I AM DEEPLY
TROUBLED BY THE ONGOING AND
HISTORICAL TRAUMA ASSOCIATED
WITH OUR LACK OF REPATRIATION.
SINCERELY I AM DEEPLY SORRY FOR
US AT THE CAL STATE FOR DOING
THIS HORRENDOUS THING AND FOR SO
MANY YEARS, I WANT TO ASSURE THE
LEGISLATURE AND CALIFORNIA
TRIBES THAT I AND EACH OF OUR
UNIVERSITY PRESIDENTS UNDERSTAND
THAT OUR FULL AND TIMELY
COMPLIANCE WITH NAGPRA AND CAL
NAGPRA IS MORE THAN A LEGAL
OBLIGATION. WE KNOW IT IS A
MORAL IMPERATIVE, AND THAT MORAL
IMPERATIVE REQUIRES THAT THE
REPATRIATION OF ANCESTORS AND
CULTURAL ITEMS BE DONE
RESPONSIBLY, RESPECTFULLY,
TRANSPARENTLY, AND WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY. IT REQUIRES THAT
WE ACT IN CONSTANT COLLABORATION
AND CONSULTATION WITH TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES AND IN A WAY THAT
HONORS AND RESPECTS TRIBAL
HERITAGE, CULTURE, VALUES AND
BELIEFS. I SAY UNEQUIVOCALLY, WE
WILL REPATRIATE ALL ANCESTORS
AND CULTURAL ITEMS AT EACH OF
OUR UNIVERSITIES. THIS HAS BEEN
A TOP PRIORITY OF ME, OF MINE
SINCE I BEGAN MY TENURE LAST
OCTOBER, AND IT WILL REMAIN SO
UNTIL OUR MORAL IMPERATIVE IS
MET. I WOULD LIKE TO NOW OFFER A
BRIEF RESPONSE TO THE STATE
AUDITOR'S UPDATE, AND SHARE WITH
YOU OUR RESPONSE AND COMMITMENT
TO THE RECOMMENDATIONS MADE IN
2023. FIRST, AS NOTED IN OUR
INITIAL RESPONSE TO THE AUDIT
LAST SUMMER, WE AGREE WITH THE
STATE AUDITOR'S FINDINGS THAT
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE HAS NOT
GIVEN OUR UNIVERSITIES
APPROPRIATE GUIDANCE AND
OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE.
TO RECTIFY THIS, AND TO RESPECT
THE GOVERNMENT, TO GOVERNMENT
NATURE OF OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
TRIBES, WE HAVE SHIFTED NAGPRA
AND CAL, NAGPRA RESPONSIBILITY
FROM THE DIVISION OF ACADEMIC
AND STUDENT AFFAIRS TO THE
DIVISION OF EXTERNAL RELATIONS
AND COMMUNICATIONS. WHILE NOT
PART OF THE STATE AUDIT ONE YEAR
UPDATE IN JUNE, MY OFFICE
ANNOUNCED THE CREATION OF THE
OFFICE OF TRIBAL RELATIONS WITH
THE SOLE CHARGE AND FOCUS TO
FACILITATE ENGAGEMENT WITH
TRIBES, CULTIVATE PARTNERSHIPS
AND ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH STATE
AND FEDERAL LAW. THE OFFICE WILL
BE LED BY AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
AND REPORT DIRECTLY TO THE
DIVISION'S VICE CHANCELLOR,
WHICH REPORTS DIRECTLY TO ME.
OUR NAGPRA TEAM HAS SPENT THE
BETTER TIME OF THIS CALENDAR
YEAR DRAFTING A SYSTEM WIDE
POLICY THROUGH AN INCLUSIVE AND
TRANSPARENT PROCESS, ELEVATING
TRIBAL VOICES AND PERSPECTIVES
THROUGHOUT, WROTE. WE HELD TEN
LISTENING SESSIONS ACROSS THE
STATE, DURING WHICH I AND OTHER
CSU LEADERS HEARD FIRST HAND THE
TRIBES CONCERNS. THESE CONCERNS
INCLUDED, BUT VÌ ARE BY NO MEANS
LIMITED TO THE NEED FOR THE CSU
TO SIMPLIFY AND STANDARDIZE THE
REPATRIATION PROCESS. THE
IMPORTANCE OF COMPENSATION TO
TRIBES FOR THEIR TIME SPENT ON
REPATRIATION, AND THE NEED TO
CONSISTENTLY REVIEW CAMPUS
SPACES FOR ANCESTORS AND
CULTURAL ITEMS. LAST MONTH, WE
SHARED THE WORKING DRAFT FOR
CONSULTATION PURPOSES, WHICH WE
MAILED TO MORE THAN 300 TRIBAL
LEADERS AND THE NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE COMMISSION. IT IS ALSO
ON OUR WEBSITE AT NAGPRA DOT CAL
STATE.EDU, A 90 DAY CONSULTATION
PERIOD WILL BEGIN IN SEPTEMBER
AND RUN THROUGH NOVEMBER TO GIVE
TRIBES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE DIRECT FEEDBACK AT THAT
POINT, THE WORKING DRAFT WILL BE
UPDATED BEFORE ANOTHER ROUND OF
TRIBAL AND COMMISSION
CONSULTATION IN THE SPRING. WE
WILL MEET AB 389 DEADLINE FOR
THE POLICY TO BE IMPLEMENTED BY
JULY 2025. AS YOU KNOW, AB 389
REQUIRES OUR FUTURE SYSTEMWIDE
POLICY TO INCLUDE A PROHIBITION
ON USING TRIBAL ANCESTORS AND
CULTURAL ITEMS IN TEACHING AND
RESEARCH. I DID NOT WANT TO WAIT
UNTIL JULY 20TH, 25 TO ENACT THE
PROHIBITION. THEREFORE, IN MARCH
OF THIS YEAR, I SENT EACH
PRESIDENT A DIRECTIVE TO ADHERE
TO THE PROHIBITION. NOW DESPITE
OUR CHALLENGING BUDGET CLIMATE
AND REFLECTING ON OUR
COMMITMENT, I HAVE ALLOCATED
$4.25 MILLION IN OUR 2425 BUDGET
TO SYSTEMWIDE AND CAMPUS NAGPRA
COMPLIANCE EFFORTS. THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE HAS ALLOCATED FUNDS
DIRECTLY TO OUR CAMPUSES FOR
THIS WORK. CAMPUSES WILL USE
THIS FUNDING TO HIRE AND TRAIN
STAFF, RESPOND TO TRIBAL
REQUESTS, AND SUPPORT CAMPUS
COMMITTEES, AS WELL AS OTHER
COMPLIANCE WORK. WE VIEW THIS
INITIAL INVESTMENT AS A LONG
OVERDUE DOWN PAYMENT, AND WE
KNOW THAT ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT
IS NEEDED. WE CONTINUE TO
COLLABORATE WITH THE NATIVE
AMERICAN HERITAGE COMMISSION TO
CREATE AND FILL CAMPUS AND
SYSTEMWIDE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEES.
OF THE 154 COMMITTEE MEMBERS
NEEDED TO DATE, THE COMMISSION
HAS NOMINATED 29 MEMBERS. WE
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE TIME
AND ENERGY THAT THE COMMISSION
STAFF HAVE DEDICATED TO THE
COMMITTEE NOMINATION PROCESS,
BOTH ON THE AUDIT AND AB 389
CALL FOR HIRING EXPERIENCED
CAMPUS COORDINATORS. OUR
RESPONSE TO THE AUDITOR
INDICATED THAT 18 CAMPUSES HAVE
FULFILLED THIS OBLIGATION. I AM
PLEASED TO REPORT TO YOU THAT
ONE OF THE THREE CAMPUSES THAT
DID NOT MEET AB THREE 89TH JULY,
FIRST DEADLINE HAS DONE SO BY
OFFERING MAKING AN OFFER TO A
CANDIDATE AT CAL STATE LA. THE
REMAINING TWO CAMPUSES, CSU
BAKERSFIELD AND CAL POLY SAN
LUIS OBISPO, HAVE REPOSTED THEIR
POSITIONS AFTER NOT ATTRACTING A
QUALIFIED CANDIDATE IN THEIR
INITIAL SEARCHES THIS SPRING.
BEFORE I CLOSE MY REMARKS, I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK
THE TEAM AT CHICO STATE LED BY
PRESIDENT PEREZ, WHO JOINS ME
HERE TODAY. FOR FIVE YEARS, THEY
HAVE BEEN A MODEL FOR THE CSU IN
WORKING DILIGENTLY,
TRANSPARENTLY AND WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY, ESTABLISHING
RESPECTIVE COLLABORATIVE AND
CONSULTATIVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THEIR LOCAL TRIBAL COMMUNITIES.
THE OTHER CSU CAMPUSES WILL
HONOR THEIR EXEMPLAR. I WILL END
MY REMARKS BY SHARING WITH YOU
SOME OF THE WAYS OUR BOARD OF
TRUSTEES AND I ARE HOLDING EACH
OTHER AND OUR CAMPUSES
ACCOUNTABLE IN OUR NAGPRA
COMPLIANCE WORK. FIRST, OUR OUR
TRUSTEES ARE UPDATED ON SYSTEM
AND CAMPUS COMPLIANCE EFFORTS AT
EACH BOARD MEETING. SECOND,
NAGPRA COMPLIANCE IS NOW PART OF
EACH PRESIDENTIAL REVIEW, AS
WELL AS THEIR MORE FORMAL
TRIENNIAL PERFORMANCE
EVALUATIONS. PRESIDENTS KNOW
THAT THEY MUST PRIORITIZE
REPATRIATION ON THEIR CAMPUSES
AND ACTIVELY DIRECT THIS
ESSENTIAL WORK. THIRD, NAGPRA IS
ALSO A STANDING ITEM AT EACH OF
OUR EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP TEAM.
CONVENINGS ATTENDED IN PERSON BY
EACH PRESIDENT AND OUR
SYSTEMWIDE SENIOR LEADERSHIP.
PRESIDENT TOMAS MORALES IS OUR
EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP TEAM LEADER
WHO SERVES AS PRESIDENTIAL
ADVISOR FOR NATIVE AMERICAN
INITIATIVES. WE ARE PLEASED TO
HAVE NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION LEADERSHIP JOIN US IN
FEBRUARY THIS YEAR, SO THEY
COULD SPEAK DIRECTLY TO THE
PRESIDENTS TO INCREASE THEIR
KNOWLEDGE, AWARENESS AND
CULTURAL UNDERSTANDING ABOUT THE
NEED TO BRING THE ANCESTORS HOME.
FINALLY, AS CHANCELLOR, I WILL
HOLD THIS UNIVERSITY SYSTEM
ACCOUNTABLE. I WILL ENSURE THAT
OUR ACTIONS ALIGN WITH OUR WORDS
AND WITH WHAT I KNOW IS TO BE
OUR SINCERE INTENT TO LIVE UP TO
OUR LEGAL AND MORAL OBLIGATIONS.
AND AS I SAID EARLIER, WHICH
BEARS REPEATING, WE WILL DO THIS
WORK RESPONSIBLY, RESPECTFULLY,
TRANSPARENTLY, WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY IN A WAY THAT
HONORS RESPECTS TRIBAL HERITAGE,
CULTURE, VALUES AND BELIEFS.
CHAIR, HEART AND CHAIR. RAMOS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS, MADAM CHANCELLOR.
NEXT, WE'LL MOVE TO MR. STEVE
PEREZ, PRESIDENT, CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY, CHICO. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIRMAN RAMOS.
CHAIRMAN HART, MEMBERS OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON NATIVE
AMERICAN AFFAIRS, JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND TRIBAL LEADERS,
THANK YOU FOR THE INVITATION TO
BE HERE TODAY. MY NAME IS STEVE
PEREZ, AND I SERVE AS THE
PRESIDENT AT CHICO STATE. THIS
IS MY SECOND OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THIS GROUP AS I
REPRESENTED CHICO STATE AT THE
JOINT HEARING OF THE LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE AND THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON NATIVE AMERICAN
AFFAIRS ON AUGUST 29TH, 2023. IN
ADDITION TO A NATIVE AMERICAN
LEGISLATIVE ROUNDTABLE ON MAY
28TH, 2024. JOINING ME IN THE
AUDIENCE ARE DOCTOR RACHEL
MCBRIDE, PRETORIUS, DIRECTOR OF
OUR OFFICE OF TRIBAL RELATIONS,
AND DON RAWLINGS, ROLINSKI.
SORRY, DON, CULTURAL ARTIFACT
SPECIALIST. ALSO IN OUR OFFICE
OF TRIBAL RELATIONS. FIRST AND
FOREMOST, I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
ACKNOWLEDGMENT THAT CHICO STATE
HAS BEEN OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH
NAGPRA AND CAL NAGPRA FOR YEARS.
REPATRIATION IS OF THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY FOR US, AND THOUGH WE
HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS,
I WANT TO APOLOGIZE TO ALL
TRIBES AND INDIVIDUALS FOR THE
HURT AND HARM CHICO STATE HAS
CAUSED. AND TO THOSE WHO
CONTINUE TO WAIT FOR THE
REPATRIATION OF THEIR ANCESTORS
AND CULTURAL ITEMS. THIS HEARING
IS AN IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY FOR
CHICO STATE TO SHARE PROGRESS
AND TO CONTINUE TO LEARN HOW WE
CAN DO BETTER, AND I'M GRATEFUL,
GENUINELY GRATEFUL FOR BEING
INVITED. THOUGH WE KNOW OUR WORK
ISN'T COMPLETE UNTIL 100% OF
ANCESTRAL ANCESTRAL REMAINS AND
CULTURAL ITEMS HAVE BEEN
REPATRIATED, I AM ABLE TO REPORT
THAT CHICO STATE HAS MADE
PROGRESS IN ITS REPATRIATION
EFFORTS. AS OF JUNE 2024, CHICO
STATE HAS SUCCESSFULLY
REPATRIATED 94% OF THE ANCESTRAL
REMAINS AND 86% OF THE CULTURAL
ITEMS THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY UNDER
OUR LEGAL CONTROL. THOSE
PERCENTAGES EQUATE TO 2567
ANCESTRAL REMAINS AND 97,098
CULTURAL ITEMS, THE UNIVERSITY
CONTINUES TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
TRIBAL LEADERS AND LAWMAKERS TO
ENSURE RESPONSIBLE AND
RESPECTFUL RETURN OF ALL
REMAINING ITEMS. THE ANCESTRAL
REMAINS THAT HAVE BEEN
REPATRIATED TO A TRIBAL
CONSORTIUM THAT INCLUDES BERRY
CREEK RANCHERIA OF MAIDU INDIANS
OF CALIFORNIA, KONKOW VALLEY
BAND OF MAIDU ENTERPRISE,
RANCHERIA OF MAIDU INDIANS OF
CALIFORNIA, MECHOOPDA INDIAN
TRIBE OF CHICO RANCHERIA,
MOORETOWN RANCHERIA OF MAIDU
INDIANS AND PASKENTA BAND OF
NOMLAKI INDIANS. THESE ANCESTORS
WILL REBURIED JUNE 2024 ON LAND
IDENTIFIED BY TRIBES AND AN
AGREEMENT AND COLLABORATION WITH
CHICO STATE. THE 2023 STATE
AUDIT NOTED THE UNIVERSITY WAS
CLOSE TO REPATRIATING A LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF ITS COLLECTION,
AND THAT DID IN FACT HAPPEN. THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE REPORT
HAVE HELPED US TO FURTHER
IMPROVE OUR PROCESSES. AS YOU
ALL KNOW, THE REPATRIATION
PROCESS IS COMPLEX AND LONG.
CHICO STATE BEGAN TO FOCUS ON
CONSULTATION IN 2019, AND IT'S
TAKEN FIVE YEARS OF DEDICATED
RESOURCES, EMPLOYEE HOURS AND
REPATRIATION AND PRIORITIZATION
TO BEGIN TO SEE REPATRIATION
PROGRESS. APPROPRIATE STAFFING
HAS BEEN CRITICAL TO THE PROCESS
AT CHICO STATE, REPATRIATION IS
FACILITATED BY CULTURAL
ARTIFACTS SPECIALIST DON
ROHOZINSKI, WHO IS AN
ADMINISTRATOR WITH THE ABILITY
TO MAKE DECISIONS AND WHO ALSO
POSSESSES A DEEP KNOWLEDGE OF
NAGPRA AND CAL. NAGPRA WITH THE
UPCOMING HIRE OF A DATA
COLLECTION SPECIALIST, CHICO
STATE WILL HAVE EIGHT
PROFESSIONALS AND STUDENT STAFF,
EMPLOYEES WORKING TOWARD NAGPRA
AND CAL. NAGPRA COMPLIANCE. OUR
UNIVERSITY IS FORTUNATE THROUGH
THE WORK OF OUR OFFICE OF TRIBAL
RELATIONS AND UNDER THE
DIRECTION OF RACHEL MCBRIDE
PRETORIUS, TO HAVE BUILT STRONG
RELATIONSHIPS WITH MANY AREA
TRIBES WHO WE HAVE CONSULTED
WITH, WHO HAVE CONSULTED WITH US
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS,
INCLUDING SERVING ON THE HIRING
COMMITTEE FOR THE CULTURAL
ARTIFACTS SPECIALISTS. THIS
FEEDBACK HAS BEEN INTEGRAL IN
OUR PROGRESS. OUR CULTURAL
ARTIFACT SPECIALIST WAS HIRED IN
DECEMBER 2021, HAVING HER ON
BOARD AND WORKING WITH THE
CAMPUS NATIVE AMERICAN
CONSULTATION AND REPATRIATION
COMMITTEE FOR THE LAST TWO AND A
HALF YEARS HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY
HELPFUL. WE ARE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUED TRIBAL CONSULTATION,
CONSULTATION WITH TRIBES AND
TRIBAL LEADERS, AND CONTINUING
TO UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN IMPROVE
OUR PRACTICES AND STRENGTHEN OUR
COMMITMENT TO TRIBAL
CONSULTATION, NAGPRA AND TRIBAL
RELATIONS TO PROVIDE A STATUS
UPDATE REGARDING WHAT WE WILL
STILL HAVE IN FRONT OF US.
CURRENTLY, LESS THAN 50
ANCESTORS REMAIN AND ARE UNDER
CHICO STATE'S CONTROL, THOUGH
THIS NUMBER MAY CHANGE AS WE
MOVE THROUGH CONSULTATION AND
REPATRIATION. THE CAMPUS ALSO
HAS 58,422 REMAINING CULTURAL
ITEMS, 14% OF WHICH ARE
CONTROLLED BY CHICO STATE. THESE
ARE LARGELY FROM 78 FEDERAL AND
94 STATE COLLECTIONS. IN
RESPONSE TO THE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE AUDIT, CHICO STATE
ESTABLISHED TWO DISTINCT SPACES
THE OFFICE OF TRIBAL RELATIONS
BUILDING, WHERE CONSULTATIONS
COULD BE CONDUCTED, AND A
SEPARATE, CULTURALLY SENSITIVE
STORAGE SPACE, A MODIFIED
CLASSROOM TO HOUSE ALL ANCESTORS
AND CULTURAL ITEMS IN A
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE AND SAFE
MANNER. ADDITIONALLY 20 NOTICES
HAVE BEEN PUBLISHED IN THE
FEDERAL REGISTERS, 15 NOTICES OF
INVENTORY COMPLETION, AND FIVE
NOTICES OF INTENDED REPATRIATION
HAVE BEEN FILED. FINALLY,
POLICIES HAVE BEEN DRAFTED ON
NAGPRA PRACTICES AND ARE
CURRENTLY UNDER LEGAL REVIEW AND
TRIBAL CONSULTATION. IN ADDITION,
CHICO STATE HAS BEEN IN
CONSULTATION WITH 13 TRIBES
INVITED TO CONSULT WITH 22
TRIBES AND CONDUCTED FOR STATE
AND FEDERAL AGENCY CONSULTATIONS.
REUNIFICATION OF COLLECTIONS HAS
OCCURRED WITH COLLECTIONS FROM
FIVE UNIVERSITIES UCLA, MICHIGAN
STATE UNIVERSITY, UC RIVERSIDE,
UC DAVIS, AND SONOMA STATE. TWO
STATE AGENCIES, CALTRANS AND
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS, AND ONE
FEDERAL AGENCY, US DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE. WE HAVE
CONSULTED WITH TRIBES WITHIN OUR
FOUR COUNTY REGIONAL AREA THAT
BORDERS BUTTE COUNTY. WE ARE
CURRENTLY MOVING FURTHER FURTHER
NORTH TO ENGAGE IN CONSULTATIONS.
CONSULTATION AND REPATRIATION
ALSO HAPPEN THROUGH TRIBAL
REQUESTS. WE WILL CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE IN CONSULTATION WITH
TRIBES UNTIL ALL COLLECTIONS ARE
REPATRIATED. YOUR GUIDANCE WILL
SHAPE OUR ACTIONS AS WE WORK
TOWARDS FOSTERING A MORE
RESPECTFUL AND EQUITABLE
RELATIONSHIP. YOUR PRESENCE HERE
TODAY IS DEEPLY APPRECIATED AND
YOUR VOICES ARE ESSENTIAL AS WE
ENDEAVOR TO MOVE FORWARD
TOGETHER, WE WILL CONTINUE TO
LISTEN TO TRIBAL LEADERS COMPLY
WITH THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ENSURE NAGPRA
COMPLIANCE, AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO REPATRIATE. AND AGAIN, THANK
YOU FOR INVITING US HERE TODAY
AND ALLOWING US TO SHARE OUR
PROGRESS. LISTEN AND LEARN FROM
YOU ABOUT HOW WE CAN DO BETTER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
TERESA MALDONADO, VICE PRESIDENT
OF RESEARCH AND INNOVATION FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAIR RAMOS, CHAIR
HART, MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS AND THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE. ALSO, GOOD AFTERNOON
TO THE TRIBAL LEADERS AND
RESPECTED GUESTS. I AM TERESA
MALDONADO, AND I SERVE AS THE
VICE PRESIDENT FOR RESEARCH AND
INNOVATION AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT. MY OFFICE LEADS THE
DEVELOPMENT ALL UPDATES AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE èC NATIVE
AMERICAN CULTURAL AFFILIATION
AND REPATRIATION POLICY. JOINING
ME FOR MY OFFICE ARE DOCTOR
DEBORAH MOTEN SITTING RIGHT HERE
BESIDE ME. SHE IS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE èC ÁP RESEARCH
POLICY ANALYSIS AND COORDINATION
COMMITTEE. AS WE CALL OUR PAC
DOCTOR. MOTEN WILL REPORT ON THE
STATUS OF èC REPATRIATION, ALSO
FROM RESEARCH AND INNOVATION, OR
MISS LOURDES DE MATOS, WHO IS
OUR PAC DIRECTOR, AND SHE IS
SITTING IN THE AUDIENCE AS WELL
AS SYSTEMWIDE REPATRIATION
COORDINATOR GLENIS ECHEVARRIA,
WHO IS CURRENTLY OUT OF THE
COUNTRY. BUT ON ZOOM AT THIS
MOMENT. IN ADDITION, WE HAVE THE
NEW UC BERKELEY CHANCELLOR
DOCTOR RICH LYONS, SITTING HERE
AS HIS AND HIS TEAM TO REPORT ON
THE BERKELEY SPECIFIC CAMPUS
ACTIVITIES. I AM HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING UC PRESIDENT
MICHAEL DRAKE AND UC SYSTEMWIDE
PROVOST KATHERINE NEWMAN.
ALTHOUGH THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO
BE HERE TODAY, I CAN SAY THAT
THEIR COMMITMENT TO REPATRIATION
IS UNWAVERING AND FOCUSED. YOU
WILL LEARN MORE ABOUT SOME
EXAMPLES OF THEIR COMMITMENT
TODAY. BEFORE I BEGIN, I'D LIKE
TO EXPRESS MY DEEPEST GRATITUDE
TO THE TRIBAL LEADERS WHO JUST
SPOKE IN THE PREVIOUS PANEL.
YOUR REMARKS WERE VERY POWERFUL
AND VERY MEANINGFUL TO ME
PERSONALLY, AND THEY WILL GUIDE
THE WORK THAT WE DO IN MY
OFFICE. THANK YOU. ALSO, I'D
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
CONGRATULATE YOU ON THE SPECIAL
FIFTH ANNUAL CALIFORNIA INDIAN
CULTURAL AWARENESS EVENT THAT
TOOK PLACE YESTERDAY. I WATCHED
IT LIVE STREAM AND THE SPIRITUAL
NATURE OF THAT EVENT CAME
THROUGH VERY STRONGLY. AND ALSO
RECOGNIZED THE ACR 140 ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN DAY. NOW FOR MY
UPDATE. FIRST, I WANT TO BEGIN
BY REITERATING OUR APOLOGY FOR
THE UNIVERSITY'S ROLE IN THE
ACQUISITION OF NATIVE AMERICAN
AND NATIVE HAWAIIAN ANCESTORS
AND THEIR CULTURAL ITEMS. THESE
ITEMS IN ANCESTRAL REMAINS WERE
OBTAINED IN VIOLATION OF
INDIGENOUS, SPIRITUAL AND
CULTURAL BELIEFS WITHOUT FREE,
PRIOR AND INFORMED CONSENT. UC
IS COMMITTED TO FULLY IMPLEMENT
THE SPIRIT AS WELL AS THE LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS OF BOTH NAGPRA AND
CAL NAGPRA. WE ACKNOWLEDGE AND
EMBRACE THE FUNDAMENTAL HUMAN
RIGHTS ENCOMPASSED IN THESE LAWS
AND NOW IN OUR POLICY. WE ARE
FULLY COMMITTED TO REPATRIATION
AND TO REPAIRING THE DAMAGE WE
CAUSE. UC'S CURRENT REPATRIATION
POLICY REPRESENTS A SIGNIFICANT
SHIFT BOTH IN LEVEL OF
COMMITMENT AND ACTION, MAKING
REPATRIATION OF FUNDAMENTAL
PRIORITY OF THE UNIVERSITY THE
CURRENT POLICY WAS FIRST ADOPTED
AS AN INTERIM POLICY IN JUNE
2020, AND SUBSEQUENTLY REVISED
TO INCORPORATE THE REQUIREMENTS
OF AB 275 PASSED IN SEPTEMBER
2020. REGARDING INVENTORIES AND
SUMMARIES, THE UC POLICY WAS
FINALIZED IN JANUARY 2022, AMONG
OTHER CHANGES, KEY CONCEPTS FROM
AB 275 REFLECTED IN THE POLICY
INCLUDE DEFERENCE TO TRIBAL
TRADITIONAL KNOWLEDGE, INCLUSION
OF ALL NATIVE AMERICAN
ARCHEOLOGICAL AND ETHNOGRAPHIC
OBJECTS IN UC SUBMITTED
SUMMARIES AND IDENTIFICATION OF
OBJECTS AS CULTURAL ITEMS BY BI
TRIBAL REPRESENTATIVES AND NOT
THE UNIVERSITY. WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF UPDATING THE POLICY
TO ALIGN WITH THE RECENTLY
REVISED NAGPRA REGULATIONS
ISSUED BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IN JANUARY 2024. FORTUNATELY,
BECAUSE OF MANY CONCEPTS FROM
CAL, NAGPRA WERE ADOPTED BY
NAGPRA, THE UC POLICY IS ALREADY
COMPLIANT IN SEVERAL AREAS. FOR
EXAMPLE, AS I JUST MENTIONED,
THE UC POLICY REQUIRES DEFERENCE
TO TRIBAL TRADITIONAL KNOWLEDGE.
IT ALSO PROHIBITS RESEARCH,
INSTRUCTIONAL, AND OTHER USE OF
NATIVE AMERICAN HUMAN REMAINS
AND CULTURAL ITEMS WITHOUT
EXPLICIT WRITTEN TRIBAL
AUTHORIZATION. IN ADDITION TO
IMPLEMENTING OUR POLICY, UC HAS
TAKEN SIGNIFICANT STEPS TO
ADVANCE REPATRIATION ACROSS THE
SYSTEM. WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED ALL
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR,
INCLUDING ISSUING GUIDANCE ON
CONSULTATIONS AND PROCESSES FOR
WORKING WITH PARTNER
INSTITUTIONS, HIRING FULL TIME
REPATRIATION COORDINATORS,
REQUIRING CAMPUS REPATRIATION
PLANS, AND BUDGETING FOR
REPATRIATION WORK. IN NOVEMBER
2023, PRESIDENT DRAKE COMMITTED
$5.7 MILLION FOR CAMPUS
REPATRIATION OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD, WITH CAMPUSES EXPECTED
TO FULLY FUND THEIR RESPECTIVE
ACTIVITIES AFTER FISCAL YEAR
2026. IN TOTAL, PRESIDENT DRAKE
HAS COMMITTED $10.4 MILLION
SINCE NOVEMBER 2021. CAMPUSES
ARE FACILITATING MORE
CONSULTATIONS AND REPATRIATION
SINCE 2018 THAN IN THE PRIOR 20
YEARS COMBINED. ANYONE CAN NOW
TRACK OUR PROGRESS ONLINE ON THE
UC REPATRIATION DASHBOARD. AND
IN CASES WHERE TRANSFER OF LEGAL
CONTROL HAS OCCURRED. BUT THE
TRIBES ARE NOT YET READY FOR
PHYSICAL TRANSFER, UC CAMPUSES
SUPPORT TRIBES PREFERENCES FOR
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE AND
RESPECTFUL CARE IN THE FORM OF
CARE AND TRUST AGREEMENTS. WE
ACKNOWLEDGE WE HAVE A LONG WAY
TO GO, BUT WE ARE TAKING
SIGNIFICANT STEPS IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. I WOULD LIKE TO
SPOTLIGHT SOME EXAMPLES FROM OUR
CAMPUSES AND OF COURSE, HERE
TODAY WE HAVE UC BERKELEY WHO
WILL PROVIDE THEIR SPECIFIC
UPDATE SO QUICKLY, STARTING WITH
UC DAVIS LAST FISCAL YEAR, THE
CAMPUS REPATRIATED 165 ANCESTRAL
REMAINS IN APPROXIMATELY 9000
CULTURAL ITEMS. UC DAVIS
ANTICIPATES REPATRIATING ALL
KNOWN NATIVE AMERICAN ANCESTORS
BY JUNE 2027. MOVING ON TO UCLA,
THEY CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS
REPATRIATION, TRANSFER AND
REBURIAL OF THE REMAINING 1% OF
KNOWN NATIVE AMERICAN ANCESTORS
ANCESTORS IN THEIR CONTROL. UC
RIVERSIDE SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASED CONSULTATION
FREQUENCY, PUBLICATION OF
NOTICES, AND REPATRIATION
ACTIONS IN THE LAST TWO YEARS.
THEY PUBLISHED 52 ACCESSIONS IN
FEDERAL NOTICES OF INVENTORY
COMPLETION AND INTENT TO
REPATRIATE, REPRESENTING A 766%
INCREASE JUST FROM 2022 TO 2021.
THEY CONDUCTED 64 CONSULTATIONS
REPRESENTING A 540% INCREASE,
AND THEY COMPLETED SEVEN
REPATRIATIONS AS COMPARED TO TWO
CUMULATIVELY IN THE PRIOR 21
YEARS. UC SANTA BARBARA HAS
CONSULTED ON FINALIZED AND
INVENTORY IN APRIL OF THIS YEAR
OF OVER 8000 FUNERARY OBJECTS,
WHICH WILL BE REPATRIATED TO THE
FEDERALLY AFFILIATED TRIBE IN
THE COMING MONTHS. THE CAMPUS IS
IN THE PROCESS OF IDENTIFYING
CAMPUS LAND THAT CAN BE USED TO
FACILITATE REBURIAL. SANTA
BARBARA HAS ALSO INITIATED
CONSULTATIONS WITH OVER 115
TRIBES THROUGHOUT THE WESTERN
UNITED STATES. THEIR GOAL IS TO
REPATRIATE ALL KNOWN NATIVE
AMERICAN ANCESTORS BY DECEMBER
2028. FINALLY, THEY CO-SPONSORED
A NAGPRA CAL NAGPRA WORKSHOP IN
JUNE 2024 WITH TRIBAL PARTNERS
FROM THE SANTA YNEZ BAND OF
CHUMASH INDIANS. THIS EVENT
AIMED TO BRING REPATRIATION
PRACTITIONERS TOGETHER TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT THE REGULATIONS AND
HOW WE CAN BETTER FACILITATE
REPATRIATION FROM A TRIBAL
PERSPECTIVE. THE LAST CAMPUS I
WILL SPOTLIGHT IS UC SAN DIEGO.
SINCE 2018, UC SAN DIEGO HAS
SUCCESSFULLY REPATRIATED 484
ANCESTORS AND 69 LOTS OF
ASSOCIATED FUNERARY OBJECTS.
MORE RECENTLY, THEY SUBMITTED A
NOTICE OF INTENT TO REPATRIATE
IN JUNE 2024 THAT WILL RESULT IN
THE RETURN OF 1922 LOTS OF
CULTURAL ITEMS, WHICH ARE
EQUIVALENT TO OVER 10,000
INDIVIDUAL ITEMS. THEIR
CONSULTATIONS REMAIN CONTINUOUS
WITH TRIBES ACROSS THE NATION,
INCLUDING 16 ADDITIONAL
CONSULTATIONS WITHIN THE PAST
SIX MONTHS WITH VARIOUS
CALIFORNIA TRIBES. UC SAN DIEGO
REMAINS COMMITTED TO
REPATRIATING ALL ANCESTRAL
REMAINS AND CULTURAL ITEMS TO
THE SAFETY AND PROTECTION OF
THEIR DESCENDANTS, AND
ANTICIPATES ACHIEVING THEIR
COMPLETION GOAL BY THE END OF
2027. NOW, I WILL RETURN TO TURN
TO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR MOTEN TO
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION ON OUR
REPATRIATION WORK. DOCTOR MOTEN.
THANK YOU, VICE PRESIDENT
MALDONADO AND THANK YOU,
ESTEEMED ASSEMBLY PERSONS AND
GUESTS, FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ABOUT UC'S EFFORTS TO
IMPLEMENT NAGPRA AND CAL. NAGPRA
WE TAKE THIS WORK EXTREMELY
SERIOUSLY. WE RECOGNIZE NOT ONLY
OUR LEGAL OBLIGATIONS TOWARD
REPATRIATION REPATRIATION, BUT
ITS DEEP SPIRITUAL SIGNIFICANCE
FOR TRIBAL NATIONS AND THE
PAINFUL PROCESS IT IS TO WORK
THROUGH. TODAY, I'LL BE SHARING
SOME KEY POINTS IN OUR RECENT
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE, WHICH
PROVIDES CURRENT DATA ABOUT UC
CAMPUS, UC'S CAMPUS HOLDINGS,
AND SUMMARIZES OUR ACTIONS SINCE
2018. IN RESPONDING TO AB 2836,
AB 275 AND AB 226, IN TERMS OF
DATA, WE REPORTED TO YOU
PROGRESS IN TERMS OF HOW MANY
AMERICANS, HOW MANY HUMAN
REMAINS IN AMERICA, ASSOCIATED
FUNERARY OBJECTS YOU SEE
PUBLISHED IN THE FEDERAL
REGISTER. AND OUT OF THOSE
NUMBERS, HOW MANY HAVE BEEN
REPATRIATED? THESE FIGURES
REPRESENT TWO STEPS IN THE
NAGPRA PROCESS THE FEDERAL
REGISTER NOTICE OF INVENTORY
COMPLETION MUST BE PUBLISHED
BEFORE THE LEGAL TRANSFER OF
CONTROL TO TRIBES TAKES PLACE.
CUMULATIVE CUMULATIVELY, UC
CAMPUSES HAVE PUBLISHED FEDERAL
REGISTER NOTICES FOR ABOUT
10,391 INDIVIDUALS, AND OUT OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS, CAMPUSES HAVE
REPATRIATED 5863. THERE ARE
THERE ARE AN ADDITIONAL 6211
INDIVIDUALS FOR WHOM
CONSULTATION IS ONGOING OR IS IN
EARLY STAGES FOR ASSOCIATED
FUNERARY OBJECTS, 200,053 756
ITEMS WERE LISTED IN THE UC
FEDERAL REGISTER NOTICES, AND
207,437 OF THESE WERE
REPATRIATED. THERE ARE 40,208
ASSOCIATED FUNERARY OBJECTS
STILL IN CONSULTATION, AND WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THOUSANDS MORE
WILL BE IDENTIFIED FOR
REPATRIATION AS CONSULTATIONS
CONTINUE. WE ALSO LAUNCHED A
NAGPRA DASHBOARD WITH MORE
DETAILED INFORMATION ABOUT
CAMPUS HOLDINGS, INCLUDING THE
REPATRIATION OF OTHER CULTURAL
ITEMS SUCH AS UNASSOCIATED
FUNERARY OBJECTS, SACRED OBJECTS
AND OBJECTS OF CULTURAL
PATRIMONY. THIS DASHBOARD WILL
BE UPDATED TWICE PER YEAR, AND
WE HOPE TO BUILD IT OUT TO
INCLUDE MORE FEATURES, SUCH AS
THE NUMBER OF CONSULTATIONS
CONDUCTED AND UC'S HOLDINGS BY
PLACE OF ORIGIN IN REGARDS TO AB
2836, AB 2836 REQUIRED UC TO
ADOPT AND IMPLEMENT A SYSTEM
WIDE REPATRIATION POLICY,
TOGETHER WITH A WORKGROUP
COMPRISED OF FOUR MEMBERS
NOMINATED BY THE UC PRESIDENT'S
NATIVE AMERICAN ADVISORY COUNCIL
AND FOUR MEMBERS NOMINATED BY
THE UC ACADEMIC SENATE. èC
DRAFTED SEVERAL ITERATIONS OF
THE POLICY. THE POLICY DRAFTS
WERE DISTRIBUTED BROADLY,
INCLUDING TO CALIFORNIA TRIBES.
THE CONSULTATION PROCESS WITH
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES INCLUDED
THREE OPEN PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIODS, FOUR WORK SESSIONS,
ONLINE SURVEYS, MULTIPLE ONE ON
ONE CONVERSATIONS, AND DIRECT
CORRESPONDENCE WITH NATIVE
AMERICAN STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THE POLICY. AS VICE
PRESIDENT, MALDONADO MENTIONED,
WAS ISSUED AS INTERIM IN JUNE
2020 AND COMPLETED AND FINALIZED
IN JANUARY OF 2022. UC IS
CURRENTLY REVIEWING AND DRAFTING
EDITS TO COMPLY WITH CHANGES IN
THE FEDERAL NAGPRA REGULATIONS.
THIS YEAR IN JANUARY, AND
CONSULTING WITH THE SYSTEMWIDE
COMMITTEE BEFORE ENGAGING IN
BROADER CONSULTATION IN REGARDS
TO THE AUDITS, AB 2836 ALSO
REQUIRED ESTABLISHMENT OF SYSTEM
WIDE AND CAMPUS LEVEL COMMITTEES
TO REVIEW AND ADVISE UC ON
NAGPRA AND CAL NAGPRA
IMPLEMENTATION. ALL COMMITTEES
HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE CAL CAL
NAGPRA REQUIREMENTS, INCLUDING
NOMINATION OF MEMBERS BY THE NHC.
FINALLY, AB 2836 REQUIRED TWO
AUDITS BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR, AND AS WE'VE HEARD, THE
FIRST WAS COMPLETED IN JUNE OF
2020 AND THE SECOND IN NOVEMBER
OF 2022. AND UC HAS IMPLEMENTED
ALL THE AUDITORS RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR BOTH OF THOSE AB 226
REQUIRED TWO MORE AUDITS IN 2024
AND 2026, AND THE 2024 AUDIT IS
UNDERWAY. AS WE'VE HEARD IN
REGARDS TO AB 275, IT WAS PASSED
ON SEPTEMBER 2020, REQUIRING
MUSEUMS TO COMPLETE PRELIMINARY
INVENTORIES AND SUMMARIES OF
NATIVE AMERICAN HUMAN REMAINS
AND CULTURAL ITEMS UNDER THEIR
LEGAL CONTROL IN CONSULTATION
WITH CALIFORNIA INDIAN TRIBES,
INDIAN TRIBES BY JANUARY 1ST,
2022, AND THEREAFTER TO SUBMIT
PRELIMINARY INVENTORIES AND
SUMMARIES TO THE NHRC WITHIN 90
DAYS. èC SUBMITTED INVENTORIES
AND SUMMARIES. HOWEVER,
CONSULTATION IS STILL ONGOING AS
CONSULTATION FOR EACH ACCESSION
IS COMPLETED WITH TRIBAL
CONCURRENCE. èC IS INFORMING
NHRC SO THAT INVENTORIES OR
SUMMARIES CAN BE MOVED FROM
PRELIMINARY TO FINAL STATUS.
REGARDING AB 226 PASSED IN
OCTOBER 2023, IT STRONGLY URGED
èC SUBMISSION OF ANNUAL
PROGRESS REPORTS TO THE
LEGISLATURE, FINANCIAL SUPPORT
FOR CAMPUS REPATRIATION EFFORTS,
AND A PROHIBITION ON THE USE OF
ANY NATIVE AMERICAN HUMAN
REMAINS OR CULTURAL ITEMS FOR
PURPOSES OF TEACHING OR RESEARCH
AT UC, èC SUBMITTED ITS FIRST
ANNUAL REPORTS TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN JUNE 2024. AS
MENTIONED BY VICE PRESIDENT
MALDONADO, PRESIDENT DRAKE HAS
COMMITTED $10.4 MILLION TO THE
REPATRIATION EFFORTS OF èC
SINCE NOVEMBER 2021. WE EXPECT
INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES WILL
ENTIRELY SUPPORT THEIR
RESPECTIVE REPATRIATION
ACTIVITIES AFTER FISCAL YEAR
2026, AND UCLP WILL MONITOR
CAMPUS BUDGETS TO ENSURE
SUFFICIENT AND APPROPRIATE
RESOURCES ARE ALLOCATED,
INCLUDING SUPPORT FOR TRIBAL
NEEDS. LASTLY, THE UC
REPATRIATION POLICY ALREADY
PROHIBITS THE USE OF ANY
IDENTIFIED OR POTENTIAL HUMAN
REMAINS AND CULTURAL ITEMS FOR
RESEARCH, INSTRUCTION, OR ANY
OTHER USE WITHOUT EXPLICIT
WRITTEN AUTHORIZATION FROM ALL
CULTURALLY OR CULTURALLY
AFFILIATED OR POTENTIALLY
CULTURALLY AFFILIATED TRIBES. IN
CONCLUSION, I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
UC'S COMMITMENT TO REPATRIATION
OF ALL NATIVE AMERICAN ANCESTORS
AND CULTURAL ITEMS CURRENTLY
HOUSED AT UC. WE UNDERSTAND THAT
IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
CORRECT THE HARM WE CAUSED AND
RETURN ANCESTORS AND THEIR
BELONGINGS AS EXPEDITIOUSLY AS
POSSIBLE. AND WHILE WE HAVE MADE
MANY STRIDES, WE ACKNOWLEDGE WE
HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE WORK
AHEAD OF US UNTIL WE REPATRIATE
ALL ANCESTORS AND CULTURAL
ITEMS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. IS THERE ANY OTHERS THAT
WANT TO TESTIFY FROM èC OR IS
THAT THE OTHERS WILL BE HERE FOR
QUESTIONS? QUESTIONS? HAVE YOU
AVAILABLE? ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THAT ENDS THAT
TESTIMONY. DID YOU STILL HAVE A
COMMENT, CHANCELLOR, RICHARD
LYONS, CHANCELLOR, UC BERKELEY.
GOOD MORNING, ESTEEMED TRIBAL
LEADERS, CHAIRS, RAMOS AND HART
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS MORNING'S
HEARING ON NAGPRA. I'M PLEASED
TO BE HERE TODAY TO SHARE
UPDATES ON REPATRIATION EFFORTS
AT UC BERKELEY. I'M HONORED AND
MOVED TO HEAR TESTIMONY FROM THE
TRIBAL LEADERS ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU. I'M FIVE WEEKS
INTO MY NEW ROLE. I HAVE A LOT
TO LEARN ABOUT THESE ISSUES, BUT
THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR ME
TO BE HERE TODAY TO DEMONSTRATE
MY AND BERKELEY'S COMMITMENT TO
THIS CRITICAL TOPIC. I HAVE OUR
CHANCELLOR'S DESIGNEE FOR
NAGPRA, ASSISTANT CHANCELLOR
CHRIS TREADWAY, AND OUR
REPATRIATION COORDINATOR, ALEX
LUCAS, HERE WITH ME, WHO CAN
HELP ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE. FIRST, I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND APOLOGIZE FOR
THE DEEP PAIN THAT THE
UNIVERSITY HAS CAUSED NATIVE
PEOPLE SINCE OUR FOUNDING
UNIVERSITY REPRESENTATIVES AND
OTHERS TOOK ANCESTORS AND SACRED
BELONGINGS WITHOUT TRIBAL
PERMISSION AND HELD THOSE
ANCESTRAL REMAINS AND BELONGINGS
AGAINST TRIBAL NATIONS AND
PEOPLE'S WISHES FOR THE PURPOSE
OF RESEARCH AND TEACHING. FOR
FAR TOO LONG. WE ARE LONG
OVERDUE IN HONORING OUR
COMMITMENT TO REPATRIATION AND
HAVE CREATED TOO MANY BARRIERS
IN THE PAST, WE HAVE LACKED
TRANSPARENCY WITH TRIBES ABOUT
WHAT WE STILL HOLD IN OUR
MUSEUMS, AND IN SOME INSTANCES
HAVE FAILED TO TREAT SOVEREIGN
TRIBAL REPRESENTATIVES WITH
APPROPRIATE RESPECT. WHEN COMING
TO CAMPUS. WHILE BERKELEY STILL
HAS A LOT TO DO IN ACKNOWLEDGING
AND OWNING THE VERY PAINFUL
HISTORY OF HARM TO NATIVE PEOPLE,
IN THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS, THE
UNIVERSITY HAS ABANDONED
PRACTICES THAT SLOWED OR IMPEDED
REPATRIATION, AND
COMPREHENSIVELY REFORMED AND
REVISED OUR REPATRIATION
POLICIES, PROCESSES, AND
PERSPECTIVES. I WANT TO CLEARLY
STATE MY STRONG COMMITMENT TO
THE FULL REPATRIATION OF ALL
NATIVE AMERICAN ANCESTORS AND
CULTURAL BELONGINGS HELD ON THE
CAMPUS, MY PREDECESSOR,
CHANCELLOR CHRIST, ALSO MADE
THIS COMMITMENT AND PUT INTO
PLACE A NUMBER OF IMPORTANT
CHANGES TO OUR POLICIES AND
PRACTICES. WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO
PROVIDE YOUR COMMITTEE WITH AN
UPDATE ON OUR PROGRESS, AND I'LL
FOCUS EFFORTS SINCE 2021. THE
LAST TIME UC BERKELEY APPEARED
BEFORE YOU. POINT ONE TRIBES ARE
NOW IN EMPOWERED IN THE
REPATRIATION PROCESS AT BERKELEY
TRIBAL KNOWLEDGE AND GEOGRAPHIC
LOCATION ARE GIVEN DEFERENCE AS
EVIDENCE OF CULTURAL AFFILIATION
IN REPATRIATION AND
CONSULTATION. TIMELINES ARE
DEVELOPED IN COLLABORATION WITH
TRIBES POINT TWO. THE CAMPUS IS
MOVED RESPONSIBILITY FOR OUR
REPATRIATION EFFORTS INTO THE
CHANCELLOR'S IMMEDIATE OFFICE.
MY IMMEDIATE OFFICE LED BY OUR
FIRST REPATRIATION COORDINATOR,
ALEX LUCAS. WE HAVE HIRED A
NUMBER OF ADDITIONAL NAGPRA
STAFF AND IMPORTANTLY, HAVE
INCLUDED TRIBAL REPRESENTATIVES
ON HIRING COMMITTEES TO ENSURE
THAT TRIBAL NEEDS AND
PERSPECTIVES ARE REFLECTED AND
RESPECTED IN OUR STAFFING. POINT
THREE THE NAGPRA CAMPUS
COMMITTEE, WHICH NOW CONSISTS OF
THREE UC AFFILIATES AND THREE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBAL REPRESENTATIVES, MEETS
REGULARLY TO APPROVE CLAIMS AND
ADVISE ON IMPLEMENTATION AND
POLICY MATTERS. SINCE 2017, THE
COMMITTEE HAS GONE BACK AND
APPROVED, PREVIOUSLY DENIED
CLAIMS AND HAS APPROVED EVERY
REPATRIATION CLAIM SINCE THEN.
POINT FOUR. IN OCTOBER 2023, THE
CAMPUS PUBLISHED A FEDERAL
NOTICE TO REPATRIATE 47% OF
ANCESTORS AND THEIR BELONGINGS
HELD AT BERKELEY. WE ARE
FINALIZING INVENTORIES AND
WRITING NOTICES FOR AN
ADDITIONAL 13 COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND ARE IN
CONSULTATION FOR 80% OF
ANCESTORS, WE CURRENTLY HOLD.
THESE ACTIVE CONSULTATIONS WILL
RESULT IN THE REPATRIATION OF
MORE THAN 7600 ANCESTORS. POINT
FIVE THE UNIVERSITY HAS
DEDICATED SIGNIFICANT FUNDING TO
NAGPRA EFFORTS AS WE MUST,
INCLUDING FUNDING FOR TRIBES TO
ASSIST WITH CONSULTATION RELATED
COSTS TOWARD REPATRIATION. THIS
CAMPUS LEVEL FUNDING IS IN
ADDITION TO THE LIMITED TERM
NAGPRA FUNDING FROM UCOP, THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT, WHICH
ENDS IN 2020 6.6. FINALLY, UNDER
CHANCELLOR CHRIST, THE CAMPUS
HIRED OUR FIRST TRIBAL LIAISON
AND DIRECTOR OF TRIBAL
RELATIONS, TEDDY SIMON, WHO IS
ALSO HERE. THIS POSITION WAS
RECOMMENDED BY A TRIBAL FORUM
SEVERAL YEARS AGO TO PROVIDE
TRIBES WITH A SINGLE POINT OF
CONTACT ON THE BERKELEY CAMPUS
AND TO FACILITATE SOVEREIGN
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
RELATIONSHIPS. TEDDY STRIVES TO
BUILD POSITIVE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH TRIBAL NATIONS WHILE
IMPROVING CAMPUS COMMUNICATION
PRACTICES AND POLICIES. ALTHOUGH
TEDDY DOESN'T DIRECTLY WORK ON
REPATRIATION, SHE DOES
COLLABORATE CLOSELY WITH THE
NAGPRA TEAM AS WE RECOGNIZE THIS
IS A PRIORITY ISSUE FOR MANY
TRIBES. COMPLETE AND
COMPREHENSIVE REPATRIATION IS AN
INSEPARABLE AND NECESSARY PART
OF UC BERKELEY'S COMMITMENT TO
BE A MORE INCLUSIVE COMMUNITY
AND TO BETTER SERVE ALL THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT OUR
REPATRIATION PROCESS EMPOWERS
TRIBES AND HAPPENS ON THIS,
HAPPENS ON A TIMELINE AND IN A
MANNER THAT WORKS FOR EACH TRIBE.
I WILL MAKE THIS A HIGH PRIORITY
FOR MY ADMINISTRATION, AND I'M
COMMITTED TO DOING ALL I CAN TO
SUPPORT THE REPATRIATION PROCESS
IN FULL PARTNERSHIP WITH NATIVE
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION. MY COLLEAGUES AND I
ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS WELL, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ALL OF YOUR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND UPDATING ON
PROGRESS AND AREAS THAT STILL
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED. IS THERE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE DÍAS
COMMENTS? ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR,
AND THANK YOU TO THE PANELISTS.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE GUESTS
THAT ARE ALSO JOINING US FOR THE
FOR THE HEARING THIS MORNING. I
JUST WANT TO GIVE A SPECIAL
RECOGNITION AND THANK YOU TO
DOCTOR GARCIA IN YOUR ROLE AS
THE NEW HEAD OF THE CSU, AS A
PROUD CSU ALUM, MYSELF AT CAL
STATE LA, IT'S A BIG TASK FOR
YOU TO TAKE ON, ESPECIALLY WITH
THE LEGISLATION THAT WE MOVE
FORWARD TO ENSURE THAT THE CSU'S
ARE IN ONE, IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE POLICIES THAT HAVE BEEN
SIGNED INTO LAW. BUT TO THAT
SET, A NEW MODEL AND A NEW
METHOD OF HOW WE WORK WITH OUR
NATIVE AND INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES TO ENSURE THAT
REPATRIATION IS PART OF THE
ONGOING PROCESS AND THAT WE
DELIVER RESULTS TO THE FOLKS
THAT ARE HERE TODAY AND THE
FOLKS THAT ARE WATCHING,
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR POST AND
FOR YOUR COMMENTS ON THAT. WERE
DELIBERATE, I BELIEVE,
INCREDIBLY AUTHENTIC AND REALLY
SET FORWARD A PATH WHEN YOU
STATED THAT YOU WILL
UNEQUIVOCALLY USE THE POWER OF
YOUR OFFICE TO ENSURE THAT THE
POLICIES ARE MET AND MOVE
FORWARD, I BELIEVE THAT, AND I
KNOW THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
GOING TO BE LOOKING AT THE WORK
VERY CLOSELY AS WE HAVE ALREADY
DONE, BUT I JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT YOU ALSO CAME
INTO TO POLICIES ALREADY MOVED,
MOVED FORWARD, AND THAT YOU ARE
DOING WHAT YOU CAN, TO ENSURE
THAT THAT ACTUALLY HAPPENS. I
THINK IT'S A NEW TONE FOR THE
CSU AND I HOPE ALSO A
RECOGNITION FOR THE UC
UNIVERSITIES AS WELL. AND SO I
THINK WE ALL WANT TO SEE WHAT'S
RIGHT, BEING DONE RIGHT, AND
THAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE, HOW HURT
SOME FOLKS ARE THAT THE PAIN AND
TRAUMA THAT IT'S CAUSED
THROUGHOUT DECADES AND REALLY
WORKING WITH OUR ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS TO DO THE RIGHT
THING, FOR, FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO I JUST WANTED TO
SAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, SO MUCH, CHAIRMAN HART, I
JUST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE, THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE CSU CAMPUSES,
CHANCELLOR GARCIA AND MR. PEREZ,
I THINK THAT YOUR PRESENCE HERE
IN PARTICULAR WITH THE TRACK
RECORD AT CSU CHICO, IS VERY,
VERY IMPORTANT TO SETTING THE
TONE, FOR BOTH THE CSU SYSTEM
AND THE UC SYSTEM. APPRECIATE
THE LEADERSHIP, CHANCELLOR FROM
BERKELEY BEING HERE AND THE VICE
CHANCELLOR AS WELL. AND STAFF,
THE COMMENTS THAT YOU MADE ABOUT
APOLOGIES TO THE NATIVE TRIBES,
I THINK IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS HAS
BEEN TREMENDOUS HARM DONE AND IS
CONTINUING, AND THAT THE SENSE
OF URGENCY THAT YOU FEEL TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES, I FELT
MYSELF AND I THINK THAT THAT AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARRILLO
MENTIONED, IS A NEW THING THAT
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. THERE STILL IS A
LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE AND I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU ARE HERE,
COMMITTED TO DOING THAT. AND
LOOK FORWARD TO THE PROGRESS
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE OVER
THE NEXT YEAR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. SO MEMBER GARCIA, THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WE APPRECIATE THE
TESTIMONY PROVIDED BY ALL OF THE
REPRESENTATIVES AT THE
UNIVERSITIES. AND ALTHOUGH IT
SOUNDS LIKE A LOT OF WORK HAS
GONE INTO THIS, AND A LOT OF
WORK WILL CONTINUE TO BE GOING
FORWARD, WE HAVE A CASE HERE OF
PERHAPS, IT NOT MOVING FAST
ENOUGH, IT SAID PERHAPS THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO MOVE
FASTER THAN WHAT WE HAVE, AND
THEN, OF COURSE, PERHAPS THERE'S
ALSO A REAL, CONVERSATION THAT
MAYBE HAS BEEN HAD OR NEEDS TO
BE HAD IN TERMS OF, REALISTIC
EXPECTATIONS ON HOW QUICKLY WE
CAN MOVE TO REPATRIATE, WHETHER
IT BE THE ANCESTRAL REMAINS OR
OTHER IMPORTANT AND TRADITIONAL
ARTIFACTS THAT BELONG TO OUR
NATIVE PEOPLE. AND I DON'T KNOW
IF THE LATTER HAS BEEN A
CONVERSATION WHERE WE ARE
SETTING REALISTIC EXPECTATIONS,
EXPECTED TIMELINES, BUT CLEARLY,
FROM WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM THE
FIRST TWO PANELISTS AND THE ONE
BEFORE YOU, ALL THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
HERITAGE, COMMISSION WITH THE
GRATON RANCHERIA, SAID IT'S
WE'RE FAR FROM WE'RE VERY FAR
FROM BEING ABLE TO MEET, THE
LEGAL EXPECTATIONS NOT TO
MENTION THE EMOTIONAL,
EXPECTATIONS AND THE DISTRESS
AND THE ANXIETY AND FRUSTRATION,
LEVEL OF EXPECTATIONS THAT HAVE
ACCUMULATED OVER THESE DECADES
FOR OUR NATIVE, PEOPLE WHO HAVE
TESTIFIED TODAY AND WHO
REPRESENT, YOU KNOW, THOUSANDS
OF OTHER, FIRST PEOPLES FROM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. SO I, I
GUESS MY QUESTION WOULD BE, WHAT
DOES THE LEGISLATURE NEED TO DO?
TO FURTHER SUPPORT THE EFFORTS
THAT ARE UNDERWAY BOTH FOR THE
UC AND THE CAL STATE? AND MY
HOPE WOULD BE THAT IT ISN'T US
SPENDING MORE MONEY ON MORE
AUDITS, BECAUSE I THINK THE
PROBLEM HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED AND
THOSE RESOURCES THAT GO TOWARDS
THE AUDITS, THE TIME, ENERGY AND
RESOURCES THAT GO TOWARDS THE
AUDITS COULD VERY WELL GO
TOWARDS THE ACTUAL ACTION
ORIENTATED STEPS TO GET THESE,
INDIVIDUALS AND, OTHER ITEMS
THAT BELONG TO OUR FIRST PEOPLES
BACK IN THEIR POSSESSION. SO I
IT'S A QUESTION THAT GOES AROUND
THE TABLE, EARLIER MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
ASKED A QUESTION TO THE PRIOR,
PANEL. SHOULD WE BE MANDATING
CERTAIN TYPES OF, PRACTICES SO
THAT OUR FUTURE ACADEMICS, ARE
ALSO ADHERING TO A MUCH MORE
ETHICAL AND CULTURALLY COMPETENT
AND SENSITIVE APPROACH TO
DEALING WITH THESE ISSUES SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT POTENTIALLY
PROFESSORS WHO RETIRE, TAKING
SOME OF THESE POSITIONS THAT
AREN'T EVEN THE UNIVERSITIES
THEY BELONG TO THE FIRST PEOPLES
OF VERY DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
STATE. I MEAN, THAT IN ITSELF
JUST SOUNDS REALLY BAD, THAT
ANYBODY WOULD WOULD DO THAT. AND
I GATHER FROM THE TESTIMONY AND
I'LL STOP MY COMMENTS TO GET
SOME RESPONSES, IS THAT EVERYONE
HERE, IS WORKING UNDER THE
NOTION AND THE PREMISE THAT
WE'RE TREATING THIS ISSUE LIKE
IF IT WAS OUR OWN FAMILY AND
RELATIVES, AND HOW WOULD WE WANT
THIS ISSUE TO BE TAKEN CARE OF?
BECAUSE IF WE'RE STARTING FROM
THAT PREMISE, THEN THERE'S NO
REASON WHY WE COULDN'T GET TO
THE END GOAL AND MAKING SURE
THAT 100% OF THINGS THAT ARE IN
POSSESSION OF THE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM GET BACK TO THE FIRST
PEOPLES, GOVERNMENTS AND TRIBAL
NATIONS. SO I'LL STOP THERE. AND
I'D LOVE TO HEAR THOSE TWO
QUESTIONS. YOU KNOW, HOW MORE
CAN WE BE SUPPORTIVE? NUMBER TWO
IS, YOU KNOW, THE ISSUE OF
MANDATING OUR ACADEMICS TO GO
THROUGH CERTAIN TRAININGS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH OUR TRIBAL,
LEADERS, TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
TYPES OF THINGS DON'T OCCUR. I
BELIEVE YOU HEAR THE URGENCY
FROM US AND THE PAIN THAT WE
FEEL FOR WHAT WE HAVE DONE. LET
ME BEGIN THERE. WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE TIME BECOMES
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE MUST
INCLUDE TRIBAL LEADERS AND
TRIBAL VOICES IN THE PROCESS. WE
WOULD WE WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE
TO DO THIS RIGHT AWAY, BUT THAT
WOULD BE DISRESPECTFUL TO THE
TRIBAL LEADERS AND THOSE WHO
KNOW BEST HOW TO BRING BACK THE
CULTURAL ANCESTORS AND ITEMS
BACK TO THEM. LET ME BEGIN.
THERE SECONDLY, YOU ASKED ABOUT
WHAT CAN YOU DO HOLD US
ACCOUNTABLE? WE HAVE SAT AT THIS
TABLE AND SAID WE WILL DO. AND
SO IT IS ALL JUST LIKE I AM
COMMITTED TO HOLDING MY
PRESIDENTS AND MY BOARD IS
COMMITTED TO HOLDING ME
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THIS. THESE
OVERSIGHTS WILL LET US GIVE YOU
AN UPDATE OF WHAT WE ARE DOING
EVERY DAY. AND FINALLY, WE ARE
TRAINING ON OUR CAMPUSES AND OUR
STAFFS. WHAT IS THE PROCESS?
WHAT IS THE LAW? WHAT IS THE
CULTURE OF CARE THAT WE SHOULD
BE DOING OUR WORK IN THIS
PROCESS OF REPATRIATION? THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. ANY
COMMENTS FROM èC ON THE
QUESTION? I HAVE A FOLLOW UP,
BUT PLEASE, THE FIRST PART, GO
AHEAD. SO I ARRIVED AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA, THREE
DAYS BEFORE COVID SHUT DOWN AND
MY OFFICE WAS WORKING ON THE,
THE, THE REPATRIATION POLICY,
WHICH IS WHY WE HAD AN INTERIM
IN JUNE 2020, WAS BECAUSE OF
COVID. MY OBSERVATIONS HAVE BEEN,
COMING, YOU KNOW, MOVING HERE
FROM OUT OF STATE AND IN,
ENGAGING IN THIS, IN THIS
IMPORTANT WORK IS, I SEE I SAW A
LOT OF PEOPLE TALKING PAST EACH
OTHER, SO THERE WAS NOT A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THEIR
ISSUES WERE, ARE. AND I THINK
THERE'S MORE CLARITY TODAY AS WE
WORK THROUGH SOME OF THESE,
MISUNDERSTANDINGS JUST IN OUR
OWN OFFICE. BUT ALSO OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT AND WITH THE
CAMPUSES ALSO, AS DOCTOR MOTEN
KNOWS, I'LL ASK ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY OF BEHAVIORS THAT
WE SEE AND TO BE CLEAR ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY, THE THIRD THING
I NOTICED IS THAT WE NEEDED TO
HIRE COORDINATORS AND LIAISONS.
BUT WHAT DID THE JOB
DESCRIPTIONS LOOK LIKE? AND SO
WE NEED TO BE CLEAR ABOUT JOB
DESCRIPTION DESCRIPTIONS OF WHAT
TYPES OF SKILLS WE ARE SEEKING
SO THAT WHOEVER WE HIRE CAN HIT
THE GROUND RUNNING. IN MEETING
THE MISSION. AND, AND ALSO, LIKE
A RULE OF ENGAGEMENT IS NOT TO
BE DEFENSIVE IN MEETINGS, BUT TO
REALLY HASH OUT VERY IMPORTANT,
CHALLENGING ISSUES. AND, YOU
KNOW, CHALLENGE EACH OTHER AND
TRY TO ACHIEVE A COMMON GOALS IN
DIRECTION. SO THOSE ARE JUST
DYNAMICS THAT I HAVE OBSERVED
SINCE I'VE BEEN AT UC FOR THE
PAST FOUR YEARS. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. YOU HAD A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION, MEMBER GARCIA, UNLESS
THERE'S UNLESS THERE'S SOMEONE
ELSE WHO WANTED TO RESPOND, I
DO. I CAN WAIT TILL GO AHEAD.
OKAY, SO MY FOLLOW UP QUESTION,
IN TERMS OF THE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND THE OVERSIGHT, I MEAN, WE
CAN HAVE THESE HEARINGS THREE
TIMES A YEAR, AND THAT TAKES A
LOT OF TIME AND ENERGY, OF
COURSE, FROM FOLKS. BUT BUT THE
ACCOUNTABILITY I MEAN, WE DON'T
HAVE, WE DON'T HIRE AND FIRE,
YOU, AND OR ANY OTHER PRESIDENT
OF ANY INSTITUTION. RIGHT. AND
SO WE CAN'T HOLD FOLKS
ACCOUNTABLE DIRECTLY IN THAT
MANNER, WE COULD TALK ABOUT
BUDGETS AND, YOU KNOW, PENALIZE
THE UNIVERSITIES IN THAT MANNER
THAT WOULD HAVE OTHER ULTIMATE
OTHER CONSEQUENCES, THAT'S
PROBABLY NOT THE RIGHT APPROACH.
RIGHT TO HOLD FOLKS ACCOUNTABLE
AT THE UNIVERSITIES. AND SO I
WOULD ASK RIGHT ACROSS THE TABLE
HERE, HOW DO WE, ADEQUATELY, AND
RESPONSIBLY AND RESPECTFULLY
HOLD YOU ACCOUNTABLE, WHEN YOU
KNOW, ASIDE FROM JUST HAVING
MORE HEARINGS AND SHEDDING LIGHT
TO THE PROBLEM AND BUILDING ON
THE EMOTIONAL ROLLER COASTER
THAT IT CREATES EVERY TIME WE
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION FOR ALL
OF US, MORE SO, YOU KNOW, THOSE
WHO ARE IMPLICATED BY THESE
ISSUES. FIRST PEOPLES, LET'S
TALK ABOUT LIKE, WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE ASIDE, JUST MORE HEARINGS,
MORE AUDITS. AND, AND MORE
CONVERSATIONS LIKE THIS. PLEASE
I'M TRAINED AS AN ECONOMICS
PROFESSOR, SO IT'S HARD FOR ME
TO GET AWAY FROM YOUR BUDGET
ANGLE, BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
MEANINGFUL. WE HAD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OVER HERE TALKING ABOUT
HOW YOU ALL HEAR FROM US
REGULARLY. WE NEED THIS. WE NEED
THAT. WE NEED THIS FOR VARIOUS
DIFFERENT TOPICS, ASK ASK YOUR.
ASK THEM. ASK ME WHEN I COME AND
TALK TO YOU ABOUT I NEED MONEY
FOR A BUILDING. WE'LL SAY, WELL,
HOW ARE YOU DOING ON
REPATRIATION, BUT HAVE THAT BE.
THAT'S WHAT MY BOSS IS GOING TO
DO WHEN I TALK TO HER IN A MONTH
OR TWO, DURING DURING MY REVIEW.
HOW ARE WE DOING ON
REPATRIATION? WHAT HAVE WE DONE
SINCE, SINCE WE TALKED ABOUT IT
IN AUGUST, HOW ARE THINGS GOING?
SO. SO KEEP IT TOP OF MIND, I
WILL SAY THAT'S I THINK HOW TO
KEEP HOLD US ACCOUNTABLE. BUT
I'LL REITERATE SOMETHING THAT
YOU SAID, SOMETHING THAT YOU
SAID THAT ACCOUNTABILITY MATTERS.
IT MATTERS A LOT, BUT IN THIS
AREA, I DON'T THINK IT'S THAT
HARD TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
RIGHT THING TO DO IS. RIGHT.
WHEN ONCE YOU'VE COME TO THE
UNDERSTANDING, THE REALIZATION
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE'S ANCESTORS AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CULTURES THAT WERE
ANCESTORS ARE DEEPLY, DEEPLY
VALUED AND DEEPLY IMPORTANT, AND
THE PAIN THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH
HOW THOSE ANCESTORS HAVE BEEN
TREATED AT OUR HANDS. IT'S NOT
HARD FOR US TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THE RIGHT THING TO DO IS. SO I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO HOLD US
ACCOUNTABLE. BUT I, AS MY
CHANCELLOR HAS SAID, I PROMISE
YOU, WE'RE GOING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING. MOVING FORWARD, IF I MAY,
THIS IS GLENNIS FROM THE VIRTUAL
PLATFORM. HI. HELLO HI,
EVERYONE, THANK YOU SO MUCH, FOR
INCLUDING ME HERE TODAY. AND I'M
SORRY I WASN'T ABLE TO JOIN IN
PERSON, I JUST WANTED TO ADD IN
THIS QUESTION BECAUSE I THINK,
YOU KNOW, A COMMON THEME I HEARD
COME UP TODAY IS ABOUT HOW THE
SUCCESS OF REPATRIATION. AND I
FOUND THIS IN MY WORK, AS WELL
AS TO THE KEYS TO REALLY TO
UPLIFT TRIBES. AND WE TALKED
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, EARLIER, YOU
KNOW, WHAT IS THE BEST
ALLOCATION OF RESOURCES? AND I
THINK SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD,
REALLY LIKE TO SEE, IF THE STATE
WOULD BE ABLE TO HELP WITH IS TO
ESTABLISH A REPATRIATION FUND,
NOT FOR INSTITUTIONS. AND NOT TO
COME TO UC OR TO CSU, BUT, FUNDS
TO GO TO THE TRIBES, BECAUSE WE
DO WE, YOU KNOW, AS TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE CAN, ALLOCATE,
FUNDS TO HELP WITH CONSULTATIONS
AND OTHER EXPENSES THAT HAVE
BEEN TALKED ABOUT TODAY. BUT,
YOU KNOW, WHEN IT COMES TO, YOU
KNOW, FURTHER WORK THAN THAT,
REBURIAL AND SO ON, WE TRY TO,
COVER COSTS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
AS WELL AT THE UC CAMPUSES. BUT,
I THINK ESTABLISHING SOME KIND
OF PARALLEL TO THE, THE FEDERAL
GRANT PROGRAM, THE FEDERAL
NATIONAL NAGPRA GRANT PROGRAM,
FOR CAL NAGPRA, FOR CALIFORNIA
INDIAN TRIBES WOULD BE,
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT, YOU
KNOW, I THINK WOULD BE A WORTHY,
WORTHY USE OF FUNDS, AND I THINK
ANOTHER A SECOND THING IS WHERE,
YOU KNOW, TALKING ABOUT, THE
ROLE OF THE LEGISLATURE HERE IS
JUST, MAYBE A REEXAMINATION OF,
OF NAGPRA. AS, COMMISSIONER
MCMILLAN SAID EARLIER, WE ARE
LOOKING AT WHAT THE FEDERAL
PROCESS AND THE STATE PROCESS
LOOKED LIKE TOGETHER. AND I
THINK, YOU KNOW, GREATER
GUIDANCE AND GREATER CLARITY
ABOUT THE TWO PIECES OF
LEGISLATION AND WHETHER, KARNAK
WAS A PIECE OF LEGISLATION
SHOULD BE, YOU KNOW, AS
COMPATIBLE IN THE WITH THE
FEDERAL, LEGISLATION WOULD BE
WOULD BE VERY APPRECIATED. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
AND THANK YOU FOR, JUMPING UP ON
THE SCREEN SO QUICKLY. THERE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS? SENATOR
GARCIA? SO THE MEMBER RIVAS,
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I THINK,
YOU KNOW, WE ALL AGREE THAT,
THESE REMAINS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ARE NOT JUST HISTORICAL
ARTIFACTS. YOU KNOW, THEY'RE
REMAINS OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
DESERVE PROPER RESTING PLACE.
THEY BELONG TO FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE LONG
AWAITED THEIR RETURN. AND WE ARE
WRONG, TO KEEP THESE IN OUR
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS IN A LAB OR
AT A RETIRED PROFESSOR'S HOMES,
AND, YOU KNOW, I KNOW ALL OF YOU
HAVE ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THAT THIS
REMAINS A CYCLE OF INJUSTICE,
AND, YOU KNOW, BUT THERE IS A
HISTORY OF NONCOMPLIANCE. AND,
YOU KNOW, THERE'S YOU KNOW, HALF
OF CSU CAMPUSES AND, THE UCS
THAT HAVE NOT RETURNED ANYTHING,
AND, YOU KNOW, THERE'S NO
CONSENT OF TRIBES TO WRITE
PAPERS ON THESE ITEMS THAT DON'T
BELONG TO US. THE STATE
UNIVERSITIES. AND, YOU KNOW,
YOU'VE, YOU KNOW, OUTLINED SOME
OF THE RESPONSES TO THE AUDIT OR
WHAT YOU'RE DOING, BUT HOW LONG
DOES IT REALLY TAKE TO WRITE A
JOB DESCRIPTION TO HIRE THE
STAFF? AND, YOU KNOW, SO I DON'T
SEE ANY TIMELINES AND MAYBE I
HAVEN'T, YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW,
WHAT ARE THE TIMELINES FOR EACH
OF YOUR CAMPUSES ARE. AND IN
TERMS OF I KNOW MY COLLEAGUE
TALKED ABOUT, WHAT CAN WE DO TO
HOLD YOU ACCOUNTABLE, AND WHEN
YOU'RE COMING TO REQUEST,
SOMETHING IN THE BUDGET, I ALSO
EXPECT AS A LEGISLATOR THAT
YOU'RE PROACTIVE AND THAT YOU
TELL ME, WHAT THE UPDATE IS ON
ON THIS ON REPEAT REPATRIATION,
AND NOT FOR ME TO MY STAFF TO
HAVE TO PUT THAT IN AS A
QUESTION, IF I'M MEETING WITH A
CSU OR A UC, YOU KNOW, THIS IS
IMPORTANT TO US, YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE TWO CHAIRS OF COMMITTEES.
THAT TAKE A LOT OF TIME TO
ORGANIZE THESE HEARINGS, WE
SPEND A LOT OF TIME AND
RESOURCES OF STATE FUNDS ON
THESE AUDITS, TOO. AND, YOU KNOW,
I EXPECT THAT, YOU KNOW, WE GET
UPDATES AND NOT JUST WHEN WE
REACH OUT, AS STATE LEGISLATORS
AND SO I JUST WANT TO KNOW,
LIKE, WHAT YOUR SYSTEMS WILL DO
TO BE PROACTIVE, TO REACH OUT TO
US AND NOT WAIT FOR US TO ASK
THAT QUESTION. WHEN YOU'RE
ASKING FOR $10 MILLION FOR A NEW
BUILDING AT YOUR CAMPUS, FIRST
OF ALL, LET ME SAY THAT WE AGREE
WITH WHAT YOU'RE SAYING. THAT'S
NUMBER ONE. THERE IS NO ARGUMENT
OVER THAT. SECOND OF ALL, I KNOW
THAT OUR OFFICE IS KEEPING IN
TOUCH WITH THOSE WHO ARE
IMPORTANT, AND WE CAN SEND OUR
UPDATES TO ALL THE LEGISLATORS
ON THE COMMITTEE IF THAT'S WHAT
WE NEED TO DO IN ORDER TO SHOW
YOU THAT WE ARE WORKING AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN, BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT WE MUST REPATRIATE.
AS I SAID EARLIER, I THINK IT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT WE WORK
WITH OUR TRIBAL LEADERS AND SO
THAT DOES TAKE TIME. I WILL BE
THE FIRST ONE TO SAY THAT TRIBAL
LEADERS HAVE LOST TRUST IN US,
AND WE MUST REGAIN THAT TRUST TO
BUILD THAT RELATIONSHIP AND SHOW
HOW WE ARE WORKING TOGETHER AND
GETTING THEIR VOICE AND THAT
THEIR VOICE MATTERS. THAT IN OUR
SYSTEMWIDE POLICY, FOR EXAMPLE,
THEIR COMMENTS ARE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY. ALL OF THAT IS A
PROCESS. AND SO WHILE I WOULD
LOVE TO DO IT EXTREMELY FAST, WE
MUST WORK WITH THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN AFFECTED TO GET THEIR
ANCESTORS BACK. BUT, YOU KNOW, I
HOPE THAT THAT RESULTS. YOU KNOW
THAT, YOU KNOW, I KNOW THE
BUILDING AND YOU LIKE YOU SAID,
YOU HAVE TO BUILD TRUST, AND
THAT RESULTS IN, LIKE, CONCRETE
DATES AND TIMELINES THAT GOALS
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO REACH AND
NOT WAITING FOR THE RESULTS OF
THESE FUTURE AUDITS. RIGHT.
WE'RE WAITING FOR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO COME OUT AND
THEN TRYING TO RESPOND TO EACH
RECOMMENDATION. RIGHT. I THINK I
MEAN, THESE ARE OUR, YOU KNOW,
UNIVERSITIES THAT PRODUCE HIGH
QUALITY RESEARCH ARE RENOWNED
AROUND THE WORLD. I KNOW YOU
KNOW HOW TO DO THIS, AND, AND SO
I BELIEVE THAT, THAT YOU CAN,
AND LIKE YOU SAID, IT DOES
REQUIRE SOME TIME AND TRUST, BUT
YOU KNOW, I JUST WANT TO SEE,
LIKE, GOALS AND ACTUAL DATES.
WELL, THANK YOU, ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RIVAS, FOR BRINGING THAT UP AND
REALLY BEING MORE PROACTIVE
RATHER THAN ON THE QUESTION OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. HOLD, HOLD. YOU
ACCOUNTABLE, BUT BEING MORE
PROACTIVE IN ENGAGING THE
LEGISLATURE TO LET US KNOW WHERE
YOU TRULY ARE IN THE PROCESS. I
DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE SOME OF
THE MEMBER TÍNH WHO HAS JOINED
US HERE, ON THE DAIS. IS THERE
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS,
FOR THE CURRENT PANEL. SO I'M
LOOKING AND STARTING WITH THE
CAL STATES, THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE APOLOGY. IT'S BEEN 30 YEARS,
THOUGH, AND WE'RE STILL AT THE
TABLE HERE TODAY WHERE THE AUDIT
IDENTIFIED, WHAT, LESS THAN 6%?
AND THEN, SPEAKERS FROM THE
TRIBAL LEADERS IDENTIFIED THAT
IT'S NOT JUST THE NUMBER OF A
COLLECTION, 510 COLLECTIONS
EQUATED TO 300,000. ASSOCIATED,
NATIVE AMERICAN REMAINS,
COMPONENTS THAT ARE THERE. SO
IT'S NOT JUST THE NUMBER. AND WE
COULD MULTIPLY THAT AND KNOW HOW
SEVERE THE ISSUE TRULY IS. BUT
THE QUESTION ALSO IS HOW DO WE
STOP THE FLOW OF, OF REMAINS
COMING INTO THE CAMPUS? HAS
THERE BEEN A DIRECTIVE,
STATEWIDE, TO STOP THAT FLOW OF
MOVING FORWARD? WE HEARD FROM
OTHER TRIBAL LEADERS, AS FAR AS
THE CONCERN OF FILLED SCHOOLS
CONTINUING TO MOVE FORWARD, WITH
SUPPORT FROM THE ACADEMIA WORLD,
SO THE REASON I'M BRINGING THIS
UP, IF WE GET A HANDLE ON THE
REPATRIATION AND WE GET THE
REMAINS, BACK TO THE RIGHTFUL
PEOPLE, THE NATIVE AMERICAN
PEOPLE. AND AGAIN, THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING UP NATIVE HAWAIIANS
BECAUSE THEIR REMAINS ARE ALSO
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
DRASTICALLY, INTERESTED IN
MAKING SURE THAT THAT COMES TO
RESOLVE ALSO. BUT HOW DO WE STOP,
THAT INFLOW? HOW DO WE ADDRESS
THAT? WITH THE FIELD SCHOOLS,
THE STUDIES THAT CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD. AND WE HEARD FROM
OTHERS THAT MAYBE IT'S TIME THIS
LEGISLATURE LOOKS AT, HOLDING
SOME PROFESSIONS ACCOUNTABLE.
FOR USING THOSE REMAINS FOR
FUTURE, EDUCATIONAL PURPOSES OR
EVEN HOLDING CURRENT PROFESSORS
OR RETIRING PROFESSORS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR REMAINS OF LOVED
ONES THAT THEY CONSIDER TO BE
THEIR PROPERTY. HOW DO WE MOVE
FORWARD? LET ME BEGIN WITH THE
FIELD SCHOOLS. LIKE WE HEARD
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE SPEAKING
ABOUT, AND WE WILL GO BACK AND
INVESTIGATE THROUGH OUR
CAMPUSES, WE ALSO HEARD THAT
SOMETIMES IF YOU DO IT IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE TRIBE. SO
LET US GO BACK AND FIND OUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THESE FIELD
SCHOOLS, HOW MANY WE HAVE, DO DO
OUR CAMPUSES DO THIS AND COME
BACK AND GIVE YOU SOME
INFORMATION ON THAT? HOW DO WE
STOP? WE STOP WITH THE PEOPLE WE
HIRE. WE'RE HIRING ALL THESE
COORDINATORS AND THERE'S GOING
TO BE AN OFFICE AND CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE TO ENSURE THAT WHEN
SOMEBODY APPROACHES US THAT WE
HAVE TRAINED EVERYBODY SAY, HEY,
WAIT A MINUTE, HAVE YOU INCLUDED
THE TRIBAL LEADERS IN THIS? AND
MAKE SURE THAT THE TRIBAL
LEADERS AND OUR NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE COMMISSION, FOR EXAMPLE,
IS INCLUDED TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYBODY'S ON THE SAME PAGE AND
THAT WE ARE NOT ACCEPTING THINGS
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING. THAT'S
WHY TRAINING IS SO IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. AND TRAINING
WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS BROUGHT
UP AS FAR AS, MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE WERE UP TO SPEED ON THE
LAWS, CAL, NAGPRA AND THE
FEDERAL LAW ALSO. SO WE TALKED
ABOUT JOB DESCRIPTIONS AND THOSE
THINGS. BUT THERE HAS TO BE THAT
KNOWLEDGE ALSO, AND AT THE CAL
STATE AT CHICO, STATE, YOU'RE
ABLE TO BE ONE OF THE TOP
VIOLATORS AND MOVE FORWARD,
THROUGH A DIRECTIVE ON YOUR
CAMPUS TO START TO COMPLY.
WITHOUT THE COMING BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND SAYING THAT YOU
NEEDED MORE FUNDING TO DO THAT
SO THAT SHOWS THAT IF THERE IS A
WILL, THERE'S A WAY TO MOVE
FORWARD. AND YOU GOT THOSE,
MEMBERS IN THOSE BOARDS FILLED
WITH PEOPLE. HOW DID THAT
TRANSPIRE? WAS IT OUTREACH
YOURSELF, TAKING THE INITIATIVE
TO THE LOCAL TRIBES IN THE AREA?
HOW CAN WE SHOW THAT WHERE THE
WILL IS THERE TO COMPLY? THAT IT
IS IT IS POSSIBLE TO GET THAT
DONE. AND WHAT STEPS SHOULD
OTHERS LOOK AT, IN MAKING SURE
THAT THAT'S TAKING PLACE? WELL,
LET ME JUST SAY THE PROGRESS
THAT WE'VE SHOWN AND AS I TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER, IS FIVE YEARS IN
THE MAKING. RIGHT. AND IT'S BEEN
A LONG NOT LONG ENOUGH CLEARLY,
COMMITMENT TO DOING THIS WELL
AND TO DOING IT RIGHT. IT
STARTED UNDER A PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION, AT CHICO STATE.
AND I'VE TRIED AS HARD AS I CAN
TO MAINTAIN THAT, THAT
COMMITMENT. AND WE WILL MAINTAIN
THAT COMMITMENT INTO THE FUTURE.
AND SO WE'VE BUILT UP A, A
REALLY TALENTED OFFICE OF TRIBAL
RELATIONS WITH REALLY SMART
PEOPLE THAT ARE VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT CONSULTATION AND ABOUT
DOING THIS WELL AND ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE BRINGING TRIBAL
LEADERS IN, EXPERTS IN THE AREA.
THEY WORK IN THE OFFICE, AND,
AND TRUE CONSULTATION IS THE
RESULT OF THAT, AND FROM THAT, I
BELIEVE THAT WE'RE BUILDING UP
TRUST OF THE UNIVERSITY, THAT
OUR INTENT IS TO DO THIS WELL.
AND SO IT'S BOTH, WHEN WE TALK,
WE TALK ABOUT THINGS. TAKE TIME.
IT IT HAS TAKEN TIME. IT'S TAKEN
TIME FOR US TO SORT THROUGH WHAT
WE WERE DOING WRONG, HOW DO WE
DO IT BETTER? AND DOING IT UNDER
THE LEADERSHIP AND THE GUIDANCE
OF TRIBAL LEADERS IN OUR AREA,
BUT WITHIN OUR OFFICE OF TRIBAL
RELATIONS AS WELL, AND MAKING
SURE WE CONTINUE THAT
COMMITMENT, THAT'S I THINK, HOW
WE'VE MADE PROGRESS AND THAT'S
HOW WE WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE
PROGRESS. WELL, THANK YOU, FOR
THAT. AND I KNOW THERE WAS
UPDATES, OF COMPLIANCE AND
MOVING FORWARD AND, CONTINUING
TO WORK TOGETHER WITH THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES MOVING FORWARD. AND
WE HEARD FROM OTHER TRIBAL
LEADERS, THAT REACHING OUT TO
THE TRIBES FROM THE LOCAL
CAMPUSES COULD BE AN INITIATIVE
RATHER THAN, REACTING, BEING
MORE PROACTIVE TO ENGAGEMENT,
COULD SERVE, THE CAMPUSES THERE.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT
REPATRIATION IS SOMETHING THAT
IS MOVING FORWARD. BUT I AM
INTERESTED TO HEAR BACK FROM THE
CAL STATE UNIVERSITIES, AND
WE'LL GET TO THE UCS IN A MOMENT
OF HOW YOU'RE GOING TO STEM THAT,
FROM REMAINS COMING INTO THE
CAMPUSES ALTOGETHER SO THAT
WE'RE NOT BACK INTO THIS PLACE.
AND I APPRECIATE THE FIVE YEARS
THAT IT TOOK TO GET THERE. BUT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A LAW THAT'S
BEEN IN PLACE FOR OVER 30. SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD. AND THE
ACCOUNTABILITY I KNOW THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT HEARINGS HOLDING
THE CAL STATES AND THE UCS
ACCOUNTABLE BY OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS, BUT MAYBE A LITTLE BIT
MORE PROACTIVENESS OF LETTING US
KNOW WHERE YOU'RE AT BEFORE WE
HAVE TO CALL A HEARING, TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYBODY IS
COMPLIANT. IS THERE ANY
COMMENTS, MADAM CHANCELLOR? NO,
I WILL SAY THAT, I WILL BEGIN BY
SAYING WE'RE HOLD I'M HOLDING
THE PRESIDENTS ACCOUNTABLE. THEY
DO HAVE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
WEBSITE OF HOW A SYSTEM OF
ACCOUNTABILITY, OF HOW MANY
ITEMS THEY HAVE. I'M GOING TO
FIND OUT. ASK HOW MANY,
RELATIONSHIPS THEY HAVE WITH
THEIR TRIBAL LEADERS. I'M GOING
TO ASK THEM, GIVE ME YOUR
PROGRESS REPORT. THIS IS HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO BE JUDGED AS
GOOD PRESIDENTS. THE WAY WE
JUDGE PRESIDENTS ON ACADEMICS,
ON FACILITIES, ON BUDGET. AND IN
THAT IS CAL NAGPRA IN TITLE
NINE. SO ALL OF THE PRESIDENTS
HAVE THAT, AND IT WILL BE MY
ROLE TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
AND CALL THEM ON THE CARPET WHEN
THEY HAVEN'T, AND THEN HAVE THE
CONSEQUENCES THAT HAPPEN. IF
NOT. WELL, THANK YOU FOR THAT.
AND BEFORE I MOVE TO THE èC,
JUST ONE MORE COMMENT. THE
SYSTEMWIDE POLICY THAT'S BEEN
IMPLEMENTED, WHAT COMES WITH
THAT SYSTEMWIDE POLICY AND YOU
MENTIONED, I BELIEVE, 4.7
MILLION. THAT WAS GOING TO BE
ALLOCATED. HOW IS THAT MONEY
GOING TO BE ALLOCATED. AND WILL
THAT ALSO HAVE INVOLVEMENT FROM
THE TRIBAL COMMUNITIES, RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE ALLOCATED 4.2
MILLION AND THE MONEY IS
ALLOCATED BY THE NUMBER OF ITEMS
BY THE AMOUNT. RIGHT. SO IT'S
BEING THAT'S GIVEN OUT TO ALL
THE CAMPUSES IT RUNS BETWEEN
150,000 TO 200,000 PER CAMPUS,
DEPENDING ON THE CAMPUS. AND
THEN THERE'S 550,000 FOR THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE FOR TRAINING,
FOR SALARIES, ETC. SO THAT'S
WHERE THE 4.2 MILLION YOU WANTED
TO FOLLOW UP ON THE MONEY, HOW
THE MONEY. AND WITH THAT MONEY
GOING INTO THE CAMPUSES, HOW
DOES THAT INCLUDE THE VOICES OF
THE NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY
AND THE HAWAIIAN, NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY TO BE WORKING
WITH THAT COMMITTEE? RIGHT.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE THAT
COMMITTEE THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
GET THE DOLLARS FOR, AND THEY
SHOULD BE WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THAT
COMMITTEE. OKAY, ALL RIGHT. AND
THEN IF YOU COULD FOLLOW UP WITH
MY OFFICE ON A MORE CLEAR
DIRECTION OF WHERE THAT'S GOING
TO BE GOING TO AND HOW IT
INCLUDES THE VOICES OF NATIVE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, I DEEPLY
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. YOU SEE,
SAME QUESTION. HOW DO WE HOW DO
WE BE MORE PROACTIVE IN STEMMING
THAT WE'RE NOT IN THIS PLACE?
AGAIN, THIS HAS STARTED AND THE
LAW CAME INTO PLACE 30 YEARS
AGO, BUT THIS PRACTICE HAS BEEN
GOING ON FOR TOO LONG. SO HOW DO
WE STEM THAT? HOW DO THE FIELD
SCHOOLS, HOW DO WE STOP, NATIVE
AMERICAN REMAINS FROM GETTING
INTO THE ARCHIVES, FROM THE
BEGINNING. MAY I ANSWER THAT
QUESTION? YES GO AHEAD. I'M LARA
YOU CAN GO TO THE MICROPHONE.
OKAY. CAN YOU HEAR ME? YEAH
OKAY, SO OUR POLICY STIPULATES
THAT èC WILL NOT ACCEPT
POSSESSION OR CONTROL OF HUMAN
REMAINS OR CULTURAL ITEMS,
EXCEPT WITH TWO EXCEPTIONS. ONE
IS WITH THE TRIBES UPON A
TRIBE'S REQUEST, WHICH I REALLY
CAN'T SEE HAPPENING. BUT THAT'S
ONE EXCEPTION. AND THE SECOND
EXCEPTION IS WITH CHANCELLOR
APPROVAL. BUT ALWAYS ONLY IF
IT'S TO FACILITATE REPATRIATION.
SO THOSE ARE THE ONLY TWO
CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH WE CAN
BRING IN NEW CULTURAL ITEMS AND
HUMAN REMAINS INTO THE
UNIVERSITY. AND THAT POLICY IS
IN EFFECT NOW? YES. WHEN DID IT
GO INTO EFFECT? IT WAS IN EFFECT
FROM FROM THE INTERIM POLICY WAS
IN EFFECT IN IN JANUARY OF 2020.
AND THEN NOW THE FULL POLICY
SINCE 2022. OKAY. AND THAT
POLICY GOING BACK TO THE CAL
STATE, IS THAT A POLICY THAT'S
IMPLEMENTED AT THE CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY LEVEL TOO, OR IS THAT
SOMETHING YOU'RE GOING TO BE
LOOKING AT? WE'LL BE LOOKING AT
THAT. WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
PUTTING TOGETHER THIS TOGETHER,
AND A POLICY LIKE THAT COULD BE
DRIVEN FROM FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ON A
STATEWIDE POLICY WITHOUT HAVING
TO HAVE LEGISLATION MOVING
FORWARD. IT'S SOMETHING THAT IF
THE RIGHT THING TO DO IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE HEARING, I
BELIEVE THAT WOULD BE A POLICY
THAT WOULD MOVE FORWARD, BEFORE
WE MEET AGAIN, THANK YOU FOR
THAT. AND THE QUESTION ON THE
FIELD SCHOOLS, SO THAT POLICY
IS, IS THERE SO IS THERE STILL
ONGOING, DIALOG WITH FIELD
SCHOOLS BECAUSE WE HEARD THAT
FROM TRIBAL LEADERS THAT THAT
COULD BE AN AREA WHERE, HOW
REMAINS ARE BEING UNCOVERED OF
LOVE LOVED ONES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA? WELL, THEY CAN'T
BRING THEM ON CAMPUS. SO I THINK
THAT THERE IS MORE WORK TO DO
THERE. OKAY, GLENIS, I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON
THAT AREA AND SPECIFICALLY
CONTRACTS, CONTRACTS THAT STILL
ARE ONGOING MAYBE REMAINS DON'T
END UP AT THE CAMPUS, BUT ARE WE
STILL ENGAGED IN THAT TYPE OF
ACTIVITY? TO THE BEST OF MY
KNOWLEDGE, NO. BUT I WILL SAY
THIS, THE LEVEL OF AWARENESS
AROUND REPATRIATION AND THE
DAMAGE THAT THE UNIVERSITY HAS
DONE WITH, INAPPROPRIATELY AND
WITHOUT CONSENT, CONSENT,
COLLECTING THESE ITEMS, IS
SPREAD AND HIGH LEVEL THROUGHOUT
OUR TEN CAMPUSES. AND I FEEL
CONFIDENT AND I'LL, I'LL LET
GLENNA SPEAK A LITTLE BIT MORE
TO IT. I FEEL CONFIDENT THAT, IF
OUR IF OUR CAMPUS, COMMUNITY
WOULD ENCOUNTER THAT TYPE OF
ACTIVITY, IT WOULD BE ESCALATED
TO OUR OFFICE AND WE WOULD STEP
IN AND MAKE SURE THAT WE WOULD
ADHERE TO OUR POLICY, THAT BEING
SAID, OF COURSE, WE ALWAYS KNOW
THAT THERE ARE SOMETIMES BAD
ACTORS. DEFINITELY. AND THANK
YOU FOR THE HONESTY AND MOVING
FORWARD ON THESE POLICIES. AND
CERTAINLY YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE
TRIBAL LEADERS HERE TODAY. AND,
THE AUDITOR THAT CONTINUES TO
MONITOR THESE THINGS AND THE
PROGRESS THAT TAKES PLACE, WE DO
KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN CHANGES,
RIGHT? CHANGES WITHIN, ACADEMIA
WORLD THAT COMES IN. WE GOT
INTERIMS. WE GOT SOMEONE THREE
WEEKS IN, THAT'S HERE IN FRONT
OF THE LEGISLATURE, ATTESTING TO
SOME OF THE GOODWILL. WHAT IS
DIFFERENT FROM 30 YEARS AGO, 40
YEARS AGO, 50 YEARS AGO, 170
YEARS AGO? IS THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE IS TAKING
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE TREATMENT
ON CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE IN
THIS NATION'S FIRST PEOPLE,
INCLUDING NATIVE HAWAIIANS. AND
SO WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
HOLD HEARINGS. WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE AND HEAR
VOICES OF POTENTIAL LEGISLATION
DOWN THE ROAD. AND WE'RE GOING
TO BE MONITORING WITH THE
AUDITOR, SPECIFIC REPORTS THAT
WILL COME OUT THESE TYPES OF
HEARINGS ARE ARE THINGS THAT
WILL BE PART OF THE FUTURE. SO
AGAIN, IF THERE'S AREAS THAT
YOU'RE YOU WANT TO BRING TO OUR
ATTENTION PRIOR TO A HEARING OF
HOW YOU'RE COMPLYING, BY ALL
MEANS DO IT BECAUSE, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS, AND SENATORS THAT
WERE AROUND THE TABLE, AND THOSE
ON THE AROUND THE DAIS NOW WANT
TO KNOW THESE THINGS WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT BUDGET,
CONSTRAINTS OR BUDGETS THAT MOVE
FORWARD FOR NEW BUILDINGS ON THE
CAMPUSES, ARE WE HONORING
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE? AND
I'LL LEAVE WITH THIS LAST
COMMENT THAT WAS BROUGHT UP BY
ONE OF THE TRIBAL LEADERS.
EDUCATION IS SOMETHING THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO ALL PEOPLE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND AS
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE, WE
CONTINUE TO PUSH OUR CHILDREN
AND OUR YOUNG ONES TO MOVE
FORWARD IN HIGHER EDUCATION. HOW
CAN WE TRUTHFULLY SIT THERE AND
TELL THEM TO PURSUE A HIGHER
EDUCATION HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE CAL
STATES OR THE UCS, WHEN THEY
HAVE NOT HAD HISTORIC OR EVEN
CONTEMPORARY, RESPECT FOR OUR
ANCESTORS AND ELDERS OF GETTING
THOSE REMAINS BACK. SO IT GOES
DEEPER THAN THE REPATRIATION
PROCESS. THIS GOES TO THE VERY
REASON AND THE
EDUCATION IN GENERAL IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE. SO WE
HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO TO MEND
THAT, THAT RELATIONSHIP SO THAT
WE CAN TRUTHFULLY GO OUT THERE
AND TELL OUR LOVED ONES AND OUR
YOUNG ONES TO MOVE FORWARD IN
HIGHER EDUCATION. BUT IT HAS TO
COME WITH MUTUAL RESPECT. AND
THAT WAS BROUGHT UP EARLIER, AND
THAT HAS RESONATED WITH ME AND
SHOULD RESONATE WITH THE
INSTITUTIONS HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. WITH THAT, I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION. NOW WE WILL MOVE
TO, PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU.
MR. CHAIR, MR. CHAIR, MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. PAULA. TREAT,
I'VE REPRESENTED TRIBES FOR OVER
30 YEARS, INCLUDING PECHANGA,
TEJON AND COLUSA. AND FOR THE
èC AND THE AND THE CSU MEMBERS
THAT ARE WALKING AWAY RIGHT NOW.
I JUST WANTED TO SAY, I
APPRECIATED YOUR WORDS. I'VE
BEEN HEARING THIS FOR ALMOST 30
YEARS, SO, NO, THERE'S NO TRUST,
UNFORTUNATELY, I'M A GRAD OF
BERKELEY èC CAL, ALONG WITH MY
HUSBAND, PHOEBE HEARST, IS THE
WORST OF THE WORST. AND YOU
ACTUALLY NEED TO HAVE MORE
OVERSIGHT GOING INTO THOSE
MUSEUMS. SO THEY DON'T THINK
THESE THINGS BELONG TO THEM. THE
HEAD OF EACH OF THESE MUSEUMS
CONSIDER THEM TO BE THEIR ITEMS,
AND THAT CHANGE HAS TO HAPPEN,
AND IT HAS TO HAPPEN NOW. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT? STATE
YOUR NAME. ANY OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT? THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING ON PROGRESS
CALIFORNIA IS MAKING ON THIS
REALLY IMPORTANT TOPIC. MY NAME
IS TONY OBERLY. I'M A ALUM OF UC
AND CSU. TODAY I SPEAK TO YOU AS
PRESIDENT OF THE SOCIETY FOR
CALIFORNIA ARCHEOLOGY. THE
SOCIETY IS A NONPROFIT
ESTABLISHED IN 1966 WITH 1300
MEMBERS, DEDICATED TO THE
HERITAGE OF CALIFORNIA. FOR
BACKGROUND, WE FURNISHED A HARD
COPY STATEMENT ABOUT THE
SOCIETY'S MEMBERSHIP, ACTIVITIES
AND HISTORY TO THE SERGEANT.
WE'VE GOT ABOUT 25 COPIES OF
THOSE FOR WHOEVER WOULD LIKE
ONE. LET ME BE CLEAR THE SCA
SUPPORTS FULL, TIMELY AND LEGAL
COMPLIANCE WITH NAGPRA AND WE
MAINTAIN THAT FULL COMPLIANCE
WITH NAGPRA IS A BASIC HUMAN
RIGHT. IT'S A RIGHTS ISSUE THAT
IS LONG OVERDUE TO BE COMPLETED.
HOWEVER, THE RECENT
INTERPRETATION OF THE POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES NOW BEING
IMPLEMENTED AT CSU CAMPUSES
RANGE BEYOND NAGPRA. AT PRESENT,
ADMINISTRATORS ARE STOPPING
PRACTICAL ARCHEOLOGICAL TRAINING
FOR TRIBAL MEMBERS AND
ARCHEOLOGISTS ALIKE.
UNIVERSITIES ARE PROHIBITING
FIELD SCHOOLS AND LAB CLASSES,
EVEN WITH NON NAGPRA
ARCHEOLOGICAL MATERIAL. THERE
ARE BROAD UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES TO THIS LACK OF
PRACTICAL TRAINING. THE DEMAND
FOR TRAINED ARCHEOLOGISTS DUE TO
ENVIRONMENTAL COMPLIANCE LAWS
AND TRAINED ARCHEOLOGISTS AND
TRIBAL MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA HAS
NEVER BEEN GREATER. OUR SUMMARY
STATEMENT THAT WE'VE FURNISHED
PROVIDES REFERENCE TO A
WORKFORCE STUDY COMPLETED IN
2022, THAT SHOWS UNIVERSITIES
WERE ONLY CREATING 60% OF THE
ARCHEOLOGICAL WORKFORCE NEEDED
OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS. THIS
STUDY WAS DONE BEFORE THE
INTERIM POLICY BY CSU WAS
ADOPTED. THERE IS A BETTER WAY
FORWARD WHERE TECHNICAL, ETHICAL
AND LEGAL TRAINING CAN BE DONE
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH TRIBES,
UNIVERSITIES AND STUDENTS TO
REITERATE, THE SOCIETY SUPPORTS
FULL, TIMELY AND LEGAL
COMPLIANCE WITH NAGPRA, BUT THE
CSU MUST FULFILL ITS MISSION TO
TRAIN THE STATE'S WORKFORCE AS
WELL. WE'RE HERE TODAY IN THE
SPIRIT OF PARTNERSHIP, TO ENGAGE
WITH TRIBES, THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND UNIVERSITY
POLICYMAKERS, AND WORKING TOWARD
ACCOMPLISHING BOTH THE LONG
OVERDUE IMPLEMENTATION OF NAGPRA
AND THE CONTINUED EDUCATION OF
OUR STATE'S FUTURE ARCHEOLOGICAL
WORKFORCE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS. HI, I'M ANNE
MARIE MIDDEN, A PAST BOARD
MEMBER OF THE SOCIETY FOR
CALIFORNIA ARCHEOLOGY, BUT MY
COMMENTS ARE MY OWN. I NOTICED
THAT MR. PARK'S SUMMARY OF THE
AUDIT IDENTIFIES MANY PROBLEMS
AT THE CALIFORNIA ARCHEOLOGICAL
COMMUNITY. HAS LONG KNOWN ABOUT,
BUT WE HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO
ADDRESS THESE DUE TO LACK OF
SUPPORT FROM THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND CAMPUS PRESIDENTS.
AND I APPRECIATE CHANCELLOR
GARCIA TAKING THIS SERIOUSLY. I
THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE EVERYBODY
IN THIS ROOM CAN AGREE THAT
FUNDING IS AN ISSUE. LAST YEAR,
MR. RAMOS WAS ABLE TO PASS AB
389 TO GET THE CHANCELLOR'S
ATTENTION TO THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE, AND I FULLY SUPPORT THAT
EFFORT. MR. HITCHCOCK'S SUMMARY
TODAY OF AB 389 LEAVES OUT THE
PART THAT FORBIDS CSU PROFESSORS
FROM USING ANY NATIVE AMERICAN
CULTURAL MATERIALS FOR TEACHING
UC AND CSU PROFESSORS HAVE
HISTORICALLY USED STUDENT
INTERNS TO MANAGE THESE
COLLECTIONS, AND THAT HAS BEEN
DONE AS PART OF THE PROFESSOR'S
ACADEMIC LOAD, AND NOT USUALLY
ANY EXTRA FUNDING FROM THE
CAMPUS. THAT'S HOW THESE
COLLECTIONS HAVE BEEN MANAGED
OVER THE YEARS. I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
CONCUR WITH SAN MANUEL. CHAIR
VALBUENA'S POINTS THAT
ANTHROPOLOGY DEPARTMENTS
SHOULDN'T BE EXPECTED TO ABSORB
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR COMPLYING
WITH AB 389, AND CHAIRMAN POTTER
COMMENTED THAT IT SHOULDN'T COME
DOWN TO MONEY TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE, BUT UNFORTUNATELY, THAT'S
WHERE WE ARE. AGAIN, THE LACK OF
FUNDING OVER THE PAST 30 YEARS
IS WHY WE THIS CONTINUES TO BE A
PROBLEM, BUT I'D LIKE TO COME
WITH A HELPFUL SOLUTION. IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT STUDENTS HAVE A
ROLE HERE IN SOLVING THIS
PROBLEM, AS COUNCILMEMBER CHACON
POINTED OUT, COLLECTIONS NEED TO
BE REVIEWED IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THEY GO TO THE RIGHT TRIBE.
STUDENTS CAN HELP WITH THIS
PROCESS AND HELPING PROFESSORS
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
UNFORTUNATELY, THREE AB 389
PROHIBITION ON USING COLLECTIONS
FOR TEACHING INADVERTENTLY
HAMSTRINGS THIS EFFORT BY
ELIMINATING A POOL OF LABOR TO
MANAGE COLLECTIONS, PLEASE
CONSIDER AN AMENDMENT TO THIS
TEACHING RESTRICTION AS A MEANS
TO PARTIALLY ADDRESS THAT
SHORTFALL. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
POINT OUT DURING THE
CONVERSATION WRAP IT UP, PLEASE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA AND RIVAS
ASKED ABOUT ANY TRAINING THAT
THAT CAN EDUCATE THESE PEOPLE.
ANYBODY CAN CALL THEMSELVES AN
ARCHEOLOGIST. ANYBODY CAN GO OUT
AND DIG OUT, DIG UP A SITE AND
CALL IT ARCHEOLOGY. BUT IT'S NOT
IF IT'S NOT DONE ETHICALLY AND
IN CONSULTATION WITH TRIBES,
IT'S NOT ARCHEOLOGY. A DECADE
AND A HALF AGO, I TRIED TO GET A
LAW PASSED FOR, REGISTRATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR ARCHEOLOGY THAT
FAILED. IF YOU WANT TO TAKE THIS
SERIOUSLY, THE SOCIETY FOR
CALIFORNIA ARCHEOLOGY IS HERE TO
HELP. CAN YOU PLEASE WRAP IT UP?
AND I BELIEVE WE ARE TAKING IT
SERIOUSLY. NEXT COMMENT. WE DO
HAVE ANOTHER COMMITTEE THAT'S
COMING IN HERE AT ABOUT 130 FOR
BUDGET. SO WE WANT TO, KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS MOVING. JIMMY SUNNY, I
WANTED TO INCLUDE ARTICLE 11,
SECTION TWO OF THE UN
DECLARATION ON THE RIGHTS OF
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES THAT STATES
SHALL PROVIDE REDRESS THROUGH
EFFECTIVE MECHANISMS, WHICH MAY
INCLUDE RESTITUTION DEVELOPED
INTO CONJUNCTION WITH INDIGENOUS
PEOPLES WITH RESPECT TO THEIR
CULTURAL, INTELLECTUAL,
RELIGIOUS AND SPIRITUAL
PROPERTY, TAKEN WITHOUT THEIR
FREE PRIOR AND INFORMED CONSENT
OR IN VIOLATION OF LAWS,
TRADITIONS AND CUSTOMS WHICH HAS
BEEN HAPPENING. ALTHOUGH IT'S
BEEN 30 YEARS, HAVING LAWS AND
POLICIES IN PLACE, IT WAS 60
YEARS AGO THAT OUR ANCESTRAL
REMAINS WERE DUG UP IN MY
ANCESTRAL TERRITORY OF ACHUMAWI
AND PIT RIVER TERRITORY FOR
RESEARCH PURPOSES, TO EXAMINE
OUR VOICE BOXES WHILE WE HAD
LIVING FLUENT LANGUAGE SPEAKERS,
AND THIS WAS THROUGH UC DAVIS,
INDIGENOUS JUSTICE AND THE PIT
RIVER TRIBE ARE AFFILIATES OF
THE INTERNATIONAL INDIAN TREATY
COUNCIL THAT WORKS ON
INTERNATIONAL, INDEED,
INDIGENOUS RIGHTS VIOLATIONS AND
PROTECTIONS AND I HAVE WORKED
FOR IITC SINCE 2008 AS THE
TRIBAL AND COMMUNITY LIAISON FOR
CALIFORNIA. THE LACK OF A CLEAR,
PARTICIPATORY PROCESS FOR
REPATRIATION AND RETURN OF
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES, SACRED ITEMS
AND OR REMAINS THAT WERE
COLLECTED IN THE PROCESS OF
COLONIZATION ARE ACTIVE
INTERNATIONAL CONCERNS OF
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES AROUND THE
WORLD. THE SO-CALLED COLLECTIONS
OF HUMAN REMAINS HELD IN
CALIFORNIA UNIVERSITIES ARE WELL
KNOWN AND A SOURCE OF ONGOING
TRAUMA FOR CALIFORNIA'S
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES. WE CALL FOR
CONSISTENCY FOR THE CREATION OF
REPATRIATION PROTOCOLS AND
MECHANISMS BASED ON INDIGENOUS
PEOPLES OWN LAWS AND PRIORITIES,
AS WELL AS THE RECOGNIZED RIGHT
OF FREE, PRIOR AND INFORMED
CONSENT. WE ARE COMMITTED TO
HOLD GOVERNMENTS, STATE AND
FEDERAL MUSEUMS, UNIVERSITIES,
BUSINESS, PRIVATE COLLECTORS AND
OTHERS CURRENTLY HOLDING OUR
ITEMS ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
HUMAN RIGHTS OBLIGATIONS IN THIS
REGARD, WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
INTERNATIONAL REPATRIATION
MECHANISMS DEVELOPED WITH THE
FULL PARTICIPATION OF THE
IMPACTED INDIGENOUS PEOPLES,
REPATRIATION EFFORTS ON THE
LOCAL, STATE, NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL LEVELS BY
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES IN
CALIFORNIA, WHICH IS NECESSARY.
I HAVE FURTHER COMMENTS, BUT I
WILL SUBMIT BY WRITING. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. LET'S KEEP OUR
COMMENTS. WE DO GOT TO BE OUT OF
HERE BY 130, AND THEN I'LL HAVE
TO CUT IT OFF. I'M FROM, ROUND
VALLEY INDIAN RESERVATION. I AM
A DESCENDANT OF THE ANCESTRAL
PEOPLE OF THE YUKI PEOPLE. THE
FIRST PEOPLE OF THE NATION. AND,
I JUST WANT TO SAY, AS WE TRY TO
FIGURE EVERYTHING OUT, THEY
CONTINUE TO DIG MY PEOPLE UP.
TWO WEEKS AGO, THEY DUG UP A
VILLAGE WHILE THEY WAS DOING
ROADSIDES. YOU KNOW. SO AND AS
THEY WERE DOING THE TRAILS AND
TRYING TO DO TRAILS, THEY DIG UP
SOME MORE PEOPLE. SO THIS IS
CONTINUING TO HAPPEN TODAY. SO,
LIKE YOU SAID, LET'S MAKE A
DECISION. LET'S PROTECT OUR
ANCESTORS AND THE PEOPLE, MY
PEOPLE THAT ARE DOWN IN
BERKELEY, THAT'S BEEN THERE FROM
THE FIRST TIME OF HASTINGS
FAMILY MASSACRING US AND TO
TAKING OUR REMAINS THERE.
SOMETHING NEEDS TO HAPPEN. I'M
JUST COMING AS AN INDIVIDUAL
INDIGENOUS WOMAN FROM ROUND
VALLEY, A YUKI DESCENDANT, AND
KNOWING THAT SOMETHING HAS TO BE
DONE BECAUSE IT CONTINUES TODAY.
THANK YOU. HELLO, MY NAME IS
MICHIGAN REDHAWK. THAT WAS MY
MOM. ANYWAYS, I COME UP HERE TO,
SAY TO THE UNIVERSITIES THAT,
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT, OKAY, IS FINE
AND DANDY, BUT WE NEED TO LOOK
TO A CULTURAL, LEADERS NOT SO
MUCH AS TRIBAL GOVERNMENT
BECAUSE CULTURAL LEADERS HAS
MORE OF, ASPECT OF WHERE ALL
THESE, ARTIFACTS NEED TO GO TO
THE FAMILIES. THE CULTURES, THEY
KEEP IT UP TO THE, TO THE DAY
AND, YEAH, NOT SO MUCH AS
GOVERNMENT. YOU KNOW, DON'T LOOK
TOWARDS THE GOVERNMENT, TRY TO
DO THE HOMEWORK AND LOOK FOR
THE, CULTURAL LEADERS. AND
THAT'S WHERE THEY NEED TO GO TO.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS. THIS WILL
BE THE LAST. LAST, BUT NOT
LEAST. HI, I'M LAURA MIRANDA, I
AM I SIT ON THE UC SYSTEM WIDE
REPATRIATION COMMITTEE. I'M ALSO
THE FORMER CHAIR OF THE NATIVE
AMERICAN HERITAGE COMMISSION, I
JUST WANTED TO COMMENT ON THE
PRACTICE OF ARCHEOLOGY. I'M NOT
SURE IF FOLKS KNOW, BUT THERE
ARE NOT, LEGAL ETHICAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR ARCHEOLOGISTS
OR A LICENSING PROCEDURE FOR
ARCHEOLOGISTS, AS THERE ARE FOR
OTHER PROFESSIONS. SO THIS IS A
GAP IN HOW ARCHEOLOGY GETS DONE
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL COMPLIANCE OR
IN ANY OTHER REALM. THERE AREN'T
STANDARDS AND GUIDANCE ON A
STATE LEVEL, AND IT'S
DESPERATELY NEEDED. OTHERWISE
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
THESE ISSUES. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE PRESENTERS AND THE PANELS
THAT, IN THE INPUT THAT HAS BEEN
THERE AND FROM THE CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY, LEVEL FROM THE
CHANCELLOR TO THE UC'S TO THE
AUDITOR TO THE TRIBAL LEADERS
AND ADDING THEIR VOICES TO THESE
AREAS, AS WELL AS THE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE. WE THANK YOU FOR ALL
THESE THINGS. AND BE ASSURED
THERE WILL BE MORE OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS, TAKING PLACE AROUND
THIS TOPIC. THANK YOU. THIS
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.